digital marketing is one of the fastest
growing fields in the modern world it's
a vital tool for businesses of all sizes
from small startups to Global
corporations it uses online and digital
channels to promote products or Services
it includes a variety of channels such
as search engine optimization social
media marketing content marketing email
marketing and website design the primary
goal of distance marketing is to reach
potential customers with they are and to
create awareness about your brand and
products but why should you learn
digital marketing digital marketing is
an essential skill for any business
regardless of industry or size it's a
cost effective and efficient way to
reach customers and promote products or
services with the rise of online
shopping and social media digital
marketing has become even more integral
part of modern marketing strategies so
whether you are looking to grow your
career start your own business or simply
stay relevant in a changing Market
digital marketing is a vital tool to
have in your toolbox so why not start
learning today so if you want to become
a digital marketing Maestro we have an
exclusive opportunity to blow your mind
introducing simple lens post graduate
program in digital marketing that will
transform you into Master of the digital
realm this comprehensive program crafted
by industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
this comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
from SEO and social media marketing to
content creation and analytics all
crucial aspects are covered with
hands-on experience using industry
standard tools real world projects and
personalized mentorship you will Unleash
Your Potential and elevate your digital
marketing proficiency enroll in a
postgraduate program in digital
marketing become a game changer in
online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below do you know that 75 percent of
Searchers never click past the first
page of the search results
moreover as per the research carried out
by backlinko only 0.78 percent of
Searchers click results from the second
page of the search results
if you notice this is a negligible
number showing minimum or no possibility
that the user will click on your website
that appears on the second page that is
why you need to appear on the first page
of the search result and rank high and
this makes search engine optimization
also known as SEO one of the most
crucial aspects of digital marketing a
very warm welcome to this new video by
simply learn in which you will get a
brief overview of search engine
optimization
by the end of this video you will have a
better understanding of digital
marketing and its components we will
have a brief look into what is SEO and
its importance next we will understand
how search engines work and what are
different types of SEO
moving forward we will discuss essential
tools required for best search engine
optimization practices and finally we
will end the session by understanding
case study job scenarios and what the
future holds for is you
before we begin consider subscribing to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon if you
love our videos
so without any further Ado let's first
briefly understand what digital
marketing is
traditional marketing strategies like
newspaper advertisements pamphlet
promotion billboard advertisements are
slowly overtaken by digital marketing
promoting products and services on the
online platform using digital technology
is called digital marketing
now you must be thinking for sure that
what are digital marketing methods
through which one can promote their
products and services on the internet
let me tell you there are several
components of digital marketing let us
have a quick look at each one of them
first we have search engine optimization
also known as SEO
with search engine optimization one can
get relevant traffic through search
results with the help of search engines
we will understand this more clearly as
we move ahead with this video next we
have social media marketing also known
as smm the promotion of products and
services using social media platform is
called social media marketing some
social media platforms include YouTube
Twitter
Facebook Instagram
Etc
moving towards email marketing it is one
of the important components of digital
marketing
promoting products and services through
emails is called email marketing
now let's know what afflet marketing is
when one business pays to another
business or influencer to promote its
products and services it is known as
affiliate marketing
getting to know about mobile marketing
mobile marketing promotes products and
services using devices like phones
tablets or mobile devices
some mobile marketing strategies include
SMS marketing in-app advertisements
location-based advertisements
Etc
content marketing content marketing is
creating and distributing high quality
content to attract relevant traffic
content can be of any form like a Blog
article video or podcast
and the last one search engine marketing
also known as sem
search engine marketing is a practice of
advertising the content such that it
appears at the top of the search results
page it is also known as pay-per-click
we will discuss all the components in
detail in the upcoming videos in this
video let's focus on search engine
optimization
mid-1990 was the initial phase when
content providers started optimizing
their websites for search engines by
1997 content providers started
manipulating search engines to get
higher rankings so algorithm for search
engines regularly updated to lower the
risk of manipulation
in 2001 there were rumors that SEO would
no longer be in action and would be
replaced by search engine marketing well
this never happened in these 20 years
various growing SEO techniques have
improved the web presence of websites
and will continue for many more years so
let's understand what is search engine
optimization the practice of getting
traffic organically through the search
results with the help of search engine
is called search engine optimization
although being one of the most important
components of digital marketing SEO has
had submits floating around it let's
have a look at them
only famous Brands can rank high in
search results yes it is a myth with
good SEO techniques anyone can rank high
in search results
competitors are way too strong so it
isn't easy to rank high in this case
this can be a bit difficult but it can
be easily overcome with good competitor
analysis skills and one can attain High
ranks and search results
a website with more pages can rank high
well it depends on the quality of
content page has if the content is high
quality even the website with fewer
Pages can rank high
to rank there is a need to spend a lot
of money one can rank high with some
strategies and techniques without
spending a penny now that we have
debunked the myths around SEO let's
understand why SEO is important
SEO increases the popularity of your
brand product or Services among the
audience thereby increasing the chances
of conversion of need to customer
traffic obtained organically is more
consistent once you are aware of SEO
strategies and start gaining visibility
in search results your site will gain
constant traffic that will keep
increasing with time
with SEO one can reach a large audience
to promote products and services
businesses can acquire audiences from
both the national and international
levels
SEO builds trust among the audience for
instance if your web page is available
on Google search results the audience
finds it worthy of trust because of its
online presence
your competitors are doing it then you
should also do it this could be a
serious note if your competitors are
doing this to rank high and gain
visibility you must also do it or remain
back in the race
there are three types of SEO that you
can Implement for the growth of your
business before moving towards it it is
necessary to understand how search
engines work let's understand it with
the help of an analogy
Susan started a business of handmade
toys
she failed to gain enough customers
using traditional marketing methods like
newspaper advertisements and banners so
she thought of putting the business
online thereby creating a website
the website was completely optimized for
search engines and was soon visible on
the search result pages
the website started acquiring the
traffic which ultimately became her
customers
the sales were boosted to an unexpected
level and the revenue has increased
exponentially
a good decision brought youth success to
Susan's business
Susan was thrilled with joy when a
thought struck across her mind
how was search engines able to find her
website
so search engines can be Google Bing
Yandex
Etc which work on three basic steps
that are
crawling indexing and ranking
first we will understand crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send the Web spiders also
known as crawlers or robots a search
engine Bots to discover new content or
any updated content content can be an
image web page video or anything else
present on the web this process is known
as crawling
soon after the discovery of content
Web spiders start storing the URL of the
content into the search index and this
process is known as indexing once the
content is indexed it appears in the
search results for the relevant searches
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant search results are taken
from the index and displayed from most
relevant to least relevant on the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking
now as you are familiar with the working
of search engines let's dive deep into
types of SEO
that is
on page SEO
of page SEO
and Technical SEO
we will start with on-page SEO
optimizing a web page to gain visibility
and rank high in search results and get
relevant traffic is known as on page SEO
some on-page SEO techniques include
optimizing content
adding attractive titles and meta
descriptions
adding internal and external links on
the web page
adding SSL certifications for the
website
optimizing images for search results
Etc
next is off-page SEO actions taken
outside the web page or a website to
rank high in search results is known as
off-page SEO
some off-page SEO techniques include
building backlinks
blogging and submitting articles on
other websites
promoting content on social media Etc
and the last one is technical SEO
optimizing technical elements of a
website such that search engines can
easily crawl and index the web pages is
known as technical SEO
some technical optimizations include
reducing the page loading speed of a web
page to a minimum
submitting sitemaps to search engines
have organized website structure as it
informs search engines about the
essential pages of the website
adding redirections for the deleted URLs
or temporarily moving urls
identify duplicate content and replace
it with unique content greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders from Simply
learn and today we're going to talk
about keyword research so what are we
going to talk about when we talk about
keyword research we're going to talk
about why we would do keyword research
for SEO we're going to talk about the
types of keywords that we need to
research we're going to talk about some
methodologies best practices on how to
do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipes so she's
Unsure how these blogs are going to
drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords he is maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the queue words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea of why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they can have
low search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very Broad are
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that is in
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short more tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three key
words in a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two keywords in a phrase
or shorter so shortcut keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tail keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short toe key word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also gonna have
lower search volume but with longer tail
keywords the key word is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short tell keywords and long
tail keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus long tail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the key
word is Broad in nature so pizza recipes
is a short tail keyword that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
3 three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tip key word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than thick keywords
in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted Pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically a about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the key word you likely would want to
use versus just pizza recipes so let's
look at an example between a short tail
keyword and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's keyboard Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
for this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
gonna click get results and and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is 33 100
for pizza recipe so note that pizza
recipe and pizza recipes are closely
related keywords and so what Google does
is they consider that a close variance
so meaning if somebody ties a piece of
recipe then they're also in Google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here I
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then I can see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then and for the
long tail keyword I can see homemade
pizza dough recipe again close variants
homemade pizza dough recipes I can see
over the past 12 months with the search
volume is for this on average it's 2400
but I could see here in December the
volume went up to 3 600 but for example
in May it was 1900. so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average is about 2400. so shorter
tail a lot of more volume longer tail
not as much volume but nonetheless there
is volume here and so these are the
differences between a short tail and a
longer tail and so well Google's Keyword
Planner also does is allow us to get a
sense of what the competition is and so
here I can see the competition is low
for both of these keywords fair enough
so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know well for ranked on page one of
Google even in the top spot we can
expect about 2400 search queries for
that keyword now whether you get all
2400 clicks for that keyword remains to
be seen chances are you're not going to
get all 2400 you're going to get a
Lion's Share of those clicks but you're
going to at least get some volume on it
so even the longer take keywords have a
lot of Promise because there is some
search volume here for this keyword how
to do a proper keyword research so we
looked at Google's Keyword Planner tool
and Google ads and we typed in two
keywords and we were able to get a sense
of what the average volume is so we
definitely want to choose keywords based
on the following factors we want to
choose it based on search volume search
volume is a good indicator of the
potential traffic we can obtain so again
for the keyword homemade pizza dough
recipe we know that it averages 2400 a
month in search volume and again we may
not get all 2400 but we're going to get
a line share of that we also need to
look at competition and so Google's
Keyword Planner gives us a high medium
or low in terms of the competition but
if you're somebody who wants to get a
better sense of what the competition is
and you should because competition is a
key component in choosing keywords and
so what I want to do is get a sense of
how many people are actually optimizing
for that keyword so Google's Keyword
Planner tool is going to give me a low
medium high really what I want to do is
get a better sense of that numerically
so what I can do is go into Google
search and I could type in pizza recipes
and I could see there's about one
billion results that's a lot of results
however that means that every potential
web page out there on the internet that
mentions pizza recipes is going to be
included in this number here and so I
want to get a better sense of who's
optimizing for pizza recipes so I'm
gonna put in the all entitle syntax and
so what that is going to ask Google to
do is tell me all the websites that have
pizza recipes the keyword pizza recipes
in the title tag so if I do all entitled
colon space then pizza recipes my result
drops down to 336 000. so what that
tells me is that there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
Enter key I'm gonna get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because ever every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2160 different results so here I can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites web pages that have that keyword
in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme team first so the theme for us in
this exercise is pizza recipes and so
that's our theme so we chose the keyword
pizza recipes so the close variance here
is pizza recipe what was the volume well
we know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm gonna put two thousand one
hundred and sixty so now I have an idea
of what kind of volume and what kind of
comp competition I have now you want to
do this for a number of different
keywords and when you do it for a number
of keywords what you do want to do is
obviously choose a relevant keyword that
has high volume and low competition so
another way of saying it is the volume
or ratio of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if I make
that a percentage I can see it's 0.35
percent is the ratio between volume of
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tier keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for number keywords and examine the
volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevant let's say you want
to choose keywords that are very
relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so if somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or season out so for example if I saw a
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza rest recipes during maybe the
summer months versus the winter months
so pay attention to seasonality it will
affect search volume so competition
based on our example it's one of the
most important key metrics you don't
want to choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always ways relevancy
always trumps ratio so always go with a
key word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 and Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples a commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you know don't be afraid
to use some of these keywords as part of
your longer tail keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary and search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I could see healthy
diet plan key word I'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900 and then some of
my secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my key word what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume the competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
you want to be able to find your
keywords use the tools available to you
and get a sense of what the volume is
what the competition is look at the
ratio between the volume and competition
and then based on the content choose
that primary keyword and then again
based on the keyword you chose choose
some secondary keywords as well because
you want to be found for not just one
keyword but multiple keywords okay let's
look at some alternative suggestions to
keyword research so for doing keyword
research we want to take into account
LSI keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keyword it's an LSI stands for
latent semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focus in on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet
and Google search all I need to do is
scroll to the bottom of the page and I
can see searches related to healthy diet
so healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other other suggestions here so
they're saying low-fat diet veganism
gluten-free diet so there's lots of
different suggestions right in Google
search bar so all of these are LSI
related keywords so if you're optimizing
a page for a healthy diet then you could
choose low-fat diet as a secondary
keyword you can use gluten-free diet as
a secondary keyword it really depends on
what the content is but you always want
to support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so so that
will allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for a feature snippet for
example maybe you know healthy diet
recipes if I type that in you can see
here there's a featured snippet so if
I'm talking about recipes that's a key
word I may want to use and if I use that
then Google has an opportunity to see
what my content's about and place my
information at the top in this featured
snippet you can also again see what some
of the questions are being asked what
males are good for weight loss what is a
good healthy diet plan all of these can
be keyword phrases that you can use so
the answers are right here in Google so
Cora is a great platform because core is
a platform that people go and ask
questions in a community response with
answer or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye is a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing core so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If I scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for man healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your Prime me a keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on quora so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google's going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google is going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for foreign Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own Advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the paragraph of Wikipedia
that has many relevant keywords or we
could take a look at keywords from the
Wikipedia content section so we can also
see additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further in the
first paragraph you go no further than
the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags in
the serp so you can also do that as well
so if I type in healthy diet Wikipedia
and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular it were so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keyword words that
we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and that theme of
keywords is relevant to a specific page
of a website then we have a better
opportunity to rank so in other words
why do we have to Target just one
keyword when we can Target many so keep
in mind you know LSI keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for Content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is SEO how does SEO
work intro to SEO what are the basics of
SEO all of those are related to the
chord theme what is SEO another cluster
of keywords for example could be SEO
techniques SEO best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page SEO
techniques Etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
like a theme of keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword Moz if
I go to keyword the keyword Explorer to
a Moz and just type in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see Moz Moz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself introducing
simply lens postgraduate program in
digital marketing that will transform
you into Master of the digital realm
this comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
enroll in a postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below today we're going to take a look
at some of the best tools out there on
the market to help you do your job
better so let's start with the keyword
research so with keyword research tools
you can do your job a lot more
efficiently find finding the right
relevant keywords I mean that's really
key to SEO is finding keywords that are
relevant to your business product or
service that you want to rank for so you
want to be able to choose keywords with
high search volume and low competition
so where do you get those numbers you
get those from certain tools you also
want to get forecasts for certain
targeted keywords you want to be able to
generate a list of latent semantic
indexing type keywords keywords close to
the keyword you're trying to Target you
want to be able to select primary and
secondary keywords wisely so having a
list of keywords or certain data points
will help you do that and you want to be
able to identify the keywords that your
competitors are also ranking for so good
keyword research tool will help you do
all of those things so what are some of
the tools out there well look no further
than some of the free ones that Google
offers like Google Trends so Google
Trends is a good tool that you can lean
on if so if we look at Google Trends all
you need to do is trends.google.com you
can type type in a keyword I can look at
the volume or interest of that keyword
over time here I'm looking at football
versus American football and I could see
how it's trending then I could see you
know how it Trends in specific regions
of say the United States as my market I
can also look at other related queries
similar to football or American football
and so Google Trends is a good tool
helps you look at the volume helps you
look at what specific regions helped you
look at other keywords you know if you
want you could simply just do a keyword
search or you can actually just see
what's trending just by looking at the
latest stories and insights so we could
see International women's day you know
started to pick up steam it's picking up
more steam Etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to Trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword Planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google ads
account so if we go into Google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need a Keyword Planner but when you're
in Keyword Planner you can find new
keywords so if I type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average month and volume and the great
thing here is I can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing I could see what the
trend is over time I could see what the
competition is I could see you know if
I'm going to bid on this keyword I can
see what the bidding range is so more
important I could see the volume and I
can see the competition here's my volume
for this keyword over the last 12 months
on average and here's my competition so
Google's Keyword Planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords why wisely now there
are other tools out there that are paid
that help you look for Relevant keywords
like semrush or keyword finder that's a
freemium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool I use that's not listed here is Moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what Moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information I
need including competitive information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools moz's freemium summer paint some
are free there's plenty of tools out
there but these are the ones I would
recommend for keyword research now let's
turn our attention to technical SEO so
for technical SEO you're going to need
to use some tools there's no getting
around that because you want to be able
to monitor how your website is performed
foreign I mean is it loading slow for
example does it have a lot of uh issues
with the website in terms of server-side
rendering for example or server response
time what about four or fours and
redirects so you want to be able to
gather a lot of the technical
information that could Aid or prohibit
your site from ranking so you want to be
able to also you know look at what the
Bots are saying and how they're viewing
your website so if Google goes to crawl
your site are they experiencing you know
a slow server response time were they
experiencing Pages not found you also
want to see if you have a site map you
know what's the site map are these Bots
crawling your site or getting the pages
from assignment again you want to be
able to lean on some of these tools to
help you fix errors that you may
encounter like meta tags or four fours
or canonicals so you need a good tool to
help you manage all that and so I'm
going to go back to Moz starting out so
if we go back to Moz Moz is a good tool
it's an online one it's a great SEO
platform so if I go to Moz and I log
into an account I can just go to site
crawl and so what Moz is going to do
it's gonna give me a lot of information
about how Moz is bot is seeing my site
okay so if I go to the site crawl I can
look at all the particular critical uh
issues that have experienced so I could
see four four errors okay reiter X
related to that I could see Meta
descriptions missing meta descriptions
duplicate content so there's a lot of
different issues that Moz is detecting
for this particular site and the great
thing about Moz and this is why I use
mods as my SEO platform I don't work for
mods I've just used them a long time is
if you do have issues then they give you
ways to fix it the how to fix it section
so if I see missing description here if
I just click on review and get a more
in-depth analysis as to what the issues
are here but I can also click on the why
and how to fix okay and they're going to
give you some information about how this
is impacting SEO and what you could do
to fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues I have I have
you know 142 total metadata issues I
have 10 title tag two Longs I have 122
missing meta descriptions so they lay it
out nicely here up the top so you can
kind of get a sense of what to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you can see if I click on content
issues I have some duplicate content
that Moz is recognizing or missing or
valid H tags so Moz does a really really
great job playing all all the issues out
for you to recognize okay there's
another tool that I like to use called
screaming frog it's a pay tool so if we
go look here great thing I like about a
screaming frog it will crawl your site
and it will give view some list of
issues just like Mazdas of you know what
it sees in your site is experiencing
four fours broken links are there any
redirects that's picking up duplicate
content site Maps you know their
JavaScript issues how is it see the site
architecture so it really does take a
deep look at everything that could
impact your website from ranking okay
there are other tools out there like you
know deep crawl or woo rank they're both
paid and so pay tools are really great
as well it just depends on you know your
pricing structure what your budget is
but really when it comes to all these
tools they all more or less overlap and
do the same thing you just need to rely
on one of them to make sure that you're
able to see what the issues are now
there's nothing wrong with using two of
them just as a second reference point to
see if both are picking up the same
issue and of course I like to use search
console I always like to lean on Google
search console because that is the so
source so search console will also you
know give you some feedback on how
Google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a site map so that's a
key to SEO you want Google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just signify to Google where your
sitemap is located so the search console
does a lot more gives you some HTML
improvements gives you some backlinking
uh and then the process of updating the
search console user interface so there's
a new user interface that you can use
with Google search console the great
thing is it's free and it has everything
you need to know about your website and
how it's affected by SEO organic search
the only thing you have to do with
search console is verify the site but
once you verify it it has all the
relevant information you need so let's
talk about backlink monitoring and
Analysis okay so this is related to to
off-page SEO so you're going to need a
good tool to help you monitor your
website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good at relevant sites or anything
in between so you need to really be able
to analyze what the good links are what
the bat links are pointing to your
website you want to identify and disavow
Port backlinks okay so you want to be
able to recognize which sites are
linking to yours that's actually hurting
you from an SEO standpoint and you want
to be able to do something about that
okay you want to measure citation flow
and Trust flow you want to check the
ratio of Link distribution in terms of
is it internal or external or you know
what kind of sites are linking to my
side are they you know social related
are they pure content related and then
you want to be able to track the number
of do follow and no followings you know
how many Banks pointing to our site are
actually telling Google and other Bots
not to follow the link or how many are
actually allowing the Bots to follow
that link if a bot follows a link it's
going to pass what we call link juice so
you're going to get credit for the
backlink if it's a no follow you're not
going to get credit for the backlink and
we want to be able to measure that and
so we want to have tools that will help
us do that so what are some of those
tools well hrefs is a good tool it's a
pain tool Majestic is a freemium tool
Moz again Moz is the tool I use sem rush
and then again I gotta mention Google
search console so let's take a look at
some of these tools in terms of backlink
monitoring and Analysis so let's start
with Google search console again it's
free you just have to verify your site
and so if I go to Google Search console
I can look at links and I can see what
external links I have pointing to my
site okay so I could see I have 17 000
in this example pointing to the home
page of this particular site okay so if
I click on that I can see all the the
top sites pointing to my home page now
from an off-page SEO perspective do you
want every backlink or external link
pointing to your home page no so you
want links pointing to internal pages so
you want to be able to measure that so I
could see with the top linking sites are
and I could also see what the anchor
text is so do I want my anchor text
always to be my brand name no I want it
to be you know keyword we're trying to
Target search console also gives you
some internal links okay what are the
top link Pages for internal link so from
an SEO perspective you always want to
have a nice balance of internal linking
so this report helps you understand what
pages are getting links and are the
links evenly spread so this is Google
search console this is the links report
this is totally free this is provided by
Google all you have to do is verify your
site now if we go over to Moz we type in
a domain any domain so I just typed in
simple and learn okay Moz has some
metrics that are important to off-page
SEO including domain Authority so the
higher your domain Authority the better
off you are and so what helps a domain
Authority grow is how many quality links
are pointing to that domain and so here
we could see over
7500 linking domains to Simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointed okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here
Moz is going to give me kind of an idea
of what my domain Authority has been
over time they're going to tell me the
top fault links to the site so they can
tell me you know what are those links
pointing to my site and what's the page
authority of those sites okay here I can
get a nice graphical breakdown of the
linking domains by domain Authority so
you want pages with high domain
Authority pointing to your site so here
I can see 69 linking domains between 91
and 100 so that's really good we want
High relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console I can
see the top anchor text being used okay
and I can see the top pages that have
you know good page Authority on the site
I could see following versus no follow
on internal and external links so this
is just the overview so Ma's really
really does break down for you you know
what those pages and linking domains are
so if I just click on linking domains
now I could get a detailed look for my
home page what domains are pointing to
our domain so I could see microsoft.com
has a domain authority of 100 YouTube 99
and so not only does Moz provide you
with the domains it also provides you
with their domain Authority score and
spam score so you want to keep an eye on
any particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain Authority will
hurt your domain and Page Authority for
that page so Mazda does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if I take a look look at
another example here Majestic so
Majestic again I can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend on that
referring domains so Majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then I'm going to just revert
back to Moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page SEO you know Moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis I can compare my domain
Authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external file
links or external no file links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to Moz and
that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that I
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright Edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing
off-page SEO you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor text are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors I mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
SEO so you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for well
keywords we find our relevant keywords
we sign primary and secondary keywords
to Pages we optimize those pages we do
off-page SEO and we do in all this work
for SEO okay we want to be able to
measure the fruits of our labor we want
to be able to measure how we perform for
on and off page SEO for the keywords we
covet in the pages they're related to
and so that's where rank tracking comes
into play so we want to be able to track
our websites ranking and not just our
website all the pages we've optimized we
want to be able to measure our
click-through rates and Impressions we
want to be able to track the ranking for
both desktop and mobile for specific
locations and we want to identify top
performing gaining and losing keywords
so in other words we want to look at
Trends is a keyword ranking is it going
up and ranking is it going down and
ranking if it's going down in ranking
then you need to take action so you need
a tool a good tool for rank tracking so
we can look no further than again Google
search console console it's free it's
right from the source so let's take a
look at what Google search console has
to offer in terms of rank tracking so if
I go to Google Search console and I put
in a URL what it's going to do is it's
going to give me and this is the search
queries report it's going to give me
what queries people have used to
actually type into google.com and it's
going to be able to tell me how many
times my pages show Pages showed up for
that query it could be more than one
page so that's an impression and if I
did receive an impression meaning did my
page show up in the organic listing then
did I get a click as a result and so in
this case if I got 68 Impressions and 10
clicks for keywords somebody typed in
that's a 14.7 percent click-through rate
and so with search console we'll also do
is say hey look for that particular
keyword you appeared on average in
position 4.1 so it gives you really good
insight as to you know what people are
typing in and how you're being found for
those keywords it breaks it down by
Pages it breaks it down by country
breaks it down by device so I could see
you know mobile I've had
899 Impressions over the last three
months on mobile and I received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile is 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keywords somebody's using on Google
search as a query and how many
Impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click the rate
and then average position so in theory
the higher you are positioned on Google
the more clicks you're going to receive
so if I'm not positioned properly for
keyword let's say page two then I'm
probably not going to receive as many
clicks as I would like so that's search
console there are other tools out there
like hrefs again does a good job of
tracking AMZ tracker we look at wincher
so there's some good tools out there I'm
just going to show you another one again
I'm going to go back to Moz for example
so Moz has a tool called so if I go back
into the account so Maz has a rankings
tool that you can look at to see where
your keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimized
Pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords into
Moz and so Moz allows you to do that and
so what Moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
ranked between positions one and three
eleven through twenty four through ten
twenty one through 50. so we'll be able
to see where our keywords Rank and so it
gives you a breakdown here of nationally
in the United States where this keyword
is ranked and if it's moved up or down
and for what URL is it ranked for and so
you can label so the keywords and and
this is what you want to look for in a
good tool you want to be able to
organize your keyword words and label
them so for all our brand keywords we
want to be able to label them branded
because ideally you don't want to
optimize for your brand keywords so
maybe we want to exclude our brand
keywords and look at our non-brand
keywords in terms of ranking and so you
can certainly add locations and look at
specific locations the whole idea
between a good ranking tool is to be
able to measure you know if a keyword is
trending up or down okay so I can simply
look at a particular keyword and I can
see the trend of that keyword and then
you know if a keyword is not ranking
then we want to wonder why it's not
ranking well is it difficult is it not
ranking because of its difficulty or can
we do a better job of optimizing for
that keyword and so Moz also has a page
optimization tool so if you're not
ranking for keyword you can flip over
the page optimization tool then put in
the keyword put in the URL and mods will
give you some idea as to what you can
further do to optimize the page okay so
that's Moz you know this is a traps so
you can see ahrefs does the same thing
they provide you some visibility average
position how much traffic you know where
you're ranking in terms of positions one
through three four through ten eleven
through fifty and so you want to be able
to get a sense of where my track
keywords are trending are they training
up are they trending down and the whole
idea again Beyond a ranking tool is if
you're trending down you want to be able
to address why it's trending down so you
want to start with on-page SEO can we do
a better job of optimizing or off page
does that page need more backlinks so
that's why you need a backlink tool to
support your ranking and ahrefs does
offer up some competitor information as
well so you can see how your competitors
are performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you could
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SEO tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ so if I
load in say video in YouTube in this
example how to rank YouTube videos I
have a vid IQ extension loaded into my
browser in Chrome and so now I can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
Reddit but further I can look at how the
video was optimized so they're telling
me the title's too long here maybe
shorten it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
YouTube tube so you want to be able to
use a tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your YouTube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid IQ
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know YouTube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind Google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for Content
optimization there are tools you can use
like SCS site checkup or site analyzer
or some good tools if you already have
Moz as an example just going back to Moz
as you already know I use mozz a lot so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content and how you're
optimized your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again I have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page in search console see if
it has any errors as well so is it
duplicated meta description is it a
duplicated title tag is it any Pages
missing title tags your meta
descriptions so when it comes to content
you can look at search console you can
lean on Moz or you can lean on some of
these other paid versions like site
analyzer when it comes to traffic and
metrics look no further than Google
analytics there is a free version of
Google analytics as well as a paid
version so if I go into Google analytics
it's going to tell me all of my website
Behavior okay who's coming to my site
how they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and are they
achieving the goals I set out for them
to achieve via conversions and so you
want to look at first in Google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if I go to Google Analytics
if I go to acquisition all traffic
channels I should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so I can see how
many users how many sessions then if I
click on landing pages I can see what
landing page they went to so I could see
the home page over a particular time I
had over a thousand sessions I can also
see engagement from organic search are
they bouncing how many pages are they
looking at in this session after they
landed on a particular page are they
staying on the site a long time what's
their duration or are they achieving any
goals so analytics will provide me all
that information about how organic
search as a channel is performing the
other thing about Google analytics I
like and that goes back to the technical
aspect of SEO and that site speed so if
you go to behavior and you go to site
speed overview you'll be able to see how
my pages are loading what's the average
load time so they'll break it down for
you by browser by country and by
specific page so if I look at page
timings I'll be able to see what page is
loading slow what page is loading quick
compared to site average and so the
great thing about analytics is if I have
a page that's loading slow compared to
site average they'll actually provide me
with some suggestions so if I go to site
speed and speed suggestions what they're
going to do is they're going to have a
link in the report that's going to allow
me to click on it and I'm going to be
able to see what suggestions they can
provide so when this report loads I'll
be able to see what the speed
suggestions are for my pages so here I
could see the page I could see what the
average low time is of that page so for
example this particular page is loading
at six seconds ideally we want to have
you know three seconds or under maximum
so if I just click on this link here
they're giving me six page speed
suggestions so if I click on that I'm
going to go to another Google tool
called page speed insights and then page
speed insights is going to run for both
mobile and desktop for this particular
page and then this page speed insights
report is going to give me feedback as
to what I need to do to speed up the
load time of that page so here you can
see for desktop and mobile they're going
to give me some suggestions and
opportunities so reduce the server
response time properly size images serve
images in next-gen formats so all these
will shave off time off my page load
time and so that's what's going to help
me speed up the page load and that's
page speed insights you can get to from
the speech suggestions report and
analytics So in theory the higher page
load time your chances of ranking on
Google organic search diminished so
Google wants pages that have very low
page load time that load quickly so
Google analytics is great tool for Speed
suggestions it's a great tool for
finding out what the traffic is doing on
your site how they're engaging and are
they achieving goals now there are other
tools out there from an organic
perspective like keyword it that's a
good keyword research tool for Reddit so
if you go to keyword it you'll be able
to see from a Reddit perspective what
keywords are driving volume these are
just the results but you can put any
keyword in there and get the results of
that keyword SEO is an important part of
the marketing strategy in case your
website doesn't show up on the first
page of the search engine then you need
to work on it to solve all your SEO
related problems we've come up with a
solution
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and today we will be discussing the top
10 tips that every marketer needs to
know so let's get started and see the
first step
the first step is voice search now voice
search will impact search queries in
2021 according to dialogtech.com
in the United States of America 55
percent of the households will have
their own smart speaker by 2022.
well that's a lot so if you're planning
to optimize your voice search consider
choosing wise keywords
find out longer phrases that Searchers
use in daily life conversation
voice search is a more suitable way for
searching long and more natural sounding
phrases creating detailed and relevant
answers are essential when optimizing
for voice search so always remember to
create Persona based content
next create web pages that can answer
FAQ use because when Searchers ask a
question they begin their question with
words like who when whom what however
there are many reasons for using voice
search such as dictating text messages
looking for a video on YouTube calling a
person from your contact list asking for
directions
Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows websites on
top that load quickly in that case you
must always ensure that your website has
a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is reduced
now the second step in the process is
the mobile optimization
now you must already know how important
it is to make your site mobile friendly
for a better user experience but did you
also know that having a mobile friendly
application impacts your search engine
optimization
sem Rush confirms that by the year 2025
approximately 70 percent of Internet
users will access the internet through
mobile devices
Google's mobile friendly update has
resulted in a big change in search
rankings with the help of Google's free
mobile friendly test have a look at how
effective your mobile website is also
take a peek at the mobile usability
report in Google's search console
now let's talk about tip number three
that is Google's eight principles Google
has confirmed that content quality is an
essential factor for ranking on search
engine result pages
but what does quality mean to Google
well content that fulfills the Google
eat principle will rank higher eat
stands for expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness
these elements will determine if a web
page has a useful quality content
Google uses the combination of
algorithms to deliver the best results
for users Google Panda is one of the
famous algorithms of Google which
emphasizes delivering high quality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have low quality and
duplicate content not just that there is
one more algorithm called rankbrain
rankbrain is a processing algorithm that
uses machine learning to interpret
search queries that users search on
Google whereas the searched query may
not have the right keywords that were
searched for
for example
when you're searching for chocolate cake
recipes you will also get results for
chocolate truffle cake recipes on the
search engine results page Google Panda
and rankbrain send Bots to crawl each
and every website and as a result shows
high quality content on the top of the
search engine results page
next is our tip number four featured
snippet
these results are featured on the top
part of the page Google programmatically
chooses the best answer from the third
party website and displays it on the
featured snippet here's what a featured
snippet looks like
according to ahrefs for a specific
search query almost 99 of web pages
shown in the featured snippet already
rank on serp's first page some of the
ways to optimize featured Snippets are
organize your content in a structured
way make sure one article answers many
similar questions use eye-catching
images and the last point is to create
answers with tables to drive clicks and
write dedicated headings to answer
featured Snippets like is red meat
healthy suppose you want to create
Snippets plan on creating question based
questions along with the relevant
keywords for ideas you can also look at
the Google search function that is
usually written in the blue color
and it reads out as people also ask so
now let's move to the fifth tip
image optimization according to sem Rush
image optimization will play a prominent
role in search in case the images on
your website aren't optimized make sure
to take care of them right now remember
to use high quality images relevant
images and use a suitable label for your
image file include images in your site
map as it becomes easier for the Bots to
crawl and finally use alt tags as
crawlers use it to classify the images
alt text is displayed on the web page
when an image fails to load on a user's
screen it is also utilized by Google to
drive meaning from images
a well-optimized image can improve your
page ranking and increase the engagement
on it image optimization can help your
web page show up in the image carousels
on search engines
next we have semantically related
keywords
semantic search will have become an
important factor for ranking in the
future semantic keywords are linked to
the primary keywords
they drive relevant traffic on search
engine result pages
a simple way to look for LSI keywords is
on Google serp
semantic search can be performed wisely
by writing content that targets the
question that your target audience is
looking for
remember to optimize content for topic
clusters instead of focusing solely on
keywords and finally use structured data
and pick your semantic keywords this can
also be done with the help of a
comprehensive keyword tool it finds out
semantically related keywords
next comes tip number seven building
quality links
building quality links to your website
is important if you are aiming to manage
a successful and long-term SEO strategy
building quality links cannot be ignored
in 2016 Google declared that building
quality links are one of their top three
ranking signals always opt for quality
over quantity
as building quality links to your
content can give your product and
category Pages a boost in serps
let me share a few effective strategies
that will increase the number of links
pointing to your website dramatically
the first one
earn backlinks from relevant and
authoritative web pages next promote
your content regularly on social media
opt for guest blogging and influencer
marketing next take advantage of social
media platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and start your own page then
participate in forums to engage with
your target audience start your blog and
attract your target audience with your
valuable content
finally get listed in the high quality
link directories this will help you
build links from authoritative websites
next number eight is local search
listings
local SEO is the practice of optimizing
a website in order to obtain traffic
from location-based searching it is the
best way to Market your products and
services to local customers
according to Google local results are
based on relevance distance and
prominence these factors help Google to
find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
have your nap details accurate and
consistent across the internet
sem Rush confirms that local search
listings will play a larger role in the
SEO strategies
suppose you want to know how to get your
business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own for this it is also important
to have a strong backlink profile
next we have number nine that is improve
the user experience
for the past few years ux has become an
important ranking factor for Google
however more and more SEO Specialists
have gained an interest in ux
ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor
consider the partnership of search
engine optimization and user experience
this way the search engine optimization
focuses on search engines and user
experience targets website visitors
so both share a common goal of giving
users the best result
this is what the content King app says
about the user experience
let me show you a few practices on how
to effectively leverage ux designs to
provide your site's SEO performance
simplify your site's navigation a good
site architecture helps to gain traffic
utilize ux design to SEO friendly
layouts which means make content easy to
digest infused images and videos
whenever possible use ctas very wisely
and finally optimize for site load speed
optimize for mobile responsive design as
more than 50 percent of all the traffic
is now driven by mobile search
in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement
and finally we come to our 10th and last
tip
that is using schema markup
according to search metrics 36 percent
of Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schema markup
schema markup is microdata that every
individual can add to his website in
order to give an enhanced description to
users on a search engine results page
in simple words schema markup is used to
define website content
adding structured data will give your
website a significant SEO boost and
increase your rankings
some of the schema markup examples are
ratings and reviews image thumbnails
product availability and finally site
links
adding schema markup to your HTML is one
of the ranking factors
search engine optimization has been
playing an essential role in the success
of various businesses for those who are
still looking for growth in the industry
and have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their primary
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so before we
begin I have a question for you the
process of getting the quality and
quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get number one on
Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tenfold
so definitely we're going to take a look
at the best tips for ranking high on
Google but before that it is necessary
to understand why it's important to rank
high on Google
well we are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business
the data states that around 1.17 billion
people across the globe use Google
search which is estimated to increase
exponentially in the coming years
moreover Google has gained the trust of
their users with their services over the
years this definitely makes the point of
interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as serps allows
a business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales
it also helps in generating authenticity
for your business well not one or two
there are numerous reasons which makes
SEO important to know more about SEO
check the complete playlist on SEO you
can find the link to the playlist in the
description box below
to gain expertise in search engine
optimization get certified as a skilled
SEO professional with simply learns
search engine optimization training
course you can check the course details
from the link in the description box
below as we know how important it is to
rank high on Google so in the next 10
minutes let's get to know the top five
success mantras that will help you rank
high-end Google so the fifth tip on our
list is promote your content
whether you are a business owner or a
blogger you definitely need to promote
your content to get a good audience
reach buy content here we mean data on
your website that can be products
services or even a simple blog to do
this find the relevant groups on the
social media platforms like Facebook or
Instagram and post your content with an
excellent call to action context some
blogging or article submission sites
like quora Tumblr and hub pages may also
prove helpful online forums and
communities can be a good option to
spread a word about your content with
people having similar interests let's
focus on our number four tip internal
linking a good site architecture is
always a happy bite for web crawlers a
website with good site architecture and
internal linking helps web crawlers
understand the website structure and
helps them to crawl the site more
effectively the more the pages of your
website are crawled greater are the
chances of getting indexed if pages are
successful indexed they get eligible for
appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below and number two we have a tip which
is of utmost importance to win a good
position in the search results on page
optimization on-page optimization are
also known as on-page SEO is a process
in which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web pages
position in search engine rankings
on-page optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more
get the detail guide to learning on-page
optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research
keyword research is a process of
identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create
proper keyword research may prove a boon
to your business but it also has the
power to ruin your business so be wise
When selecting your keywords try
choosing long tail keywords if you are
new to the business as these are easier
to rank for you can look at Google's
Auto suggest feature to understand what
people are looking for in your industry
be updated with what your competitors
are doing if something is working for
your competitor there are high chances
that it may work for you as well you can
also take the help of various keyword
research tools like Google's own Keyword
Planner answer the public tool Google
Trends and Etc
these fantastic and 100 practical tips
can drive your business to Heights make
sure you implement all these tips with
more detailed attention as SEO can make
and break you so what according to you
is the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments below introducing simple lens
postgraduate program in digital
marketing that will transform you into
Master of the digital realm this
comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
enroll in a postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below in today's video we are going to
talk about Google business profile you
may remember Google business profile as
Google my business but Google has
changed to name and I'll explain to you
later the reasoning behind this change
we're going to be talking about what is
Google business profile what do you need
to know about it how do you use Google
business profile as a small business yep
and we're going to discuss many other
topics in relation to this as well but
before we start let me introduce myself
I am Mark campman I am your digital
navigator for this video if you like the
video click the like button and if you
want to subscribe to our our Channel
click the Subscribe button below and you
will get lots and lots of access to more
videos and get notifications about when
we publish new videos so let's dig
straight into it let me give you some
facts about Google which will tell you
which will show you that you cannot
afford to miss out on what Google has to
offer you did you know that Google was
visited
189.3 billion times in the past month
only
yeah Google holds over 90 market share
in the search engine Market Google
processes 99
000 searches every second which makes
that a total of 8.5 billion searches
every day
yeah also remember 63 of those surges
are done on a mobile phone
now Google Maps is a key part of your
Google business profile did you know
that there are over 5 billion downloads
of the Google Maps app
and as you find to finalize these
numbers yeah Google generated
146.92 billion dollars in advertising
Revenue in 2020. so do I need to
convince you any further that Google has
to be center stage of your marketing
efforts let's talk how you can do this
when you are a local small business so
what are we going to be talking about we
will talk about what is Google business
profile
how can you use Google business profile
for your local marketing
yeah how do you get started with Google
business profile how can you use your
Google business profile for your search
engine optimization to get a higher
ranking in your Google search engine
results and I'll finish off with a few
pros and cons of the Google business
profile so are you ready let's first
talk about what is Google business
profile it used to be called Google my
business Google has renamed Google my
business to Google business profile to
make it more simple you have to bring
more of the business profile management
functions out of the Google my business
app directly into Google search and the
Google Map
yep so now the history of the name which
you currently called Google business
profile you may remember Google my
business before that it was Google
places before that it was Google Plus
local remember those Google days and
when it officially started it was just
Google local
but to keep things simple it has now
been renamed as Google business profile
that you can access through the Google
search or through Google Maps
so how would you define it Google
business profile is a tool that enables
you to manage and optimize your business
profile on Google
yeah so you can create a free business
profile on Google for your shop or your
service area so you can turn people who
find you on Google Search and on Google
Maps into new customers and once you've
created your Google business profile you
can then personalize it with photos with
offers with posts and many other things
and later in this presentation I will
show you how to do all this
so your business profile is Google's
term for your Google Business listing
yeah they appear in Google maps and in
the local results of Google search and
that's very important you can access it
through Google Maps and Google search in
the local search results and you can
also see it on the right side of the
search engine results page
so let me show you an example if I open
up a new frame and I search for Indian
restaurant
yep then here you see the search results
yep you see
restaurants and here you see a map where
you can find those places yeah so that
is in the first place where your
restaurant will show up
yes so if I go then click on one of the
restaurants I can get more details of
different restaurants but also more
details about a restaurant that I picked
yeah and this is what you specify in
Google my business profile so I could
also access them through the map
yeah so if I click on that that opens up
the same window which more details about
the restaurant as specified in Google
business profile now what is all in
there I'll share that with you in a
minute
so that is the power of Google business
profile
so how can you use this for your local
marketing why is it good to use it to
set up your business profile
Google has reported that 46 of all
searches done on Google have a local
intent
and at business location is the main
piece of information sought by local
searchers
yeah so it's the easiest way and the
fastest way for you to show up in the
search feed
so Google business profile gives you the
ability to incorporate your search
engine results into your marketing and
that is a huge Advantage for local
businesses it's not just an ordinary
business listing but it's a robust tool
that gives you benefits from appearing
in the Google search results
so if I would summarize the benefits of
Google business profile they are as
follows they will give you customer
engagement they will help you
highlighting your business in Google
you can gain insights from the people
that visit your website and you can
optimize your online presence for local
SEO
so let's dive into these a little bit
deeper let's start with the customer
engagement
so through Google business profile
customers and Prospects can contact you
and in your business profile you can
specify your telephone number your
address and directions to your business
so people can contact you they can find
you and they can engage with you
say for example a potential lead comes
across your business in the search
results but he wants something special
so how will you reach out to you
directly from the search list
Google business profile has a messaging
feature that lets you directly chat with
potential customers who will find your
profile on the search results page it
enables you to quickly answer questions
in real time and help your current and
potential customers
Google gives you the option to activate
this yeah so when you activate it users
visiting your page will see a clickable
message icon on top of that they can
call you or you can add posts to your
business profile to promote special
offers or events and updates to keep
your customers in the loop you can also
reply to public customer reviews to
build trust with new returning customers
and of course you can post answers to
frequently asked questions by your
customers
the second Advantage is that Google
business profile offers you the
opportunity to highlight your business
yes it gives you a ton of opportunities
to specify a lot of things about your
business when you sign up and sign in
you get to your dashboard and that's
where you can add items like showcasing
what makes your store special show
photos of your latest products and your
store to stand out to customers who find
your profile yeah you show whether your
offer options like a pickup or a
delivery you can give people who find
you online a warm welcome with posts
about discounts new products upcoming
events so lots of things that you can
highlight about your business again let
me show you an example if I go to Google
and I search for instance for Disney
Paris
yeah you will see I find or let's say
Disneyland
Paris
yes so when I click here on Disneyland
Paris then here I get all the details I
can see the description I can see the
address the rights that you can do the
hours of opening you can see who is
owned by you see events that they have
there's questions and answers there's
reviews yep and there's more information
there's links to social media so lots of
stuff that you can find here as long as
you specified at all on your dashboard
when you highlight your business
so the third benefit is that you can
gain a lot of insights with people or
from people that visit your um and that
find you on Google yes so you can gain
data about your target market and your
local search performance
you can track your performance over a
given time period and it will give you
insights how people interact with your
business on Google you can check how
often your profile has been viewed you
can use profile views insights to track
how popular your business is with
current and potential customers
yeah not obviously only the owner of the
business profile can view the profile
insights
you will get metrics like the queries
people used to find your business the
number of unique visitors to your
profile number of unique customers who
request directions to your business the
number of clicks on the call to action
button on your business profile number
of clicks on the website link number of
unique conversations through messages
a number of completed bookings by
customers a summary of all your
interactions number of views on products
over a selected period And if you are a
restaurant you can get food orders
placed for pickup or delivery and you
get a number of clicks on the menu
content per user per day so you gain a
lot of knowledge about who what and when
people are accessing and finding you on
the on Google and finally one of the
biggest advantages that you can get with
Google business profile is that it
improves your local search rankings
leading to a higher visibility of your
business on the web
so when you search for a product or
service on Google the first three
listings are usually Google ads
yeah followed by a map with the local
three pack as we call this and then you
will see the organic search results
so let's show you an example of this
local three pack on Google if I go to
search and I search for shoe shop near
me
yeah I'm getting ads yeah that's the
first part and then I'm getting three
places and here is your Google three
pack your local three pack with the map
and then I have the organic search
results
yes so one of the biggest benefit then I
get the shirts results
so for local businesses prior to this
local pack yeah there were two main ways
to show up on the first page of Google
through local pay-per-click and through
local SEO
now with the addition of this Google
local pack you now have three potential
ways that you could show up on the first
page of Google for Relevant local
searches and that's something that can
not be ignored now what is this local
three pack it consists of the top three
local businesses based on the searcher's
location
yeah the best part of it is that
customers now end up at your shops Front
without even having to visit your
websites
so remember this used to be a seven pack
and it's now limited to only three local
listings hence the title the local three
pack
now many many businesses have been
trying different SEO tricks to get into
this special category of three listings
yeah but what most of them don't know is
that by creating a Google business
profile listing you can significantly
increase the chances of making it onto
this list
now there's more that you can do to make
it in this three pack it's important to
get reviews on your Google my business
profile yeah so that helps you increase
the chances of showing up in this local
pack and it's also good for your
reputation which is very important for
your business and Google will reward you
for that with giving you higher search
rankings
and additionally all the SEO rules and
guidelines that apply to standard search
engine optimization they apply to your
local listing as well so think about
your keywords your website SEO getting
backlinks these will all contribute to
your local search listing and whether or
not you will appear in the three pack
now also consider that paid advertising
can help you in getting your business
listed here
yet through local search ads on Google
there is an opportunity for your
business to serve a local pay-per-click
ad in the three pack
yep and remember just a few tips in
order to show up in the Google three
pack with your pay-per-click ads there's
a few steps that you need to take yeah
enable local extensions or location
extensions as we call them in Google ads
bit the location and use sorry bit by
location and use location targeting
and optimize your keywords to include
your location as well
so having your business appear in the
local three pack can help you tap into
potential Revenue opportunities as
Google not only shows customers your
business on Google Maps but it also
places it before organic search results
and let's look at the final topic before
we go into a demo of Google business
profile let's look at a bit more detail
about how Google business profile can
help you with your SEO and what you need
to do to optimize it for SEO
there are three aspects in using Google
business profile for SEO
you need to Target your information by
including your SEO keywords relevant to
your business
you need to make sure you maintain
information quality by ensuring all
information is accurate consistent and
correct and you need to build trust by
engaging with your customers
so to achieve this here is what you need
to do you need to verify your business
you need to fill out your profile
completely
you need to make sure your profile
information is and stays accurate
you must ensure that your nap name
address place is consistent across the
web which is very important yeah your
address is unique across all your places
where you are on the web you pick the
most relevant categories for your
business
make sure that your pictures your photos
are of the highest quality
focus on getting reviews
create posts on your business profile to
drive engagement with your customers and
when customers ask questions on your
business profile make sure you answer
those questions
yeah here you see the importance when
you fill in all the data of the various
Fields you see the most important yeah
there is name address phone number
website link but don't forget the all
the other items as well
so for determining your local ranking
Google takes three factors into
consideration
there's the relevance of your listing is
how well your business matches the
user's search intent and to increase the
chances that your local business appears
in the search results you should feed
Google with as much information as
possible
Google will also look at the distance
yeah so the distance refers to how close
your business location is to the
location of the user who searches
and finally prominence yeah Google
determines your local ranking by
checking out how well known your
business is and whether or not you have
a good reputation
and to influence this reputation you
have off-site links and articles related
to your business they can really
contribute to building your reputation
online
so now that you've got all the details
about Google business profile let's have
a look at how you set it up and I'm
going to show you how to sign into your
Google business accounts how you can add
your business how you can enter your
location how you can fill in your
contact information I tell you about the
process of verifying your business and
then finally how you can customize your
profile
so let's have a look at Google business
profile if I go to the Google business
profile website then I just go there by
searching for Google business profile
and click on the link that I see on the
search results and then I get to this
page yeah a short summary of what your
free business profile is all about how
you can access your dashboard if you've
got to be a business profile you see
some benefits free easy personalized and
then it gives you all the benefits that
you get from having your business
profile on Google
yes so that is one area where you can
access of course your Google business
profile now the other area where you can
access your Google business profile is
to go to Google Maps so if I go to
Google Maps
and I click here on Google Maps this
takes me to Google Maps if I now want to
go for instance to register my own
business own Google business profile let
me show you how to do that I can be on
Google Maps I can go to
the place that I want to
um to register
yeah so and I want that actually on
Google Maps so I don't want that here I
want to stay on Google Maps so let's say
I say like
South Cerny
there is where I have a lodge that I
rent out and if I zoom in on that
yeah and then here I can see it is
dislodge yeah and currently there's
nothing on there you see this house has
no
business profile this one has
yes so this one has as well so how can I
register this Lodge on Google business
profile very simple I can register it by
right clicking on it
yep so I can get directions what's here
I can say add your business so if I
click here on add your business guess
where that takes me it takes me to
Google business profile and I'm now
going into this setup under my Google
account
yeah I'm going to the setup on Google my
business for this place so the place
name is Isis 97.
Lodge
okay so I click enter and I'm going to
click continue
now it talks to me what is this place
about what kind of business type is it
an online retail is it a local store or
is it a service business let's say it is
a local store customers can visit the
business in person click on that and it
takes me to the next screen
that's why I'm going to go for an enter
a business category there's a whole load
of uh categories here I can say just a
lodge or I can say what is it a
um a resort let's see if I can do that a
resource Hotel yeah or a resort place I
can just say a holiday
sort of
a home
yeah so let's call it a holiday home and
I'm going to click next
now it wants the business address so the
country in this case is not Malaysia
because that's where I am at the moment
so it takes my default address it's in
the United Kingdom the street address is
Isis Lake
and then it is I need to put the address
97 Isis Lake
spine Road
East
yeah the post tone is south
Cerny postcode gl75lt
so spine wrote e species the watermarks
spine Road East I don't mind to share
this data with you because it's going to
be public anyway because people will be
able to find this on the internet yes so
I'm going to click next
what contact details do I want to show
my customers I want to show them the
phone number and that could be 07545
and then three two eight
nine nine nine
is United Kingdom and I can also say I'm
going to skip this step actually for now
I'm gonna skip this step
put your business on the map yes start
connecting with your customers across
Google all in one place so here are the
details that you've learned earlier in
today's presentation get discovered
respond to review manage your business
details yep and now I'm going to click
do I want to get tips and alerts I'm not
interested in that I just click continue
and here I am in my
dashboard now here comes the process of
verification which is an important
element of Google business profile
yeah so we talked a bit about businesses
using it for spam purposes yeah so the
verification is very important for
Google there are various ways that you
can get verification Google has made it
fairly simple you can verify through a
through a phone number you can also
verify by getting a card sent to your
physical business address
your listing will not show on Google
until you have verified your business
okay but for now I'm going to click next
and I'm going to actually I'm gonna
click verify later because I don't want
to do the verification yet
so now I can add business hours I'm
going to skip that
yeah remember we talked about messaging
I'm going to skip the messaging and now
I can add photos of my business so let's
grab a photo from the internet yep so
let's say Isis Lake South Cerny
and I'm going to go to images
so here is the park where you see images
so I am going to uh take any random
image let's say we'll take
this image
yep I'm going to right click I'm going
to click save image s and I'm going to
do Isis Lodge 01.
all right so I'm going to complete my
profile I'm going to add a photo I'm
going to select photo from the computer
I'm going to YouTube and then desktop
and here is the Isis Lodge
yep there's the photo and I can
obviously add a lot more photos there's
the next do I want to start advertising
on Google ads I can actually claim a 400
pounds free advertising credits of
course that is really good what they do
here just to get you to start using
advertising
and then get a customer domain name for
a website I haven't got a website yet
but I'm not interested in that at the
moment
yes so remember your edits will be
visible once you're verified all right
so my listing will not be visible yet
but here is basically my besting list
business listing as it stands at the
moment but it is not publicly visible
but at least I have set up my business
profile yeah so now I'm in my dashboard
in Google
my business I had to go into a separate
app for this but now I can actually edit
it all through the search so that is
very useful so here is edit profile read
reviews read the messages
add photos what is the performance do we
want to go advertising all the things we
discussed in our earlier session so edit
profile and here I can get information
about contact information location
information hours of opening my business
name of my launch the opening date
contact information yes so location I
can specify here
so all the details that I need and if I
do this properly is where it will show
up in Google and if I really got my
reputation sorted and everything I may
show up in the Google three pack as well
so that is the process of setting up
your Google business profile so let's
now look at an existing business profile
let's switch my account
so I'm going to sign out of this account
and I'm going to sign in again into my
own accounts
so now I'm in my own Google account and
I'm going to I'm switching to Chrome I
say no just leave it as it is
okay well we can do that
yeah so now I'm in my Google Chrome my
my personal account and I'm going to
show you an existing
um Google business profile that I have
which is for a website for another house
in Marrakech which is Riyadh farasha
yeah so you see here it is already on
Google my business oh sorry it's already
on Google business profile but I haven't
really populated it yet with information
okay so here you can see I can access
this
through the Google search to manage my
profile
yep so I can edit the profile I can read
to refuse all the things that I want to
do I can add an update I can see the
photos yep so here I have access to it
and then here you see the site panel
with a summary of all the things that
you've done
okay I could also access this through
Google Maps again if I go to Google Maps
and I search in Google maps for Riyadh
for Russia
yeah here it is Russia there it will
take me here's the basic details in
Google Maps yeah and it will take me
here to Riyadh for Russia but it is
empty I haven't added any information in
it yet so I can now click here on manage
my business profile or I can see where
um the all the details that I have added
so far
I get some basic data so 55 people
feuded this month and without actually
having done any effort in optimizing it
or populating it with information so if
I hear click on manage your business
profile that takes me back to the Google
search screen where I can add all the
data so let's add a photo I can click
here for add a photo or I can click here
to add a photo I'm clicking here add a
photo I'm doing a photo click here
and then select photo or video and that
is from the YouTube
desktop it's here for Russia 01 it's the
photo that I'm going to add
yep so now I can see the photo
let's see if I can do here you see the
photo
call it
yeah and of course I can add a lot more
I can do a logo a cover a video photo of
the Interior here's a photo that I've
done so far so I can now go back to my
business profile
yeah I think it will take a bit of time
before the photo shows up on the
on the profile
yeah so click add photo
yes so the photos don't show up yet
yeah but that's how you can optimize
your profile making sure all the
information is relevant yep so that is
basically all there is to managing your
profile on on Google business profile so
remember you can access it directly by
searching for your business name in
Google search
or you can exit it access it directly by
entering for searching for your business
name on Google Maps
both show the results and then they also
give you access to your dashboard where
you can add all the information that
needs to be added
yeah performance we talked about that as
well yeah so here you can check by month
you can see I've I've started the um the
the created the pro the business profile
sort of the beginning of October so here
you can see I can check from October to
December apply
so I see I had 18 business profile
interactions I can check people that
called me people that message me the
directions people that look at website
clicks booking clicks so you can get a
lot of information
of people that visited your business
profile
okay so that concludes the demo of the
Google business profile and now let's go
back to the slides to give you a summary
of the Google business profile and the
positives and the negatives of it
okay hope you found that useful so let's
finish today's presentation with a few
more facts about the pros and the cons
of your Google business profile we
talked about old approach all the
benefits that you can get yeah and to
summarize Google business profile can
help you with reaching your customers
it can help you responding to customer
interests it can help you respond to
customer feedbacks and you can get into
engagement with your customers and most
important of all it can help you in a
very easy way to get a presence on
Google search results page without
actually having a website
is so it is of extremely powerful tool
and it's a free tool for your business
to get yourself an online presence where
your customers can find you
and where they can engage with you
but there are some cons as well
yeah I have to think hard about cons but
as most things in digital marketing one
con you could say yeah it takes time
yeah of course you need to set up your
business profile yeah and it takes time
to do that it takes time to maintain
this but I don't see this a considerable
serious drawback because people that are
prepared to put a time and effort into
it they will be rewarded accordingly
one potential negative of Google
business profile can be that fake
businesses can use it as well because
it's a free service
yeah and although you do there is a
verification process in the Google
business profile yeah there may be
businesses who take advantage of this um
of this free service yeah so anyone can
realistically set up a profile to
promote their business
so there was an example a few years ago
that fake locksmiths were committing
fraud through local listings on Google
business profile with bogus profiles so
while the majority of the profiles are
genuine businesses trying to promote
themselves in a very competitive World
there are some to see this as a feature
and an opportunity for scams
yeah so people believe that reviews
photos and verifying a business by mail
would be enough to disturb scammers
however in this age of fake news as well
as misleading e-commerce reviews Google
must take action to constantly optimize
their verification process of Google
business profile now coming to create
the Google ads okay so first of all
creating the campaign we need to be
having a Google ads account that's a
very first requirement so I'll just help
you now how you create a Google ads
account for free by using your Gmail ID
okay so we go to Google
let me just search probably here itself
and we type Google ads just ensure that
you are logged in with any of your Gmail
ID
and then we see Google ads
on a top
then we just need to click this
and once you reach to this page you have
to click get started
after get started probably in my case
you would see a different screen because
I have lot of accounts created a lot of
clients accounts are there but in your
case it will show new Google ads account
like this
so I will repeat my steps so that you're
not confused
so you go on Google
you type Google ads
you click Google ads the very first
result
or either if it is not showing in your
country in your location then you have
to just find ads.google.com
and you click get started
okay the moment you click get started
you would directly reach to this page
okay that's why I just repeated my steps
because I have been taken to some other
page where my already created accounts
were showing but in your case after just
clicking get started it will directly
going to take you to this page now here
you have to ensure that you are not
clicking anything why because this has
brought us to the express mode Express
mode is more of the kind like automated
or a smart mode which is created by
Google for uh making the quick ads you
know it is not going to be showing you
all the exhaustive settings or you know
advanced settings inside so for that
reason what we do we go down we just you
know I've just I've just scroll down
okay and then switch to expert mode
okay I'll again repeat when we click
this get started we reach to this page
where it takes us to the smart or
Express mode where we don't have to be
doing anything we scroll down and we
click on a switch to export mode
once we click that
then you would see few things which you
have just seen in the PPD probably that
what is your objective why you have come
here you have come here to increase your
sales leads website traffic and XYZ
things but because right now I'm just
teaching you or just letting you know
how the account is created then we can
ignore these tabs for a moment of course
in a while we'll talk about these as
well so we'll just scroll down and we'll
create a account without a campaign as I
said we are going in a sequence so we
are not creating the campaign first I am
considering most of the users would not
have the Google ad account as of now so
I am going that way so you create the
account first without a campaign so when
you click this
then you see
there are a few basic questions been
asked like from which country your
billing would be which time zone you
want to follow or which currency you
would be paying in okay once this is
done just click submit
okay just click submit
once this is done congrats you're all
done okay then you just need to click on
explore your account
and this takes you to the
dashboard of this beautiful tool Google
ads from where we can start our journey
of making the very first campaign
okay so now let's again come back to the
PPD because our account is created now
before making the campaign what all
things should be cleared let's discuss
okay so you can create all these kind of
campaigns or with all these goals inside
the Google ads which we have just
learned how to be creating the account
okay how the account is created we can
create the campaign to increase the
sales we can in we can increase the
leads by running the ads you can
increase our website traffic we can work
for the product branding or a
consideration we can also work for brand
awareness and app promotion okay these
are the subdefined goals or predefined
goals before we jump into the campaign
making of a search or a display or a
video okay I I hope this all these all
are very much defined or self-defined
one so I don't have to be you know
telling you what is sales and what is
branding and what is awareness but still
if you feel so in a in a while I will
just going to throw some light on it
okay then
setting up the ad group so I'll be just
making all this practically with you so
we don't again you know have to be
understanding all this now coming to
some of the metrics which you would see
inside
the campaign once that is created so
let's just go back and
see one of the
ads from any of my clients so that we
can learn better
only I'll just open in a different tab
okay so if I just have to show you
probably I can just use right now the
demo account of assembly where important
metrics
we can discuss which which has already
been given in the PPT but of course I
would just show you how they look like
inside the campaigns or inside the
Google ads account so if we move to the
dashboard when we have created and if we
have already been running any campaigns
and we want to see results or any of the
metrics then what we do we go into all
campaigns
and from here we can see all sort of
campaigns created in the past okay
because I wanna see only the results
from the search campaigns because there
are all kind of campaigns been created
here like video campaigns and display
and all so what I can do I can click
this
this law of uh navigation menu on the
top left
and then I can just select the search
campaigns
when this is selected
only these search campaigns would be
visible
now if I just go on any of the campaign
suppose inside
then this breadcrumbs changes earlier I
was only in the all campaigns then I
just selected search campaigns and now
inside the search campaigns I have
selected a specific campaign okay so
considering suppose this was the
campaign I have run in the January for
any of my digital marketing sales okay
or any of my product sales or any of my
services lead generation XYZ objectives
could have been okay now coming to the
main part
from the metrics point of view so we see
here that there are
results been shown of course because
this is a demo account so you don't see
numbers we can always change the dates
like suppose I wanna see the uh result
of last 30 days so I would just go here
and this would show these many
Impressions have come Impressions like
how many times the ad is just been seen
okay impression means just how many
times the ad been seen okay then it
would show how many times the ad
actually been clicked okay how many
times had been clicked assuming 100
times The Impressions have come and two
clicks have come so the percentage which
is basically a ratio of a clicks to
impression is called CTR
the click-through rate which is the next
one
clicks impression and CTR okay so
click-through rate is the ratio of
impression to clicks your ad been shown
hundred of times or 100 times probably
but only click today for three times so
your CTR is three percent your ad been
shown
100 times but been clicked seven times
so your CTR is seven percent which is a
very good number okay anything around 5
to 10 is good okay we don't get to see
lot of Clicks in our initial days
because people do trust the brands which
are already established but slowly
gradually with the right branding with
the right awareness our click rate
increases our CTR increases okay then
comes your average CPC which certainly
you would see here as well so average
CPC is a price which you actually end up
in paying for every click
okay so there is a bid value bid value
means when you started to create your
account or with a campaign of a search
then you decide for certain keywords
that how much money you would pay for
every click okay that is called a bid
price which we certainly see here okay
and once you start getting the clicks
after running your campaign then the
exact pricing been shown as a average
CPC price okay then comes the cost cost
is basically going to be your
multiplication of number of clicks
you've got with the average CPC you have
paid suppose you have got 100 clicks
today and for every click you paid five
rupees
so 100 into 5 going to be 500 or if you
uh understand by the dollars so suppose
for every click you have paid one USD so
for 100 clicks you pay 100 USD by the
end of a day okay that is going to be
your day cost or average cost you have
paid for
particular ad on a particular day that
is also understood by saying daily
budget you have spent okay so if I have
allotted that I would pay 900 rupees a
day and 9 900 rupees a day in the
average of the CPC if I would have
probably 10 Rupees so I will get 90
clicks okay because 90 clicks into 10
Rupees for a click going to exhaust my
900 per day budget if this would have
been 100 dollars
and then 100 clicks multiplied by one
dollar will going to exhaust my hundred
dollars per day okay this is how Google
calculates like for how much uh budget
you want to run the ad for and on
various factors your average cost per
click is decided okay this is the uh
understanding of all these terms cost
per conversion and conversion depends
that how your next step actually been
designed so by Next Step I mean suppose
if I talk about this particular ad only
a person clicks and person reaches here
okay so we can Define the conversions
like suppose 100 people have reached
here on the landing page this means 100
clicks would have happened okay so the
dashboard would say
thousand Impressions 100 clicks one
rupee 100 rupee okay one rupee being the
average CPC 100 clicks we have received
and we have spent 100 rupees but it
doesn't mean that all those 100 clicks
which actually
took the users to the landing page would
have been converted okay so when the
conversion code has been placed on the
confirmation page which opens after the
conversion happens or after the goal
completes so that actually tells us how
many people got converted or how many
people actually uh fulfilled or
completed our objective of goal whatever
it was lead generation sales download
brochure any of the subscriptions any of
the ctOS you talk about okay
so talking about the numbers suppose
only three people or two people or two
users have filled this data okay so the
numbers in my dashboard would be like
1000 Impressions have been shown 100
clicks have come means 100 people have
reached to the landing page but only two
conversions have happened okay and the
cost for all the clicks would be like
100 rupees because average CPC was one
rupee okay so when the conversion is two
then we can say that our conversion rate
was two percent why because out of 100
clicks I was only able to get two people
across the confirmation page or across
that CTA which was a call to action of
buy now shop now or sign up or download
whatever it was that is called a
convergence and conversion rate two
percent cost per conversion can only
also be divided like two conversions
I've got in 100 rupees so my cost per
conversion would be 50 rupees okay my
average CPC is one my clicks been
hundred my Impressions been thousand my
CTA been ten percent how 100 divided by
1000 CT or ten percent I have a CPC one
cost becomes 100 rupees my conversions
been two that's why my conversion rate
is two percent and my cost per
conversion comes like 50 why because
I've got two conversions on the spent of
100 that brings 50 rupees here
I hope this is clear if I have to just
demonstrate
you just wait
so that this is basically you know
uh been captured in your heads with more
clarity so I'm just going to
use a normal example
impressions
the same numbers which I just explained
so that you know
okay so this is Cosmic conversion
suppose your ad received thousand
impressions today 100 clicks have come
so your CTR becomes ten percent because
that is how this is calculated clicks by
Impressions where our CPC was one rupee
or it has
a billion dollars so your cost would be
100 rupees
or hundred dollars
you've got two conversions means two
people or two users have bought anything
or have subscribed or have just you know
completed that call to action and the
conversion rate for that reason would be
2 divided by 100 so 2 percent
and cost per conversion in this case
would be 50 rupees because you have paid
100 rupees for two conversions and in
this case it would be 50 dollars just a
hypothetical number did not be very much
worried about the numbers okay with the
high priest okay this would change
certainly when we do the research of our
keywords
okay
now coming
to the part how now these ads been
created that's the most important part
how we create a beautiful ad copies and
all that okay so we go
into the campaign making by all campaign
and then we click on a campaign
we will click on a new campaign
Google ads most of the time works low
nowadays so you have to be a bit patient
with this and then we click on a create
campaign without a goal guidance or we
can always click website traffic lead
sales okay these all four can be created
uh for the Google ad search campaign you
know we can only use these four for the
search app because if I'll just click
this this will not allow me to create
search and this only allows video ad if
I'll click this this only allows display
and video ad this only allows mobile ad
and this is for the local so if I have
to create a search ad like this or a
text ad like this so I have to be either
creating through sales leads or website
or either without a guidance so I'll
just going to be teaching you all the
settings inside so that you know the
Google ads uh you know search ad
settings in advanced level so I'm just
taking without a rule
then you click search ads
our focus is just to create search ad
you can leave this part right now
because your conversions are not being
created we'll do in maybe in the next
session when we'll talk about the
advanced settings and website visit is
my Premiere goal and suppose I'm running
we add for any of these sites probably
I'm running the ad for
thank you
just see if I can get this simple
learning page so this is my remote
search
marketing
just terminal guys
yeah digital marketing
course
click on continue
and then the very first thing you see
bidding which we have just learned that
we pay on the cost per click basis so
clicks
and you can always set up your
bid limit that I do not want to pay more
than suppose one rupee a click or two
rupee a click or five rupee attack
okay and there is another
thing which we have to be discussing
before we talk about the bid limit so
let me just take you to the
Keyword Planner so this comes from here
tool settings
Keyword Planner so that we get an
overview that how much actually we
should be paying for every keyword we
are running the ad for suppose my
keyword for which I want to run the ad
is digital marketing code that is the
Premier keyword or the most searched
keyword by which
the ads of a competitors also are
showing and also I want to show my ad
for okay so what I would do I would just
go into this beautiful tool I again
repeat my steps I can just go tool in
settings
Keyword Planner open in a right tab why
so that your existing campaign settings
are not Disturbed okay you come here you
click this and you click discover new
keywords and you search your term like
digital marketing course
click get results
and then you are able to see
digital marketing course in the period
of last one year in India of course you
can change the country to U.S Canada
Australia anywhere and you would see in
the last one year how many search
queries on a monthly basis have come for
this particular keyword in addition you
see lot of suggestions as well suppose
we're just sticking around one keyword
right now to understand the bid part and
all so we see that we got around 1
million searches in India for this
particular keyword with the competition
of medium competition medium means that
most of the advertisers who are selling
this digital marketing course been
running the ad for the This this term or
not if this competition would have been
high then I should have ignored this or
would have changed the keyword but this
is medium so I would take this and this
you know talks about the bid value this
is the low term and this is the high
term like low price means this is the
lowest price any of the advertisers
would have paid this year for this
particular term to show the ad and this
is the highest bid price which any of
the advertisers would have paid in this
year for this term so they doesn't tell
which part of year it was which
Advertiser it was but at least we get a
fair idea that our bid value would be
around 46 to 195 so we go bit smart
we go on the average price suppose a bit
46 so I'll just go 30 40 over this price
so suppose I take 30 percent around 12
rupees or 13 rupees so that makes it 15
and around 60 rupees so this is the
build value I am aiming 60 rupees plus
what I do I take some of the keywords
which I feel like from a naked eye at
this moment are very important for my
campaign just like I take this I take
this I take this
no you can just take any of them
you can download this data into Excel
and copy paste as well so there are a
lot of ways to do this
okay and then you can certainly
just name the new ad group and they
would be added to it or otherwise it is
very easy
that we just copy them from here okay
there are ways to do it so this is the
simplest of the way suppose I just liked
all these keywords from my product point
of view and I like the pricing as well
so what I would do I would just copy
this
copying this
and then putting into maybe here
so when there would be a space you know
when the campaign would ask me please
tell me for which keyword you want to
run the ad
certainly it would come here when we are
done with these two settings then I
don't have to waste time I will just go
here and copy these keyword and paste in
here under the keywords okay I can take
more but before you know the time
exhaust because I have a uh you know in
my head that I have to complete all the
campaign settings and everything within
one hour so that you are not bored of
this and I want that energy level to be
on a higher side so you can do this
research probably and you can also you
know add a lot of keywords you know
dependent on how much you know you wanna
actually leverage from them and as well
more keywords means you end up in paying
your budget uh you know in a very quick
basis so it's important that we
segregate them from the monthly searches
High monthly searches keywords are
always important because the demand is
high and then we always check the
competition should not be higher okay so
I probably would not take these you know
because these are high ones okay I can
delete and I can always aim the low ones
like medium medium medium and medium so
I can just take this okay so copy and
we'll be replacing these
because I got the better keywords now as
compared to the other ones because they
had the high competition keywords as
well so I'm just now aiming the medium
keywords with the higher searches and I
have just decided that I would give the
bid value or a highest bid cap of a 60
rupees because I have just seen the
average that if I have to rank for this
particular one or probably this one or
probably this one you know which are on
the higher side then I should be paying
40 50 extra as you know compared to the
low priced okay so that is how the bid
value is calculated roughly okay anyhow
you would only pay to uh you know
outrank your competitor that's how the
algorithm works like you will not going
to pay high amount it is like if three
advertisers are bidding on a certain
term then if the next one to you is
paying 2 rupee or two dollars so just to
outrank him you would end up in paying
some amount over it like 2.1 or 2.2 it
is not like that you would be paying 40
rupees so that's how the algorithm
calculates okay you you put anything as
an account as a bid value but it will
only going to take I have a CPC
depending on how the competitors are
working and how their pricing is being
given okay so just on a safer side we
give our average price but moreover to
save the cost of the CPC we work on the
quality score or on the quality of our
content and on the ad which certainly is
a very important part okay so coming
back to the campaign making we come here
and we give a bit value suppose of 50
okay this is what we have seen or other
60 from that particular you know keyword
sheet from here 30 40 percent over this
particular keyword which is the most
important one for me and then I click
next
once this is done then I just select my
Google search Network I don't have to
select the Display Network because this
will going to put my text ad on the
different websites and apps Display
Network are good when we are running the
banner ad because we are just running
the search ad so we're just going to
keep it around the Google search result
and Google sites like Google News Google
Maps Google shop Google YouTube so all
the text ad wherever the placements can
be given so it will going to take
directly we don't put on our search
Partners too because that is again going
to lose the visibility search patterns
are like ask.com AOL New York times.com
okay so again you know it is my strategy
that I don't want to increase the
visibility outside Google I'm very happy
in showing my most of the Impressions
around Google only okay or either on a
Google widgets like these wherever the
text ad has a possibility just like you
might be wondering how come I said
YouTube so if I just go here and if I
just type again this so probably you
would see text ads on the top okay
nowadays there are a lot of Tech stats
been running so this is a tech start
okay this is not a video this is not a
banner ad this is the banner ad this is
the text ad okay so this is coming from
here only
Google sites okay then comes your
location you can run the ad on different
locations by you know sitting anywhere
suppose I want to run that for the
worldwide then I'll select all countries
and territories if I want to select
particular country like India or I want
to select multiple countries like
suppose United States
or I wanna select
Canada
or I wanna select India too
so I can do this way
Okay then if I want to exclude any of
these states probably suppose I wanna X2
Texas from here so I'll click Texas and
I'll click exclude
I wanna
exclude probably
uh Mumbai
so Mumbai as a city can be excluded
and probably I wanna exclude Ontario
from Canada
because of XYZ reasons just to explain
the settings I'm doing this so this is
also done
okay then we also can use advanced
search where a beautiful setting of
radius can be worked and the second
advantage of advances tab is that you
are able to see the map so whatever you
have selected like we have selected
Canada and us and whatever you have
deselected or excluded will come in red
blue part included red part X2 did the
same way you would see in India as well
blue part included and this small dot
Mumbai excluded okay plus we can do the
radius targeting here suppose I sell
something within the radius of one or
two kilometers or one or two miles so I
have to just select that part suppose if
I just deselect India right now
and deselect the Mumbai exclusion as
well and consider that I have a
restaurant or a cake shop in Delhi
and probably I will also add this
keyword into my keywords so that that
matches the term if anybody searches
this I have to be seeing the character
limits that's why you have to be always
checking and changing things accordingly
okay then digital marketing Google
then simply learn till
marketing
digital
on a course verbally if we can get that
space
okay
then going down and we can always see
where we are lacking right now so we
have not very good headlines been added
including popular keywords been there
description works well so let's see what
they give us is the idea like
so they say
we are not given any online availability
brand call to actions okay I'm just
going to play with some of the terms now
so let's just see
from CTA using the ctnr
you can see the strength has improved
learn
I don't know it is actually
pausing my recording again and again and
that could be disturbance for you guys
so I'm just taking some time so that
this comes back to normal
yes
okay so this is how you can add up to
headlines 10 headlines and that would
improve your ad strength and last not
least you can add the descriptions which
are very relevant to the ad copy okay
try to get some headlines or
descriptions here from the landing page
okay once this is done you can just
click done here
and your ad copy is prepared you can see
here very much and click next
and then you can set up your budget so
the budget which we were talking earlier
in the Excel if I have to show you so
you got 100 clicks you have paid one
rupee for every click so you have given
100 rupees per day so this is your daily
budget which you have spent okay so you
can always decide your daily budget by
setting or customizing it you can put
anything though it is showing dollars
but this is INR you can see here this is
kind of a bug which we are seeing since
almost a month now so your average daily
cost which they say like a weekly cost
rather after 41 multiplying by 33 for
every CPC price would come to 1382 but
we are giving a daily price so we can
always divide this by seven or you know
by 10 probably so I'm just giving a
rough number 100 okay or thousand could
have been you know 500 also because it's
been given okay
so every day I would spend 500 and
accordingly my clicks you know would
come and then you click next
and your ad goes to review like they
would going to be checking your landing
page they would be checking your uh you
know uh what else the ad copy everything
can be checked and would take some time
I think I just need to change that
let me just keep it
5 am
so this is simpler
and then just click next
and publish the campaign from here
publish
so once this is done
then your ad which can be checked from
here
would go into a review part and it would
say
under review
once this is approved then your ad start
showing and you start seeing the results
like impression clicks and CTR obviously
PC whatever we have talked about okay so
this is all about the hard making now we
can see some of the important things
there like Matrix we have discussed
all these we have discussed CPC
conversions cost per conversions
CTR the only thing which will notice is
the quality score so quality score is
you know completely
um the part at the backend which works
like to improve our ranking so quality
score is something which has been given
out of 10 and when we see a ad which is
already been created like suppose for
this campaign if I'll take you so if I
just go to the keywords
so every keyword been given quality
score out of 10.
okay so if any of the keyword has got 10
out of 10 it means there are three
important elements like their CTR like
how many clicks have come their landing
page and their ad copy is relevant or
not okay they see three elements how
relevant the landing page is how
relevant is the ad copies and certainly
they see how relevant being the ad copy
with the search then only your CTR
increases somebody searches something in
the art shows and if the clicks are high
then only CTR goes high so that's why
the CTR the landing page and the address
has to be above average that's how you
know they Define they don't give Marks
here they give total marks out of 10
here the quality score so above average
is going to be the highest average going
to be the middle one and the below
average is going to be the lowest one
okay so if you have any issues uh in any
of these elements then your overall
quality score impacts okay this is all
the all disco so high quality score
means you end up in paying less and you
get a better value for your money okay
that's I think the last part of it so
Google ad ratings of quality of your ads
keyword and landing pages I think this
is what I've been given here as well
then you check I have already shown you
you check the keyword you tell the
timing which which were the best timing
you have from the ad which was the best
locations your ad has actually got the
result from and then accordingly your ad
can be optimized and can be changed you
change your budget you change your bid
price you change your location you
change your timing you change your
headline it all depends after your ad
actually been shown and then you
research or you do the analysis like you
know we are seeing which keyword is
working better which keyword is having
the best of the cost which keyword is
giving you the good impression to
interaction rate like a CTR then we
check the ad copy you know how the ad is
working suppose if I have multiple ads
to just compare if this ad works better
or this ad works better this ad works
better so I would just going to
be comparing these three ads which one
has given me the better of the clicks as
compared to the other one which has
given me the better CTR whose CPC was
lesser who CPC was higher that is how I
will be checking it okay I can always
have number of ads created under the
campaign just like are we right now we
have created one campaign one ad we can
always test with the another ad copy by
clicking this so that we can see which
ads performs better okay that's why in
this existing account you can see
multiple ads so because we were testing
which one works better so this is how
you can also make one other AD copy and
you can just click done and that would
be added to the list of ads
okay you can see now one more ad
actually been added so out of these two
which one works better would be only uh
diagnosed or checked if the ad starts
running okay you can always add your
account the you know money the the
billing part into the student settings
building summary
and from here you just need to add your
mode of payment okay you have to select
your country you have to select the
currency you know you are paying in and
then of course you would have options to
pay like debate money transfer net
banking and India paytm qualities also
available very much available
introducing simple lens post graduate
program in digital marketing that will
transform you into Master of the digital
realm this comprehensive program crafted
by industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast paced digital realm
enroll in a postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below hey guys
welcome to today's session
my name is Sachin sehgal and I'm here to
talk about a very important tool Google
ads and out of all the ads we can create
under Google ads today we would be
talking about a very important one
Google search ad
this is going to be very exciting this
is going to be very deep from my
experience I can say I will going to
take you through a lot of technical
aspects and a lot of optimization
strategies where you can really bring
down the cost down if you're really
paying high for your clicks and
conversion so please be with me and I
would try to give you the best from my
site great so let's just start guys
Google ads is something which we have
discussed in the last class if you have
seen my last session if you have not we
will leave the link in the description
where we talked about the basics of
Google ads and we also talked about how
to create this beautiful ad account or a
tool with a free Gmail ID okay
we did talked about few more things that
how many types of ads you can create
just to give you the quick glimpse we
are on Google and when we type something
like if I want to do a data analytics
course
so I would type few things like a word
or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called Tech Stat or
this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online
so then there would be results but in a
different shape and color and different
structure there is an ad which is a text
ad but on the top we are able to see
some more ads but they are not just text
they have a pricing they have a title
they have a brand name they have an
image of the product so they are called
shopping ads or product listing ads in
addition to that sometimes you know when
you go to a product a website like speed
test and you see the product ads there
but again in the different shape and
color so they are called
display ads because they've been
displayed on different websites and
different apps so why I'm going so fast
in explaining you different type of ads
because as I told you we have another
video created uh with the name of Google
ads for beginners 2023 you can just
check the link in the description and
you will able to get all this type of
ads and whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just
has to show you if you can see that ads
by Google so this is the display Adder
Banner just quickly I have shown you
three types of the ads but our Focus as
I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which
is the most important ad from the Google
ads family okay so let's just begin guys
when I come to Google ads this is how
the Google ad structure looks like
we have a Google ads account created
again I repeat if you don't know how to
create it please find the link in the
description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if we are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learned Google ads manager
so I am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply learn
probably you have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simple
an ad here so data analytics course
India
and then probably we can see if there
are any
you can always change the keywords but
just to test time randomly changing the
words or I could have just written
simply learned specifically because I
want to go with simple learn only I have
researched a lot and I feel like this is
one of the best okay so probably there
is no ad though
still I would check
probably I have to just change the codes
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can expect any of the ads
running
because this is not a very peak time so
we are probably you know saving some of
the cost not running the ads at this odd
hour anyhow so we can assume that this
is the ad you know I am running for so
how we can create this ad how we can get
the best of clicks as I said it is not
the very best time to run the ad so this
is also kind of a change you know we can
bring into our ads by doing some
research so how all these things are
done we're going to be learning it okay
so when we come here to the dashboard
and when we see our dashboard looks like
this a bit complicated so we can be
confused we can be disheartened that I
have created the account by seeing uh
the first video but now I am all stuck
okay so probably I have to again wait so
the weight is over now we are here to
understand the whole structure okay so
let me just take a very simple example
suppose I uh I'm someone who's selling a
shoes okay because I have just said
simply learn probably let's just convert
it to any of the Google ads account of a
shoe seller probably I am Nike okay and
I am making the add for Nike shoes and I
am selling two types of the Nike shoes
today probably formal or Canvas OR
probably I am selling the casual or any
sports shoes and what I did I created
the campaign named it search ad
uh any month you know whatever the month
you have started with suppose November
so November 2022 that is the name which
I am giving name can be changed name is
something which is being put it up for
my reference so that after creating a
lot of campaigns I'm not confused in
which campaign I have to check the
results okay so I'm running the search
art for shoes for the month of February
or November or December 22 23 whatever
and then I open two ad groups into it
why I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I am
selling formal also
under the shoes only I am selling casual
also so what happens suppose I would
have just you know created one art group
and would have inserted or submitted all
the keywords of formal and Casual inside
one hat group then if somebody would
have searched a term called formal black
shoes then this ad group would have got
confused that should I show formal as
shoes or should I show casual ad shoes
because what I did I have just got all
my keywords like formal casual Cricket
shopping jogging party office you know
all the mix of the keywords from formal
and Casual family into the same ad group
the moment any of these six keywords
being typed or been searched on Google
then this ad group would have got
triggered and then again randomly it
would have shown the ad of a formal or
ad of a casual because both of the ads
would have been under this okay but
after doing uh this bifurcation or after
doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here
this ad group would trigger if any of
this keyword would search and
accordingly this ad which has everything
related to only formal shoes will be
shown and of course with that ad the
landing page is connected which would be
open you know when somebody clicks the
ad okay and vice versa if somebody would
have searched for a casual term like a
casual shoes sports shoes jogging shoes
running shoes then this ad group would
have triggered and then the casual shoes
ad with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shoes you know would have opened okay so
if this is clear actually you are very
much ready to uh dive into the Google
ads because many people takes a lot of
time to understand the structure because
uh you know maybe they are very much
confused at the art group level but I
have just tried level based by bringing
this example why I am creating two
different ad groups I why I'm not just
going with the same ad group you know
mixing all the keywords
second scenario could have been on a
second permutation could have been I I
would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign all together and I would have
named it campaign search ad
casual shoes November then this second
campaign or a second campaign can be
assumed here with you know with a green
color would have been drawn okay so this
is how on the structure it works like we
can always now create inside so let's
just see a few things uh before we
create the ad okay very important uh
requirement or rather I would say uh if
being the campaign manager of any any
any any company you name any startup you
name or any client you work with or
probably for yourself as well you have
to be very much sure how these terms
works like Okay so this terms when I
talk about is going to be a bit inclined
towards the search ad today only and
when I talk about the display ad in the
next video then I would you know take
you through about the terminologies and
all the kpis off display Banner or video
ads okay so now if I talk about a search
ad a very important
um term which we should be aware of is
the maximum bid price
okay because we all know when we're
talking about this ad which is called a
text ad then we are paying on every
click okay that's why this is also
called PPC ad this is also called PPC
marketing or you can understand in a
very simple words uh Advertiser which is
Emirates this in this particular ad only
has to pay when somebody like Sachin
this movement clicking this ad I click
this ad I reach to the landing page of
this particular University or this
college and a certain amount is deducted
from this particular ad account and that
certain amount actually decides or
decided on the basis of the keyword
helped to show this ad okay so as an
Advertiser must have paid something to
Google ads for showing this ad for this
keyword okay so when I say a maximum bit
price it means it's a maximum bid price
of a keyword that's why now this would
be easier to understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course 2022 what I
did I have opened the Google Keyword
Planner you know I did talked about this
in the previous session but I will take
you through again how you use a Keyword
Planner smartly so I have got this data
from the keywords planner that the
average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bidded something over
the minimum bit price okay this is the
minimum bit price is the maximum bit
price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take a chance maybe 30 40
over the minimum bit range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bid price but
coming back to the terminologies what
we're talking here is once I have set it
up my maximum bit price of 7 rupees then
my ad would start showing suppose my ad
shows for thousand times today and every
time when my ad been clicked you know
certain amount being deducted there is a
competition there are other advertisers
also you know who are running the ad and
after showing my ad for the whole day
Google in the dashboard just shown that
you have paid average CPC of 5 rupees
only so I bid it for 7 but by seeing
different uh you know factors like the
competition the demand and how many
times the ads got clicked what was the
position where my ad was shown I ended
up in paying five rupees for every Click
by the end of a day so the average CPC
sometimes you know people get confused
they have a CPC and the maximum
Enterprise is the same no so maximum bit
price is something which I uh you know
submit to Google that this is the
maximum I can pay for my add to show on
certain keyword for every click and I
have a CPC something which actually you
know I pay every day or you know in that
average of the duration your ad got
displayed or got clicks for every uh
click on that particular keyword okay or
the number of keywords if you have more
than one keyword submitted and suppose
I've got 100 clicks then you know it's a
simple math that my budget which I have
spent today is five rupees for one click
500 rupees 400 click so daily budget
would be 500 rupees and tomorrow if
company says I need 300 clicks then of
course my average CPC which I have from
the historical date of yesterday you
know I would just do my maths and I will
going to submit the daily budget of not
100 rather 300 today so that in 1500 I
can expect 300 clicks at the cost of 5
rupees per click okay so this is a very
simple of the example you just make you
explain how things works you know you
submit something then on the basis of a
lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds the screenshots over so
your Keyword Planner opens and then you
discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
course and then I'll click the get
result and then accordingly it will show
me a lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and the high price so I
would take the 30 40 percent over the
low bid price or the average price
between these both and that would be my
maximum bit price and after checking all
the permutations Google would show my ad
or either it would not show my ad also
there can be a chance so I have to just
wait for my impression and clicks and
the results by the end of a day and I
would you know I would know how much the
average CPC actually I'm paying for each
keyword okay so I'll show you all those
reports in a while that's it right now
let's just go and see few things so the
Keyword Planner will start with suppose
I start
you know in researching all these things
my campaign is about data analytics
course
I'm making it for CM probably and I
would go and I would just try to you
know search into planning my Keyword
Planner and then I will write a term
quickly here you know whatever I want to
show my ad for
suppose data analytics course as I said
okay probably let's say digital
marketing because we would have more
results so it's
easy to understand with a lot of results
because I would be able to tell you how
to sort and filter them down uh digital
marketing course and you can just test
it with any of the keywords I'm just
doing a random check
so once we are here we have a lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know
monthly searches and of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the you
know in the month of 2021 to September
22 so this is actually the average
monthly searches happened in between
this period and uh the advertise is
actually paid as low as 44 Rupees to as
high 20 224 rupees okay that can easily
be uh you know converted to dollars uh
half a dollar or maybe more than half a
dollar UH 60 70 cents probably and this
is like going to be a three dollars cost
okay so what we can do is we can see now
there are a lot of keywords been given
and we can easily sort them down here on
certain you know bases like you know
suppose the monthly searches are high or
the bid is low and all that
but this is quite you know difficult
when we have to sort down here in the
Keyword Planner so what I do is I'm just
going to talk about the same you know
like hi how I actually go when I am
working for my clients okay I have
clients here a lot of clients I don't
want to show you but yeah I have and um
suppose I just go and download this data
from here
and then this would be you know uh
downloaded in the Excel format and we
can just save it anywhere suppose I just
bring it here and then now I would open
the keyword sheet
and I would have a data in my Excel okay
so I need this this one so this is the
most important column because I have to
highlight uh which column is important
and what is not required right now so
whatever is required I'm just I'll be
keeping with me and what I feel like is
not very important as of now I'm just
not going to be taking them so now there
are
five column which I have kept with
myself like
4 where we talk about the results
okay
this is not required this is not
required so I'm just going to be
deleting or hiding them okay so when we
talk about uh competition index value so
this actually tells us that a particular
keyword is how much uh you know from the
competition point of view is difficult
to rank suppose I talk about two
keywords right now let me just take
um a one with a lower score suppose this
one and I would take the higher or the
highest one probably is this one okay so
now when I talk about a comparison you
know probably uh or or probably let's
say this this one because this has a
monthly searches which are equivalent uh
you know from the uh compression point
of view they are very different but the
search has been same so if I would stuck
to something of this sort that if I have
to finalize between these two so what I
would do you know that's something which
we are talking here you know if we have
a kind of a combination where we have to
decide out of these two so both of uh
the keywords have been very important if
I would just check from my naked eye a
quick Scan they look very promising they
look very great to me suppose and they
have a equivalent number of searches in
the last you know one year on the
average monthly basis but there is a
difference between the competition okay
now people can be confused what is this
competition so I would just make you
explain in a very simpler way Suppose
there are 100 companies so there are 100
you know ethic institutes or probably
physical institutes who teaches uh
digital marketing because we are doing
online marketing or you know digital
marketing course online so so let's keep
it online uh institutes like simply
learn and all okay so what they have
done is in the last one year they all
have used these keywords to run their
ads you know to show their advertisement
or their digital ad on a Google space
okay when this data has been given so
this is telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100 competitors
66 or a 66 percent advertisers have used
this ad
okay or have used this keyword to show
their ad okay and out of 100 33 or if it
is 100 then 33 advertisers have used
this keyword to show their ad okay so it
brings you know kind of a comparison to
US that probably these two keywords are
very much in demand you know like
equally from the searches point of view
because both have been searched equally
but whenever this has been searched then
there has been a competition where 66
people or 66 advertisers or 66 percent
advertisers are fighting to show their
ad okay and when this keyword being
searched as equally then only 33 percent
or 33 people or 33 advertisers are
fighting to show their ad on Google
space okay when I talk about 100 then it
seems to be okay where my AdWords look
like you know where my ad would show
because if I just go on a Google space
you know that only seven ads are shown
when you know when we go on a Google
search engine one two three and four and
then the rest three would be at the
bottom if they are shown at this moment
or not I'm not very sure so three would
be here somewhere so total seven adds
placement on the first page nobody goes
beyond first we know that 97 of the
worldwide audience don't don't go beyond
the first pagination okay so we have to
be on our first page so if I talk about
from the first page seven positions
point of view it would make more sense
so let's imagine there are only 10
advertisers of digital marketing course
so out of 10 if I take out 66 66 percent
then it means almost like six to seven
advertisers are fighting or have bidded
or probably are trying to outrank each
other to show their ad on the top or on
the first four versions of Google but
when I talk about this then only three
to four advertisers are fighting or have
bidded for this keyword to show the ad
on the first page so this actually is a
very important data sometimes we just
you know Miss it because it has not been
uh I think explained anywhere else that
what exactly this value is we only go by
the low medium high which is the very
first column I delete nowadays you know
I don't you know go by this because they
both come under the medium but there is
a big difference you know seven out of
10 would have been bidded for and only
three to four would have been bidded for
this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
okay that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best searched keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bit
value or a bit price which is also on a
very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we'll try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bid price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30 to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30 to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
in the first if the Impressions has come
it means my price actually been accepted
but if any of the keyword my price is
not accepted then I would again revise
the price by 20 30 and then would wait
from the secondary report and that's how
you know I keep changing for the first
two three days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know it starts getting the stable
results then I uh just allow the
campaign to work uh you know on the
algorithm and uh you know I I see uh
results actually moves in the positive
direction when you give some time to
campaigns to read and to learn uh you
know from the audience Behavior okay so
this is about the keyword planning which
we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus is more on
this uh presentation parallely I would
keep showing you the uh you know uh the
uh Google ads other demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the
um add algorithm point of view so what
happens or what used to happen uh when
when the quality score you know which
I'm just trying to speak now I was not
there uh what used to happen the one who
used to pay the highest bid price used
to get the first position and the second
one used to get the second position and
the third bidder used to get the third
position so I have just brought into
this table suppose a Advertiser has been
at 8 rupee B10 C 15 and D 20 and when
the quality score concept was not there
so they actually been given the very
direct position this one first this one
second this one third and this one
fourth but they have realized or Google
has realized that the one who is paying
the most is not having a very good
quality of the ad uh his uh landing page
or the website it's is not working or
probably the pages which is which are
connected are not very relevant and the
keywords on which the ads been shown is
nowhere near uh you know when the
landing page is open so it it was like a
very negative impact on Google when the
reviews been checked and people or the
users who are clicking on those ads were
not happy so what Google did Google
brought us you know kind of um uh test
score or a check which is called quality
score for every keyword we bid okay and
this is only for the server chats that's
why I said on all the keywords we made
okay
I'll just show you the result on a
client side so when we submit our ad on
the basis of you know different keyword
we bid and the and the strategy we use
and the landing page we connected the
backend so what the system does is
system starts analyzing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I will just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every Advertiser here is
bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let's
um assume that they all are running the
ad for the digital marketing course so
what would happen they would check and
on the basis of the you know factors
they would give a score out of 10.
suppose the a Advertiser who bid it for
the least had the best of the quality
score because of the reasons we'll just
going to talk about B got 8 out of 10 4
out of 10 and 2 out of ten so the one
who have bidded the most got for the
very least quality score probably the
reasons you know would be more clear
once we talk so how this allow we're
going to impact the whole position
system is that their Google rank not
Google position okay there is a Google
rank kind of uh kPa can be understood
your Matrix which is a product or a
multiplication of what you bid and how
much quality score you were able to get
so 8 into 9 being 72 10 into 8 brings 80
15 into 4 bring 60 and 20 into 2 is 40.
okay so the combination of a good
pricing and a good quality score got B
bidder as a first position okay and the
one who got the best quality score but
still paying very less from the average
price in globally is you know brought
the Google position or add position to
Second and then the one who was spraying
very high but the quality score was
below average which is a Force 5 6 is
average price average score they've got
into third position and the one who was
paying so High probably would not get a
position because this is the maths from
the match point if we have got these
numbers if the quality score would have
been below 5 then the ad would not have
got any position rather because Google
always tries to you know show the ads
which are the best uh for the users you
know because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users
um you know expectations so and when I
said that I think you were able to
understand more now how the factors you
know which which actually results in
these quality score is
um like relevant score like by relevant
score means when you type a query or a
person would come here would type a
query so he doesn't know that this is
called a keyword we as a digital
marketers know this is called a keyword
for them it is a normal query because
they are about to start a course where
they would be taught about all these
things but right now they are not very
aware you know very much aware of these
things so they are putting a query when
they put the query they want to see the
ad or ad extensions or a description
relevant to what they have searched and
when they see all these three things
here with the search uh you know what
they made they would definitely going to
click more and Google only earns when
somebody clicks so it means Google
making Revenue only when somebody is
clicking so from that perspective also
Google always tries to pay you know or
rather give more score and give a better
position to the ads where all the
components of the ads are perfect are
relevant and the ones who starts getting
more clicks in the very first hour or a
first day okay so the important factor
which after the click is the landing
page so when somebody opens this so it
has to be very relevant to this query
and do whatever being shown outside they
cannot just show anything here which is
not relevant to the ad which has
actually been shown outside so all these
you know factors in combination gives
the quality score very important factor
is CTR which you must have understood
when you know we I added you know
explained in the last session the basic
one but if you do not aware of it so CTR
is called click through rate okay and a
click through rate is a ratio of clicks
to impression okay it is a ratio of
clicks to impression
just a spell check okay so suppose today
when we are saying ABCD so let's see
these are this is the a or this is B and
this is C and I've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their ad their description
everything is very much common so Google
in the starting of the day you know when
the ad actually started to show for
everyone uh you know giving them a very
good quality score probably of five okay
and when this quality score of 5 been
given to them then the other factor
which actually adds on you know to that
algorithm is the CTR so CTR is I just
told you is the ratio between click to
impression so now they all have a same
quality score but this got 100 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions been
given today this got 50 clicks out of
the Thousand Impressions given today
this got by any mean probably 200 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions given
today okay every time this this search
is happening here digital marketing
course so these
ads are very much visible equally so all
got thousand Impressions thousand
Impressions thousand Impressions but
this got 100 clicks they scored 50
clicks and this got 200 Clicks in the
very first hour or maybe in the next two
hours okay so this CTR you know when we
are talking about 100 out of 1000 to 10
percent This Is 50 out of thousand it
means this is going to be five percent
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of 1000 means
twenty percent of the CTR so Google was
actually benefited or made the most of
the revenue and you know clicks have
come from here because it is almost like
a double or a four times of this so
because of the high CTR the quality
score of a force you know every every
Advertiser would improve but this one
would be improved from probably from
five to seven and this would you know
probably from five to five point five
and this probably from five to six so
because of that quality score has
improved and uh you know because of the
high CTR this ad has got so this
position will be changed and this would
you know we probably would get the first
page on the second position and at the
end of a day this ad has to pay or
Advertiser has to pay lesser because
it's quality score increase we have just
seen it is you know almost like the uh
you know inversely proportional the ones
who are actually paying or the ones who
are having the best of the quality score
are paying the least or has to pay the
least okay so this is all basically you
know can be checked once your ad starts
running so I will just open the client's
account uh where you can just see this
with
you know better
understanding you were able to get out
of this
hopefully I'm able to show you from okay
I'll just see because I have multiple
advertisers you know
but I cannot just show for all so let me
just check if I can show you how many of
the older one
just wait it is actually asking you some
verification
okay
it's taking too much time
yeah it's just done now
so once this is done
so I'll just take you to one of the
accounts where
my main focus will just show you how the
quality score report look like and then
you know you know you will get a fair
idea but all the factors you have to be
focusing to bring your quality score
high or two take your qualities for high
okay
so I'm just going to open the search ads
because we're talking about a search ad
here only and suppose if I just go into
this
Campaign which is of course you know not
running right now but I just want to
show you how you check the report and
all suppose this is the campaign you
have run for and you got 75 clicks at um
you know
um app with CPC price of 40 PESA and you
have just given this much pricing and I
have put it for many keywords but I
wanna see which keyword had got the best
of the quality score and how the
qualities have been given and all okay
so once you reach to the keyword report
here you know at this level then you see
um uh you know uh the kpis or metrics
here which gives the quality score out
of 10. okay you can see here very well
and every keyword being given you know
if there are 10 keywords I don't know
how many keywords we made it for we've
bitted 50 keywords okay and you know you
can see all the keywords here and every
keyword being given the quality score
out of 10 okay because their CTR which
was the last part which I've explained
you the ratio between the impression two
clicks got the above average so they
give below average average above average
so above average is best actually for
any of the factors so the CTR is above
average the landing pages above average
and their ad is above average means all
are perfect then they got the 10. the
moment anything goes below average or
probably to the average suppose you can
see this is above average for them this
is above average for them but they're
landing page experience from this
keyword point of view is only average
their quality score has come to eight
okay if we go further down uh let's see
anything where two of them yeah so here
the kids ride on is a keyword where CTR
is also not as high or as great you know
to as compared to the other keywords
which we have seen and also the landing
page is not as relevant to the keyword
so there are two factors like ctrn
landing page has come to average as
compared to the Android 11s which is
above average so their whole qualities
for got impacted which actually came
down from 10 to 8 and then seven for
this particular keyword and last not PC
if I just take you to somewhere where
something is below average has come now
one is above average one is okay they
are getting clicks but probably the ad
is still not very much relevant to the
keyword okay so they are below average
above average has brought the quality
score to 6 out of 10 which certainly
would have you know impacted on the cost
and also to the position okay so this is
something which you would see
when you come here also you can check
one more thing here suppose you have
bidded for your keyword and your bid
price where you are paying for is
maximum bit price let me just see where
that column is
so otherwise I would just add that
column so that you can learn that part
as well
okay
[Music]
just wait okay so this is basically
CPC price is being given in the average
cost 2.50 is the cost for every click
and we got 249 clicks so got 623 you can
just check the maths it's always good to
cross check so 249 clicks multiplied by
the CPC price which is 2.50 rupee would
give you 6 22.5 which is the cost you
know or the keywords uh you know we beat
it for and the total clicks we have paid
okay and the
maximum beta price suppose you know you
have got uh the maximum bit price of uh
one rupee and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and
all and then what happens you wanna
secure your position suppose the very
first page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the position but you're not
getting the first page then here because
this campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talk about these three keywords right
now a particular one keyword uh I
suppose so this is something which I'm
you know trying to show on a one rupee
cost but to show on the first page it is
saying that you have to pay 1.5 okay to
show on the uh first four positions here
one two three four it is saying that
probably you have to pay 2.5 and to get
the absolute first position which is
going to be the top most it would tell
you that you have to probably pay five
rupees you know you bring one it is
asking 1.5 the first four it can be paid
for 2.53 or this has to be five so you
can always go and change your you know
bid price for the particular keyword
okay so there are ways to do it suppose
if I'll just go here and I just go to
the edit I can change my maximum CPC bit
price for this particular bid or a
keyword like 25 rupee okay because I'm
not changing for all the keywords so I
have selected that particular keyword
and I have made the change to this
particular keyword to five rupee so if
you know the average price was one and I
was not getting the keyword uh from this
keyword the position secured on the
first page or the first absolute
position and I want because this is the
most important keyword for me then I
would just come here and would check the
pricing okay this says five rupees you
have to pay for the top position so I
will just go here edit and would change
the bid price or a maximum CPC bit price
of this particular keyword you can do
for all you know you have to just of
course you know select all of course but
if you would do for all then it you can
really impact your whole budget okay so
try to go for the keywords where you
really feel like it is required and
always go by the quality score it has
you know it has a very good quality
score so I should be paying or I should
be ready in paying uh the maximum price
which actually Google is asking me to
pay to secure my first absolute position
and certainly that would increase the
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so conversions can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now now
I will just move to the campaign making
though we have done as I told you last
time but I will try to make it again so
that we can quickly see how the Google
ad search ads or the search Google ad
created okay so if I just go to the
campaign uh My Demo
account so if you just go to the Google
ads account the dashboard and then I
would come to the campaigns
I would just click Plus
new campaign
and whatever the you know
um objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate session
altogether so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we are
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with adding the extensions to the ad as
well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is just open safety
learns
uh landing page
so that I can make the ad for
simple generational marketing as a demo
ad of course not a
mean AD
so copying and just putting in here I
have to just put a you know website
domain that's it I don't have to bring
the whole landing page here and then I
can just name it probably November
search and
and then I will just go and continue
start new
and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks
and of course from my Excel I would
learn that okay my bid price which I'm
going to be paying uh you know uh is
certainly in the range of something like
probably 50 60 and I have just told you
that I bring my price kind of a thing
into this like I always bring like this
and then
let me just delete all the other columns
which are not required
so this is the sheet which I did explain
to earlier with the index value and all
so my price what is my price like so I
always pay 30 40 extra to the low bid
price so I can you know just get the
formula here like
this
Plus
this 30 percent
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 plus 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of x y z factors such
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum being 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I was going to
give the limit to my bid price and I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90. okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level
and then you move ahead
and you remove this because you just
want to keep your ad on the Google
search and then you go down you select
your countries you select your location
if you want to show the ad in all the
locations then you certainly can just go
and keep the very first option open
which is all countries and territories
if you want to just show your ad
um
in a particular country like you know
right now if I just go India so the
whole India would see your ad and if you
want to go for a manual locations like
suppose I want to select any of the
states or cities then what I would do I
would just probably take daily so Delhi
would be targeted like this okay or
probably I just want to Target the state
of Texas here so I just would go and
Target the whole state or if I want to
Target any of the provinces of Canada so
I would just go and take the uh
provinces of Ontario Canada and I would
just Target the whole Province and now
if I also want to go for any of the uh
PIN codes suppose I want to Target to a
certain pin code then I can just go and
Target the PIN codes like this so it is
up to us that we want to go worldwide or
if you want to go for a country specific
if you want to go for us State specific
or if you want to go as a province or a
pin code specific okay otherwise if you
suppose
um a restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and advance
search
and then you can go to radius and you
can just bring this whatever you
understand better in India we understand
kilometers better maybe the person us
would understand miles better so we just
go and take that two kilometer radius
and probably I am the cake shop in Delhi
so I'm just going to search my location
this is my location and now we're just
going to Target people around 2
kilometer because I don't deliver
outside two kilometers so it's all up to
us how we're gonna go uh this is called
radius targeting or geofencing when we
go to the locations we can also learn
one thing suppose I want to show the ad
to the
um whole country India I have targeted
at the same time I am not delivering in
um uh in in in Mumbai okay or probably
in Karnataka you know Bengaluru where
the city is okay or probably I'm not
delivering in any of the uh northern
states like haryana Himachal Punjab so
what I would do I would just take Punjab
suppose for example and I'm just going
to exclude that okay so what would
happen now my ad would show in all these
states and all the cities of India but
just not in Punjab okay so I can save it
that's how you go about the location
language is you know in which language
the users will uses the search engine
and all so you can keep it all languages
that's the best and
audience we don't cater here much
because we are doing the search ad which
actually shows the ad on the basis of
keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the more settings comes where you talk
about the add rotation so add rotation
is already default being selected as the
perform best ad uh if because the
nowadays the ad actually been created a
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you the
headline changes for every user the
description sometimes changes for the
user what I mean is if Sachin is
selecting or you know writing this
keyword so probably this headline is
shown to me and after one hour if I'll
come again and put search the same term
so the headline from the same Advertiser
could be different or the description
could be different so that's how these
Dynamic ADS works like okay so once you
are done with this okay the start end
date is important and you know the
basics from the previous chapter so I'm
just going a bit faster in here so you
would select the date and
then if you want to schedule this
campaign for a certain period like
suppose you don't want to run the
weekends so you can just select Monday
to Fridays and you know our timing
whichever suits you suppose just like a
very common time of 8 AM to uh you know
the late nights like 23 45 and you don't
want to run the weekends if you want uh
Saturday Sunday to be you know 24 hours
then you don't have to put any timing so
that goes like 24 hours for Saturday
Sundays and then you click next and you
reach to the next level
where it will just going to ask you for
certain things like keywords you want to
submit and the ad you want to run for
and the ad copy you know you have to
create okay so once you come here it is
the you know work you have done so you
can just copy paste them and you know
bring in there and otherwise these all
keywords are the ones which Google has
suggested you from you know the page
which you have submitted okay so the
landing page is this so I'll try to
change the landing page first so that I
can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would mean to search again on a
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show a certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords is what is the
competition of this keywords is how much
the monthly search has been so we go by
our own maths we we calculate we do all
this free homework on the Keyword
Planner sheet just like we did today and
then we bring them here by deleting all
what they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
been used how that copy is created I'll
just show uh you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling online
digital marketing so I would just going
to write whatever I want to show
okay
probably I'll just keep it here
so that works okay so now it has
computational marketing and then the
part comes where you know you have to be
foreign
extension once the ad is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which shows
you know you know the basics where I'll
be fast again
under the landing page link this blue
which actually uh you know brings the
most of the engagement or which actually
appeals the user to click it is
something in blue which is you know
going to be the headline so we have to
be focusing very much on bringing the
best of the headlines here so that we
can get the best of the clicks because
you know once the click increases the
CTR increases CTR increases the quality
Square would increase quality Square
would increase your cost you would come
down and your position would rise so you
have to ensure that your headlines your
clicks everything is in you know in a
line whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and
I'm just going to get the headlines as a
suggestion been given
okay and
we can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords here
this is okay
this is nice this can be changed
digital
marketing course
online is not taking so it's Marketing
Online probably I'll just stay because
course I already submitted and then I
can take few more like social media
marketing I just seen
whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the rest
this is the one and I should ensure that
I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know been given egg
a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have um uh you know online
availability key benefits and the offers
and all or call to action so enroll
register
today
for free
demo
then we will talk about
you can see the moment I've added the
headline this the strength has changed
100 plus
tools for free
job
assistance
program
okay so I'm just adding few random
things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen these headlines in any of the
acting companies ads uh include some
popular keywords popular keywords could
be your brand name as well so simply
learn
courses online
of hopefully the spelling is fine and
we can batch for
professionals
oh
mm-hmm
just a batch for professionals
and that's it you know because I already
added a lot of keywords a lot of red
lines probably Revenge so I would just
not work on headlines anymore uh I'll
see you know if reception doesn't takes
it high then I'll just add one more but
right now the description is also not
giving me the full uh tick like in the
headline unique and the headlines been
given so I'll just try to bring the
description so simply an online to do
online that's great that's great so just
try to get something from Google itself
let's see what they have given so I'll
just going to bring this one
okay so that it is being taken from the
landing page itself so that would make a
difference to
uh the quality score simple digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to put
our courses focus on skills
co22
focus on
else like Su PC nanotax
so we're doing this one here so they
has been picked up so now you can see
this has also been picked up and the
last thing I would do is now going to
bring some headline uh again you know
I'll just check probably
uh digital marketing
notification I'm not sure if this
headline I have submitted earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
you should
yeah
Clinic
so now it has you know come down to good
and uh that's the best you know right
now we can do of course you can take it
further but yeah that doesn't
um matter if you are just stuffing it to
get this one completed you have to just
ensure that all the keywords all of the
headlines are relevant just do not
overdo 10 to 12 are okay okay once this
is done your ad is created you can just
click done and you can click next
and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet and I
was explaining you so the the bit price
which you have submitted for you know
when I told you is like something which
is in this range uh like 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need
um at least 100 clicks today so 90 into
102 mqp your 9000 daily budget so
because you know that you know you would
end up in paying maximum 90 rupees per
click because that's the maximum bit
price you have submitted if that comes
down to 70 80 60 then of course your
clicks would increase but right now
though being very uh you know hypothetic
hypothetically thinking that okay I
would pay 90 rupees per click at Max
because that is what I submitted so to
get 100 clicks I have to pay 90 into 100
which would be 9 000 your you know
delivers it has to be so we would have
come here and you were just going to
change it set a custom budget and you
were going to bring down 9000 Rupees
here okay so on that yeah I have a CPC
whatever it would be you would get the
number of clicks if you have a CPC goes
down from 90 to 45 then of course you
are not going to get only 100 you'd
rather get double amount which is going
to be 200 okay once that is done then
you just click next and your budget goes
uh you know your campaign goes for a
review
and then you can add the extensions from
outside okay so they're just giving you
some of the uh you know kind of uh
suggestions so let's see uh there is one
issue in the ad
let me just check that first
let me just see
you can always fix it
with that foot again you're not going to
give you the option of um publishing you
know till you fix it but it is not
clickable or not no
uh what is the problem
I'll just go away from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is the issue
one product names
okay so just to do that the
better limit part I have not given the
space so that is something which is not
acceptable by them
I just want to put like skills like this
and
now so these all small things you know
they do
take care of so here only because you
have come down so why not you know just
to see the extension here itself because
that would I'm going to save our efforts
by going from outside so when you see
the ad you see some extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created on detail
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headlines the description but
in this ad by emirators you can see more
links like applied to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or a sub page
has also been shown in this same ad how
they are done so they are done through
the extension called site link okay so
you can see here if you go down after
the headline there's an option to have
the site links here okay so you can just
click Plus
here itself you know I'm not submitting
the ad because I wanted just to show you
from here itself and then you can go
down because in your case these would
not be given because mine are already
created yours or not so you would go
down and you would create the new South
new site link from here and you can just
give a name suppose download
brochure
and then you can give a URL of that
download brochure page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page
like this like this has to be the
landing page which is workable for the
downloading version of course so this
would be added and then I can just go
and probably add
um
testy nails
and reviews
okay so somebody wants to read the you
know testimons and reviews of when they
see the ad so you can see that on the
desktop how that would look like so they
would have an ad and then they would
have these four links involved which you
have just seen the Google when I show
new so final URL of reviews can be given
which should directly take them to the
page where the reviews being given and
uh site 2 could be anything you know
which can just see
um industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always wants to
just know
from the uh very first glimpse of the r
itself so I can just maybe
take them to the page where fee is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe tools
provided
the tools and
certificates
you would get so that can also be one of
the links which people would very much
interested in you know clicking and
checking okay so you would see the the
ad in certain shape you would have a
normal headline uh the description which
you open it up and then four links where
people can directly reach okay and then
you know this had to be saved here and
you can always see the preview which
I've already shown you but yeah this is
how that would look like so you add
your ad and your four
extra links which actually been added
okay so this is one which you can apply
now
and now your ad has the extensions in
addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your ad as the
number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here I believe right
now it is not showing any of the ads
with the number but the you know uh
generally have when advertisers have
nowadays the numbers in addition to the
headline and everything okay so you can
add that as well by just going up and
you can see there is an option of calls
okay okay let me you can add from here
uh certainly I can show you wow you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your
country and you know giving your number
here it will just be cross checked by
some verification and all so that is
done you can save it so you can see what
actually I was showing you you know I
would just show you
um from outside also that if by any of
the uh you know
um that is done that we have corrected
so you don't have to be you know
uh worried about so if I just click done
so that should not be there if it is
still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about
um
actually I have unacceptable spacing
contains comma and I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just
um
delete the whole description properly
that would something which
and I would save our time
okay so we're not adding the description
though
let's click done so this is actually you
know kind of a bug because that is
something which has been deleted rather
in front of you so this is not
um
taking but I would just click next and
probably this would now be not the error
in which we would see
so you go for a review so what I was
saying I did shown you from outside the
you know the the campaign was created
from the ad itself how the site link is
connected and how the uh call been added
for now the publish campaign you can see
because that add error actually been
rectified so if by mistake you know you
just forgotten that you have to add the
call number or extension you know which
we just added so but you don't have to
be worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you had just created then you can just
go inside the
um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets
let me just click that
so there is an ad which you just created
and there's an assets
you know where you could see the
extensions and like you know you just
have added today now we just started
this site link and this number so if I
want to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button
and then you would just go to the call
and you would see the same kind of a
preview which you have seen inside the
ad when we were creating okay nothing
different it's just like the you know
where you do it you know either you do
when the ad was created or otherwise you
can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add an assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these extensions I will talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough learning on the Google search
ad with the extensions and also the main
agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can you save
the cost and of course to understand how
the quality score works like you can
have a lot of videos on a YouTube where
you can find the quality score of Google
ads working though I try to you know
bring everything under this session but
still if you want to go for a deep
learning you can always search more and
research more introducing simple lens
postgraduate program in digital
marketing that will transform you into
Master of the digital realm this
comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
enroll in a postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below do you understand the basics of
email let's talk about how you get
started with it it's not that
complicated first of all like with many
marketing activities you need to Define
your audience and establish your goals
why do you want to use email marketing
and then you start with one of the most
important aspects of your email
marketing that is about building your
email list and that is the most
important it's a very important aspect
because if your email list is not up to
date yeah there will be a lot of bounces
on your email and your email service
provider may get back to you say hey
your email list is not up to date so we
may actually block you because you may
be spamming your customers you then
choose the the email campaign type that
you want to run you make a schedule when
you want to send out the emails and then
of course you need to measure your
results
so as I said a very important part is
creating your email list and how do you
go about that there's lots of ways that
you can create emails the simplest ways
is when you are at an event just put a
little box at your reception desk and
ask people to leave their business cards
and that gives you already a lot of
emails that you can enter in your email
lists database yeah there's other ways
you can take your existing customer list
and upload that in the email system or
you can use two very powerful methods
which is a lead magnet and an opt-in
form
now what is your lead magnet a lead
magnet is a document or a piece of
content like an ebook a white paper
infographic or a report or a checklist
or a template or a webinar or a tool and
you put it on your website you promote
it through your email so you have those
documents available on your website
through your marketing campaigns you
drive traffic to your website where
people will see the tech the checklist
or the template they will click on the
link and before they download they have
to enter their email address
yep and then that email address will
automatically be added to your mailing
list yeah now how do you design an
effective lead magnet usually it's done
by creating a landing page and on that
landing page you have only one message
and that is the solution that you offer
or the piece of content that you offer
you make sure that the asset is simple
to use yeah that it helps you in
promoting your offer
you can use it as a Cornerstone to your
page solution so maybe you promote a
freebie that will lead to a paid
solution and you make offers that are
relevant for the face that the customer
is in in the buying process yep now the
next fall that we talked about was the
opt-in form an opt-in form is a form
that can pop up on your website where
people just need to fill in their name
address email contact number Etc you can
specify What fields you want to capture
yep and again they can do that to
register for something or if they have a
question or if they want to have a
conversation with you
opt-in forms are important that you make
sure that the header stands out visually
and people will see it when they are
visiting your websites yeah often you
see websites when as soon as you get to
the home page that form will pop up
yeah and then make sure that once people
have seen the form and they they clicked
it away or they filled it in that they
won't see it again there's nothing more
annoying than every time you get to a
home page that form pops up make sure
that relevant copy is there to encourage
readers to take advantage of the offer
keep the form easy yeah make sure you
have double confirmation enabled yep and
make sure everything flows smoothly on
your form so having gone through those
basics of email marketing what we're
going to do now is giving you a short
demo of MailChimp
one of the leading email Services now
what started off as a simple email
Marketing System yes so you put in your
email addresses you create an email
campaign you link the campaign to the
email addresses yep and then you send it
out MailChimp would take care of that
and then MailChimp would also give you
the reporting now this melody this email
Marketing Systems they became more and
more advanced they knew that digital
marketing is not only email marketing
there is no pay-per-click marketing
there is social media there is
um what's it influencer marketing there
is advertising you name it so they had
to enrich their services and you will
see that when we go into MailChimp that
there is now a whole range of additional
Services even down to developing your
own website that MailChimp can offer you
but at the core of
MailChimp is its email system so let's
go and have a look into how to use
MailChimp and how to set up your first
email campaign so if you go to
mailchimp.com
yeah you can see here a little overview
of what it does yeah then again we're
going to go into automations I'm going
to show you some of the analytics I'm
going to show you how you can segment
with um with MailChimp and how you can
synchronize with other applications in
MailChimp as well so lots of stuff that
you can do here is a little promotional
video and here is the pricing so you can
see that a free version gives you
limited functionality but it does give
you all the functionality you need to
send emails to up to 500 contacts per
month
yep and then it goes up to 11.70 and
then the premium version gives you all
the Full Features 299 dollars but let's
focus on the free version again that's
what I kind of like often of MailChimp
so let's go into my account yeah so I go
on to
took it down
let's have a look I'm logged in yeah so
here is my
audience
so here you see the features that
MailChimp has to offer
so first of all there is create you can
create campaigns
yeah that is where you run your email
campaigns and where you create your
marketing campaigns a very important
part of your MailChimp is your contacts
or your audience
of course if you don't have any emails
in your database if it were then yeah
then there's not many people that you
can send stuff to so contacts are very
important that you get an email list
that you can connect with your campaigns
there are automations that you can do
which basically means you can send
emails automatically there is analytics
there is website you can create your own
website and modules of it there is
content so that is sort of your library
of assets and then there are different
Integrations that you can do here you
see kind of your dashboard of the
campaigns and this is your audience
dashboard
so the very first thing of course that
you need to do when you are starting on
MailChimp that is create an audience
yeah and that's where you go into your
contacts so there is your audience
dashboard as you see here you can have
all an overview of all your contacts you
can create signup forms that you can add
to your website to capture people's
email addresses there are tags that you
can set to content so you can group your
contents into segments and you can do
surveys and there is your inbox if
people send you messages
yeah so lots of functionality but your
first challenge will be
how to get your emails there's lots of
ways to do that first of all there may
be your existing customer database or
your existing customer list you probably
have them in a spreadsheet
yeah so what I'm going to show you in a
minute is how you can enter or import
that spreadsheet into a MailChimp yeah
so that is one way second you can
actually set up on your website a form
that people can fill in to sign up for
your newsletter for instance
or you can run a campaign where people
go to a landing page and if they
download a certain piece of
documentation then they need to give you
their their email address
yeah so there's lots of ways another
really effective way if you're at an
exhibition for instance have a little
box on your your counter where people
can leave their ear their
um their their business cards
yeah and then you can take all of that
information and put them in your your
MailChimp so the question here then is
of course how do I bring contacts into
my
MailChimp audience so let's go to all
contacts
yep and then you see I already have two
contacts in my my co
that's the name of my audience
yeah so I'm going to add additional
contacts I can get an overview of my
contacts I can add contacts manually I
can add a subscriber
yeah and then I can just put in the name
yeah so that is Mark at
uh
simplylearn.com and then it's Mark
there is
simply learn don't have to put in a
dress I can get phone number I can get
birthday I can get company name that
would be simply learn
I can add a tag so that would be
training
add or create a tag
yeah that could be training
there's my tag now very important what
SIM what about the MailChimp wants to
know that you people that you have in
your database
that you that they gave you permission
to email them yeah they're a very strict
requirements these days for people yet
that you need to respect your privacy
you need to have permission before you
send them an email
yep and there's different ways that you
can ask that permission you can ask it
on the website before they fill in a
form you can ask it in your newsletter
yeah so make sure that you have those
permissions because if people get
unsolicited email through a commercial
email campaign yeah in principle that is
not allowed and you may be subject to a
fine the you may have heard of the gdprs
regulations in in Europe and there is
also regulations in the United States
there's regulations in Asia yeah there's
a real tightening of those privacy
regulations when it comes to email
marketing if this person for some reason
is already in my audience then I can
update it will update your profile so
let's click subscribe
let's see
there's probably one
field I ever got
phone number that is 075
yeah shoulders phone number was a
required item as well
yep and then I click subscribe
so if I now go back to all contacts you
will see that Mark at simplylearn.com is
now has been added to my database so
that is one way to get emails in your
audience list
the next way is if you go to add
contacts you can import contacts
there are three ways how you can import
contacts you can import contacts from
another service
there's a way you connect with another
piece of software you can upload a CSV
file or a text file and you can even
copy and paste
yeah so if I import from another service
you can see you can import for
Salesforce from Squarespace from Shopify
and there's probably a lot more
Integrations that you can have
if you want to upload a file it will
then basically ask you to upload your
file so what we need to do we need to
create a spreadsheet that we save as a
CSV file so if I go to
Google Drive
and I'm going to actually I already have
a file here
yeah so let's open this file
so you see
that I have these names in there I'm
going to take them out very important
that you add first name last name
company email and all the fields that
are relevant for you yeah so let's say
telephone as well so then we're going to
say the first name is uh Jacob
last name is Jones
company
is Biko
and email is Jacob jones.com
telephone number is oh one two three
four five six seven
yep then the second name is
um Anne-Marie
Carol
and that is Carol
dot com
and that is n
at Carol dot prom and that is
987654 telephone number okay let's take
out that dollar sign
right yes so now I have the file and
this name is MailChimp or whatever
MailChimp one
so the first thing I'm going to do of
course is to save this I am going to
download this file as a comma separated
values file which is a CSV file
and MailChimp wants me to upload this
CSV file into
this field yeah so that's how I can
upload my contacts so I'm going to my uh
YouTube
downloads here is my MailChimp CSV file
yep so there it is I'm going to continue
to organize now the first thing that
MailChimp is going to do now if I'm
wearing any
existing context they will be updated
the first thing I can add a tag yes so
I'm going to let's say a member and I'm
going to continue to match that is what
MailChimp is going to do now remember
the first line of our spreadsheet was
sort of the field names first name last
name company name and telephone
MailChimp is going to match those
MailChimp things that the first line was
first name the second name was last name
so these are correct company it has
picked up it doesn't know what to do
with telephone yeah so what I can do I
can edit this column yeah and I can look
at the fields that they have
yes so is telephone in here
I don't see I hear phone number yeah and
I'm gonna link it with phone number
so now it is okay and I can now see here
five columns will be imported and I'm
gonna say finalize Imports
yep so now it has added two contacts to
the list so I'm going to say complete
Imports
and if I now want to view my contacts
you will see that my contacts have been
added to my email list
yeah so now I have two additional
contacts in my list
I could also
add a subscriber actually have done a
copy and paste
go back
add contacts import contacts I could do
a copy and paste so I'll show you how
that works continue
yeah so when I go back to the
spreadsheet
and I would copy these just copy it
command copy
going back to my MailChimp and I can now
just paste them here just like this and
now
MailChimp is going to analyze this yeah
and it says okay this is what I think it
is and it goes back into that same stage
that we saw in when we when we imported
the spreadsheet
yeah you see here first name last name
company name and then the telephone
yep now I'm not going to import this
again because we've already imported
these contacts but this is how you
import your contacts
okay
now a few tips on your database
yes very important
are you sure you want to exit this okay
yes so you may build up a list of a
couple of hundred contacts in your in
your MailChimp and that is fantastic
yeah the bigger your list the more value
that you will get from it a very
important aspect of this is to make sure
that your database is clean
yeah people may ask to be removed from
your database people change businesses
yeah make sure your database is clean
when you run a campaign
and you use your email list and there
are a lot of emails that cannot be sent
because there are a lot of wrong emails
in your list
yeah you will have what we call a high
bounce rate
and if you have a continuous high bounce
rate
MailChimp may come back to you and say
hey why do you have such a high bound
rate
and if you can't explain why you have a
high bound rate MailChimp may actually
block your account
because MailChimp wants you to work with
a clean database that is also the risk
if you buy an email list that you don't
know the source from
and if you import it and then run your
first campaign if you get a whole lot of
bounces on your emails yeah then uh
MailChimp May block your account so be
very careful make sure that your emails
are correct that your bounce rate is low
and never buy
email lists because you don't know what
the quality is of the list
make sure that you segment your mailing
list and then you can within one mailing
list you can send it to your different
segments could be customers could be
prospects could be
suppliers or what have you yeah
constantly work on growing your database
make sure you don't spam people always
get
um people's approval yeah that they are
happy for you to send them
um emails and of course honor
unsubscribes as well if people ask you
to unsubscribe them from the mailing
list make sure you do that
okay just a few tips when it comes to
managing your database
so now that you have your email audience
set up your contact setup let's look at
a campaign
let's
when you go into the campaigns here you
have an overview of all the campaigns
that you've run now we haven't run any
campaigns here is a draft campaign yeah
but what you're gonna do you're going to
create a campaign
yes when you click here on the top right
on the create campaign button you have
then the different types of campaigns
that you can order and create you can do
a regular email
you can actually create a landing page
or you can also create an embedded form
yeah that helps you in capturing context
that could be part of your landing page
campaign
but what we're going to look at is
regular emails
yeah so when I click on email I can just
click here design email
yeah then there is a new email Builder
that you can use and since you're
probably new to Simply learn a new to
um to MailChimp I click straight onto
the new Builder because that is a lot
easier to work with
yeah so here you see it's time to design
your email
yeah I put this little icon already in
yesterday yeah so there's different ways
of doing that here you see sort of your
editor for your email here you can
preview the email here you see your
editing building blocks the layout The
Heading paragraph button Etc here you
can specify Styles and here you can
specify templates for your emails so
here you see and whole range of email
templates
yeah if you click on the creative
assistant that is beautiful but it will
drive you to a premium
account yeah so I'm not going to show
that I want to show you the free
features of MailChimp so let's say we're
going to go for a little design here
we're going to go for this one we could
do preview as how it will look like yeah
and then we're going to click apply
continue with start with a clean
template
yes so this is how it will look like so
what you can then do start optimizing
the text and the images
so let's do that so here few this email
in your browser that is always good to
have you can change your image
yeah so if I click on that
you see here replace logo yeah so if I
click on replays logo I can then
go to the content studio and I can just
upload different files here and this is
the image that I picked yeah so let's
stick with this particular image here
then I can add a photo so I can say add
a photo like I say upload an image
yeah so if I go to my YouTube I go to uh
thought I had an image somewhere videos
Banner
yeah so here I've added a banner as an
image I can align it left center right
full yeah I can just line to the right I
can align it to the center left I'm
going to do a full alignment okay and
then here you see my text it's time to
design your email so here I can say
um welcome
to this week's newsletter
in this newsletter
episode and in this newsletter
we will
be talking
about
and then blah blah blah blah okay then
here you see a button yeah and I've
added that I can then just click here
first I click done yeah so the buttons I
can bring in here through my
um
my
built units yeah and here I can change
the button text so I here is book now
for instance
so here I have my social media buttons
yeah and I can there put my own social
media onto that
I can do the same with my Instagram
and I can do the same for my Twitter
I can add another social link I'm going
to leave it like that here's my logo
again then here this will be picked up
automatically every email
will at the bottom have details about
your company about your address how can
people unsubscribe yeah and because
you're using the free version there is
this item grow your business with
MailChimp yeah that is a little bit of
MailChimp branding that will be added to
your email if you're using the free
version so keep that in mind
okay so then you click preview this is
how your email will look like
yep and then you're gonna exit preview
mode and if you're happy with this
you're going to save and exit
now here you kind of have your admin
screen for your campaign
yeah so you see here the name so I need
to type in the name
so I'm going to name it is MailChimp
demo for instance and I'm clicking save
then here I have selected all the
contacts so I can just go to my audience
I pick the audience that I've created I
can then have all my subscribers or I
can pick certain segments or tags in my
subscriber base I can personalize the
two Fields yeah and then I click save
here is the from so that is it's from me
or you can edit that save it from send
from somebody else you can add a subject
now your subject line of course is very
important in email marketing because in
the subject line people will when they
read the subject line people will decide
whether or not they will open the email
yes so the subject line always has to be
catchy so when it could be five reasons
why you shoot read our latest
email newsletter
newsletter
yeah or any other subject line but they
are they need to be short and sweet yeah
you could use emojis you need to in that
one line you need to give people the
reason why they shoot open this email
preview text appears in the inbox after
the subject line yeah so in today's
newsletter
we will talk
about
social media
and email marketing
for instance and you click save
so that is your subject that is your
content
yep and then here is part of your
contact you can send yourself a test
email
that is always useful to send it to
yourself and check it on your desktop
and check it on your mobile so I send
myself a test email send a test to any
email yeah so let me quickly check here
my Gmail
that is uh
to me
that is tube for Mark
okay so I'm going to send that email to
Cube for Mark okay I can send it to
multiple people and I'm going to click
send test
email has been sent
so let's check the email so here we see
the email test five reasons why you
should read our latest newsletter
and then here you see the email and then
you check it on typos you check it on
the links that are in there yeah make
sure that your social media buttons work
etc
and if you're then happy with your email
you can then publish it
yeah and there's two ways of publishing
it you can schedule it
when you schedule it you can set a
delivery date and a specific delivery
time but in order to use that feature
you need to upgrade to Premium
okay so you can send it directly
so when you click Send it will go
straight to it
yep so very important or you can say
finish later if you don't want to share
your campaign you see here the link for
the campaign
yeah and you could change that
your default campaign URL yes your
MailChimp generate randomly five reasons
why you should read our email if you
upgrade to premium you can turn this
MailChimp into your own URL
okay good and then you can track your
your campaign your email campaigns but
um we'll print they will usually we'll
cover that in a in the next video on on
MailChimp when we go into more advanced
features okay so I'm just gonna click
finish later
and if we're now having our list of
campaigns then here you see we have our
MailChimp demo as a draft ready to be
published
so that is the so that is the campaigns
how to create a campaign on MailChimp
right now let's have a look at a few
more things so first of all a new
feature in MailChimp is the analytics
when you send out an email campaign you
will get basic analytics here in your
campaigns dashboard as well but
MailChimp now also has an analytics
dashboard
and here you see the type of data that
you will get in MailChimp and it is
using sample data so we can explore the
dashboard so here you see number of
emails sent whether it's up or down you
see the number of people or the
percentage of people that opened the
email
and very important the actual percentage
of people that clicked on the email or
clicked on the link in the email and
that is very important yeah so that's
where you can really follow through on
your email campaigns yeah on who opened
it who clicked it to the form the
phrases that needed to be filled in so
very useful information that you can get
out of your campaign and you can see
that from various periods yeah you can
even actually in the other reports you
can actually see who are the people in
my
mailing list in my audience who actually
clicked on the email and who are the
people who opened the clicked on the
link
and then you can approach them
separately
yeah so here you see engagements
email sent and the click rate
yep so here you see by email the number
of recipients the open rate The Click
rate the revenue that you made
if you had that set up so lots of data
that you can get on your email campaigns
open rates are very important and they
differ by industry yeah and general and
the open rate
anywhere between up to 15 and higher are
usually good open rates
okay so that is the analytics that you
can get and then finally what I really
like in MailChimp is that you can use
MailChimp to create landing pages so if
I'm going back to my campaigns
and I'm going to click create campaign
then I can also decide to create a
landing page
name of the landing page is Michael
select an audience Michael and I'm going
to click begin
yeah and here you see
a number of templates that I can use for
my landing page
yeah so very simple templates so let's
take this template
except
I'm going into the editor
yeah so here is the editor for the
landing pages I can add text I can do
box text I can add dividers images I can
change the text
yeah you see here band mates that is the
logo I can change the logo
yeah so I can replace the logo and I can
edit a logo and what if you I'm just
going to stick with this text for the
time being and here is my email address
form yeah and the beauty about it when
people fill in their email address in
this form it will automatically be added
to my mailing list
in MailChimp so that is a very powerful
feature I can also create this as a
separate form
Okay so
so here you see the available fields
that I have email I can add first name
if I want to yeah I can add last name
and I can add phone number as well
yep I can then go to the settings
I can do the style different styles that
I can have so this is my sign up form
yeah the button text is subscribe I can
then also send visitors to a
confirmation message
I can preview the confirmation message
success you've been added to the
audience
yeah exit preview
yep and that is my sign up form and
again it will automatically be added to
my campaign email list and I click save
and close
yep and here is the full campaign
yeah and when I'm happy with it
I can click save and close
so here is my landing page
and it's now
here I have the page title and site icon
here's the social share preview here is
the URL of mic and my landing page here
is the contents
and I can then get my
finish it later or I can publish it and
as soon as I publish it
this URL will be life
yeah so click publish
so this landing page is now live
so if I now go to this landing page
yeah so here you see email address I'm
saying uh
um
cherry
oh
Cherry at palmri.com
com and that is
cherry
and I'd say subscribe
so now let's check the litmus test if I
go to my contacts and I'm going to all
my contacts
and here we have cherry Henry the famous
Arsenal football player who has just
joined my mailing list so that is the
power of MailChimp so now Having learned
about these sort of fundamentals of
social media marketing let's now have a
look at how do you put together your
social media marketing strategy how do
you set it up how do you develop it now
with my over 40 years of experience in
marketing digital marketing and social
media I developed a simple five-step
methodology to set your business or to
set up yourself for social media and
it's called flirt
yeah and flirt is an acronym
flirt the first letter the f is for
focus
yeah and in the focus phase what you do
you look at various things the first
thing you do in developing your social
media marketing strategy is look at what
is your niche
what Market are you targeting
and the more you focus in your Market
your targeting your Niche the easier it
will be to reach them
yes so it's very important that you
focus on a very particular niche
once you've identified that Niche you
look at your positioning
why should they buy from you what is
your unique value proposition remember
the definition of marketing yeah the
value for your customer is key in this
and you put it in what we call a
positioning statement
you also look at your customers you
create customer personas
where you look at your customers and you
kind of map their interests their pain
points the typical questions that they
would ask so you get a good
understanding of your your customers
yes or you look at your Niche you look
at your positioning you look at your
focus or sorry you look at your
customers
yep and then you're going to ask
yourself why am I going to use social
media
yeah am I going to use it to build
awareness am I going to use it to drive
traffic to my website
am I going to use it to generate sales
am I going to use it to improve customer
service
am I going to use it to recruit new
staff am I going to use it to
communicate with my
um my employees
yeah so lots of reasons why you could
use social media and it's your challenge
to identify one or two objectives for
your social media
and then a very important aspect of your
social media marketing strategy even
your overall digital marketing strategy
what are the keywords that you will be
focusing on
in other words what are the keywords
that you want to be recognized
recognized for Google wants to know
Facebook wants to know LinkedIn wants to
know and it's all about repetition the
more often you use those keywords the
more those social media platforms and
Google will associate you with those
keywords when people search for them
they will then show you how you're up in
the search results we call this search
engine optimization or search engine
marketing
yeah so keywords is like a whole course
in itself
but it's very important part of your
social media marketing strategy in the
focus phase
so that is the F for Focus think about
your Niche your positioning who is your
customers why are you on social media
and what are your main keywords
the next is the L for listen
listen is so important
yeah we tend to
talk too much
yeah where social media
can give you fantastic listening
opportunities
and when I say listen I mean read
articles online
listen on Facebook and on Twitter on
LinkedIn listen on Google
yeah watch videos listen to podcasts
there's dozens of ways that you can
listen online because when you listen
you learn
and when you learn you get better and
you develop
so what does that mean from you some
practical tips when it comes to
listening first you need to listen to
where your customers hang out
are your customers on Facebook are they
on Twitter are they on LinkedIn and
later in this session when we go through
the various social media platforms I'll
give you an overview of what type of
people are on the various social media
platforms
the next thing that you want to know
when you listen is who are your top 10
bloggers or influencers in your Niche do
you know your top 10 bloggers do you
know your top Instagram influences
because you want to learn from them but
you may also want to build relation with
them
to use them in your marketing Outreach
you also want to look at the trends in
your Niche Google Trends is a really
useful tool that you can check to find
out what are the trends in your niche
and you're looking at your competitors
and your customers what are they doing
what are they talking about
yes so a very important stage and if
you're doing it properly you would
actually set up a social media listening
dashboard where you bring all your
listening channels together in one
dashboard
and then instead of having to go to all
those social media networks or websites
you let them come to you Inno reader is
a very good dashboard online dashboard a
free dashboard that you can use for this
we're then looking at the eye for
integration yeah so you know your
strategy you know where your customers
are you know which social media Networks
you're going to focus on then you're
going to integrate them you're going to
set up your social media Networks you're
going to make sure the branding and the
profiles are consistent you're using
your keywords you're going to create
your content calendar
and you're going to set up your blog
blogging is very important in social
media marketing because it is the
easiest way to start creating content on
your website and to start sharing that
content through your social media
channels that will then drive people
back to your website
yes so that is part of the integration
stage and then once you've got that all
set up you're then going to reach out
it's very important that you reach out
because if you're not reaching out then
people won't find you people won't see
you yeah the whole essence of social
media marketing is that you create as
many touch points as possible on the
internet for people to find you
yeah where they start engaging with your
content going back to your website want
to know more about you want to know more
about your content and you start
building a relationship that may then
turn into a sale
so reaching out you're going to start
sharing your content you're going to
repurpose your content so turn your blog
post into a video or into a carousel or
turn your video into a podcast or what
have you
yeah you're going to share other
people's content there's nothing wrong
with sharing content from other people
and you're going to run
campaigns
campaigns to push your content in the
channels
yeah and campaigns nowadays are no
longer sort of just posts on social
media it is a combination of organic
posts yeah where you just share your
posts on social media could be paid like
pay-per-click advertising or it could be
influencer marketing style
reaching out yeah so very important is
the reaching out stage and then of
course tracking is the icing on the cake
as it were when you track you measure
your online reputation you measure your
conversions you measure your social
media activity and engagement you're
meshing your Roi and you plan for your
next quarter
okay time to talk about the social media
marketing platforms let's have a look at
some of the most relevant ones out there
now but before that let's make sure that
you understand the essence of the social
media marketing platforms how do they
work very simple they all work according
the same concept what you do you create
an account on the social platform like
Facebook for instance you fill in your
profile
on Facebook you put in a lot of data
about yourself on Twitter a little yeah
so you fill in your profile and once
your profile is ready you're going to
connect with friends or follow and be
followed
there are some platforms when you send
somebody a connection request or a
friend request request when they accept
your mutually connected like Facebook
and like LinkedIn other platforms like
Twitter and like Instagram when you
follow somebody doesn't mean that that
person follows you
yeah so we're talking about followers
and following as it were
yep and then when you've got that you're
going to start sharing updates
and you're going to check your news feed
where you will see the updates from your
friends
now as a business every platform enables
you to create a Facebook page or to
create a page
yeah and what you want to do you create
your page you put in your company
information you brand it to your company
branding guidelines and then you get
people to follow or like your Facebook
page
or your LinkedIn page yep and then you
start sharing updates and people that
liked your page they may see your
company updates in their feeds
and this is what we call organic reach
so you do a post as a business and then
the people that follow you will see your
posts on their personal news feed
now in the early days of social media
this organic reach could be 40 to 50
percent
which means that if you have ten
thousand
followers on Facebook so 10 000 people
liked your Facebook page five thousand
of those people would see your update on
their personal news feed which is
fantastic
and that was in the early days for
social media many Brands they spent lots
of marketing building huge communities
because it was a fantastic free way of
reaching out to your Market
nowadays things have changed
Facebook has been driving this yeah
Facebook wants you to advertise on
Facebook all these social media
platforms they have to make money so
they have advertising sort of on their
platform and they want you to use
advertising so over the years Facebook
has lowered organic reach to less than
three percent
so again if you have 10 000 people that
like your Facebook page fewer than 300
people may see your updates in their
feed
and Facebook says hey that's the way it
is we offer you a fantastic marketing
environment and we need to make money as
well so hey yeah start advertise on
Facebook to reach your entire audience
and businesses Now understand that they
now know that social media is paid to
play
to reach your audience it's no longer
relying on organic reach you have to pay
to use pay-per-click advertising or PPC
but we're going to talk about that in
the next videos
all right so it's very important that
you understand this concept of how
social media marketing platforms work
so let's start with the first one the
biggest one Facebook with 1.9 billion
active users worldwide
is that over the years the younger
generation has left Facebook
yeah why have they left Facebook because
it's not cool anymore
yeah and their parents are on it
yeah so if you want to reach the young
teens
early 18s early 20s don't go to Facebook
you want to be on social networks like
Snapchat or Tick Tock if that's
available in your markets now there's
still markets where Facebook is enormous
yes so they are the leading social media
Network in your Market if that is the
case then of course you have to be on
Facebook but in general we can say that
the audience for Facebook is now a
slightly older audience Generation X or
Millennials it's still a really good
Network to reach these people
particularly when you talk about
consumer type products now what does
Facebook offer you as a business to use
Facebook has the Facebook page that you
can create to reach your audience
nowadays Facebook really would like you
to use Facebook groups
Facebook groups is a fantastic area in
Facebook where you can get really good
engagements
and as a business you can offer a group
to your customers as a VIP area or a
product knowledge area or a pre-launch
area or just for your customers yeah
lots of reasons lots of areas where you
can use a group to reach your customers
then there's Facebook Messenger of
course that you can use for your
business where you can set up Bots yeah
so you can have sort of automated
conversations with your customers on
Facebook messenger and there is Facebook
live
don't ignore Facebook live Facebook
loves you to use Facebook live
the beauty about using the Facebook live
it gives you sort of Buzz and engagement
before the event during the event and
after the event
yeah we call this tent poll marketing
you can build up excitement leading up
to the event and after the event as well
and then finally of course Facebook is
betting heavily on the metaphors yes so
it's Mark Zuckerberg's Vision that
instead of engaging with your friends in
the news feed you engage with them in a
virtual world now the verdict is out if
this is going to work but fact is that
although we've been talking about
virtual and augmented reality for years
it is here now
yeah there's more and more apps becoming
available on your mobile on your desktop
that use augmented reality
and virtual reality I can now download
Ikea place I think it's called where you
just open up the app you pick a product
from the catalog like a table and then
you can just position the table in your
living room
yeah and then you can move it change the
color of it or whatever you're using
augmented reality through your um your
camera
okay so that is Facebook
let's look at the next one Instagram I
love Instagram yeah a lot of users from
Facebook have gone to Instagram
why because it is a visual social media
platform and it has
inherently higher engagement than
Facebook it's easier to reach the
audience not just your friends
yeah so lots of cool features in
Instagram one of the coolest features is
the Instagram stories
yep and people now spend more time on
the stories than on the the timeline
where they see the posts so Instagram
started as a photo sharing app very
simple yeah you made a photo you put a
filter on top of it which almost felt
like you're a photographer and then you
share it with hashtags and you saw
immediately the likes coming in and
people loved it for its simplicity
and now it has grown to a fully featured
social media Network that businesses can
use to make their brand come to life via
photos and Via stories
the audience is slightly younger than
the Facebook audience but a more and
more mature audience is coming on there
as well and it's it initially it had
very much a business to Consumer Focus
but nowadays it's not just photos that
you can share you can share visuals I
can turn a blog post into a carousel of
five visuals
yep and
um in that way share really good content
so very powerful and very useful for
businesses to reach the audience that
hangs out on on Instagram
all right so that is Instagram let's
look at the next one and that is YouTube
now YouTube of course is not just for
watching video YouTube is a fantastic
social media platform to build an
audience of followers
yeah it's a great platform to monetize
your video as well by enabling
advertising to be shown before or during
your videos a lot of video creators they
do that yeah and your YouTube has a
program for that if you qualify by a
number of views that you have on your
video and number of uh and then the size
of your audience you can participate in
this program and it is a really good way
to make money on you for many content
creators now check out our earlier check
out our earlier video on how to create a
YouTube channel to find out how you can
set up a YouTube channel and how you can
use YouTube as a social media platform
YouTube is great for brand awareness and
since it's owned by Google it's also
really helpful for your search rankings
both on YouTube and on Google Google
and there's lots of different videos of
course that you can make you have videos
that do well are typical videos like
how-to videos unpacking videos Vlogs
video blogs we call them review videos
live videos lots and lots of ways to
reach the video your audience yeah on
with video on YouTube
so the typical audience that uses
YouTube are basically everybody from
young to old but very important to
understand with YouTube that people are
there for a reason they search for
something they may search for
entertainment they may also search for
answers to their questions
which is different than the videos you
would have on Facebook for instance yeah
so Facebook is very good for brand
awareness where YouTube videos are very
good for
um for lead generation for instance and
for building relationship with your your
audience
good and very interesting social media
platform that emerged around 10 years
ago is Snapchat
they have around 300 plus million daily
active users
and let me tell you a bit about the
history of Snapchat Snapchat was a
response to Facebook's problems about 10
years ago in privacy
and not being cool anymore and
particularly the Privacy issue where in
those days a lot of people said who is
owning my photos on on Facebook yeah
um is it Facebook or is it myself so a
lot of people and that there's always
been a gray area
yeah combined with Facebook not being
cool anymore and you know how important
being cool is for the younger generation
yep so fata so two guys who came up with
the idea of doing something radically
different and they came up with a social
media platform Snapchat where posts
would delete themselves within 24 hours
they built a a user interface around
this which was fairly difficult to use
yeah but that was for a reason
gets they love to explain to each other
how it works and if it's complicated
enough then their parents won't be able
to get on it
yeah so kids love that idea it's too
complicated to use for my parents so I
really have my own social media worlds
yeah in Snapchat that nobody else has
access to so particularly the teens the
generations that was very uh keen and
they were very hot on the uh on Snapchat
so it was that new place for Facebook
users to go to and they grew ever since
steadily not huge but they are there and
they are a very powerful social network
particularly when you want to Target the
younger generation
now there are two major features that
they sort of drove into social media
lens which was the stories
and second the vertical videos
so you all know the concept of the story
itself deletes in 24 hours but it turned
um social media instead of sort of
scrolling through your news feed you
swipe from story to story much more
visual much more fun much more engaging
yep and you would swipe those stories
vertically and that automatically led to
using vertical video
and vertical video is a major Trend in
social media content yeah which is
picked up by
um by Tech talk as the main format for
uh for videos on Tick Tock YouTube have
shorts so all social media now networks
they now have stories and they have
vertical video as a key element yeah so
vertical video particularly for short 10
12 second videos which we call snackable
content is very important why would you
tilt your phone to watch a video why not
just use it vertical which is also a
quite an interesting
um sort of form factor to get a good
engagement on your videos
finally Snapchat has very Innovative
advertising features
yeah they have lenses they have stories
they have filters you can put a filter
over your face BMW had a really good
campaign to launch a new car where you
could place the car through a lens
anywhere that you liked in augmented
reality and you could actually put a
filter where you gave yourself a golden
face yeah so very powerful advertising I
think the the WhatsApp advertising
platforms is one of the best advertising
platforms out there it's also probably
one of the most expensive
advertising platforms of all social
media Networks
right so let's look at Twitter
I call Twitter SMS on steroids yeah it
was one of the first besides Facebook
one of the first social media platforms
that came out and it was a very exciting
platform when it launched
and Twitter relied heavily on celeb
celebrities using it to drive acceptance
on a global scale yeah but many music
stars rock stars actors they started
using Twitter and that drove the global
adoption of the uh the platform now what
makes Twitter so powerful there are
three aspects on Twitter first of all
you can retweet a tweet
yeah so when you send a tweet and I
follow you I receive your Tweet if I
just click on retweet it'll go to all my
followers yeah if somebody in my
follower base retweets that tweet your
Tweet can go viral without uh in in in
in minutes
yep and there's various examples of
tweets that went viral within minutes
yeah like the um which was it a selfie
tweet during the Oscar ceremony a few
years ago
yes so it is sort of retweeting is very
powerful
it also makes it instant yeah because of
this retweeting aspect news goes on in
on Twitter instantly and it shares to a
global audience instantly so that makes
it very very
powerful for news agencies as well and
for businesses a very powerful feature
of Twitter is the Twitter search
each tweet is indexed and you can search
in all the tweets you can search for the
very first tweet that was ever sent
yeah so that makes it very powerful for
Brands to find content so Twitter is
really good for finding jobs for
instance because lots of businesses they
tweet about I'm looking for a marketing
manager or a web developer so if I
search for web developer hashtag jobs
that tweet will show up in my search
results
[Music]
had is that they did not keep up with
the developments in social media
platform functionality yeah so most
celebrities went to Instagram because
Instagram was much more visual much
better place for celebrities to engage
with their their fans so Twitter lagged
behind and in the last few years it
clearly repositioned itself
so it now is seen as a great way for
businesses to use as a communication and
service Channel with their customers and
for media companies to share the latest
news
so if you want to find out what is
happening in the world now or what
businesses are doing now or if you have
a problem with a product from a business
Twitter is the best place to be
and for you individual as I always say
you don't need to be on Twitter to tweet
but you must be on Twitter to find great
content to search
whether you want to search for jobs or
whether you're searching for
opportunities if you're a photographer
yeah and you in London for instance and
you go to Twitter and you search for
looking for wedding photographer London
you get a list of tweets of people who
are tweeting I'm looking for a wedding
photographer does anybody know anybody
yeah so extremely powerful to uh to use
for lead generation
right so what about Pinterest
Pinterest is a visual bookmarking
platform
it's very cool the concept is simple you
see a photo on the website that you like
yeah but you can then do you can pin
that photo on Pinterest in a board
yeah and you're not copying the photo
you're just copying the link in your
board so by doing that you can build
fantastic collections of visuals that
you like and want to organize
so I bought a house in Marrakesh a
number of years ago in Morocco and we
needed to design the interior so we had
a board with Morocco design we had a
board with Morocco riyads we had a board
with
um a tiling and what have you and we
just build up a whole collection of
ideas that we liked and then we got the
people that helped us in making the
things that we wanted and we could just
share them the links on Pinterest of the
ideas that we had worked really well
now because you can save those Boards of
course you can then share them as well
yeah so everybody can access your boards
which means that it becomes a great tool
for getting ideas and Inspirations from
boards from other people
so if you want ideas for home design or
your wedding or fashion Pinterest is a
fantastic place to get inspiration
another major benefit for businesses is
that you can put your product catalog on
Pinterest as visuals organized in boards
yep and then when people
find those products on in on Pinterest
and they click on them it will take them
to the catalog of your website where
they can buy your product so it's a
great way to drive additional traffic to
your website if you want to see a good
example for that go to the IKEA UK
Pinterest page and look at their boards
you see boards for small living room
ideas back to school Christmas holiday
celebrations and then you get lots of
ideas with for instance for small living
rooms and then you click on some of the
products that you see and that takes you
to the
page on the Ikea catalog website where
you can buy the product
now Pinterest is very popular amongst
women amongst Millennials and it also
has very powerful advertising features
and then LinkedIn LinkedIn is serious
yeah I call LinkedIn Facebook with a tie
where Facebook is fun LinkedIn is
serious in Facebook you can get away
with a funny profile photo in LinkedIn
your photo needs to be professional
now if you go to linkedin.com forward
slash sales forward slash SSI you get
your Social selling index and that is a
score between 1 and 100 of how good you
are on LinkedIn
and you will see in the score in the
summary that our four components that
contribute to your SSI score or four
components that contribute to how well
you do on LinkedIn
so those four are your profile
here your activity level in connecting
with people
how much content you share and your
activity a level in building
relationships with people
yes so the better you do in those four
areas the higher your score your profile
of course is very important make sure
that your LinkedIn profile is as
complete as possible
now linkedin's biggest challenge as I
mentioned earlier is to get people to
engage and share content
so how does LinkedIn make money very
simple there are four areas where they
make money first of all they allow
people to upgrade their LinkedIn account
to a premium account where they get more
features
there is a whole section in LinkedIn
specifically for recruiters
yeah so a recruiting version of LinkedIn
there is a whole area for sales we call
this sales Navigator
yeah if you run a sales team that you
use LinkedIn of course you want to keep
the customer data so you're getting a
sort of customer relationship management
system within LinkedIn when you sign up
for sales Navigator and then there is
LinkedIn advertising
LinkedIn of course is best for business
to business and it's really good for
developing your personal online profile
as long as you share content through
publishing articles and sharing uh
sharing posts
so I've been operational on LinkedIn
from the very beginning and I shared
lots and lots of content and articles on
LinkedIn and I got lots of business
coming in through Linkedin
yeah we're talking about serious amounts
of business that I did by being on
LinkedIn so you've got to be on LinkedIn
if you are in business
right now one thing that I will not talk
about here is a stick talk yeah we
haven't got a slide for that but bear in
mind Tick Tock although it's not
available in India
um tiktok is a very important social
media Network these days which derives a
whole new format of uh of engaging and
communication but more about that that
later introducing simple lens
postgraduate program in digital
marketing that will transform you into
Master of the digital realm this
comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
and olena postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind the goal
of your marketing strategy may be the
driving force behind every decision that
you make and this is exactly why setting
up goals is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
here are some things that you need to
keep in mind while setting up your goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative for example you need to
have a thousand conversions by the end
of the quarter or 5 000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options number three
make sure your goals are smart now smart
refers to specific measurable attainable
relevant and time-based
now let's go to number four like I
mentioned earlier your goals need to be
aligned with the marketing strategy
and alongside these goals there also
needs to be the North Star metric now
what is the North Star metric well this
represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this North Star
metric will also give your team Clarity
and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
North Stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your audience
social media allows you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
Audience by understanding what they need
want and desire you can deliver content
in a way that makes your product or
service the answer that they're looking
for
there are also other ways that you can
understand them better
this could be surveys to determine the
issues that bother them the age
demographics of Their audience
by conversing with them in forums
responding to their comments and blogs
in social media taking up their
feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learns audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
baijuab has high school students as
users
now let's go to number three determining
the right social media platform
now when performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
When selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform who you will reach
with this platform what content could
work best on the platform and is there
any content that was unique to that
platform like for example YouTube and
then there's the video
answering these questions will help you
zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest
now let's talk about the purpose of each
of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences
for Facebook well just about everyone
has an account on it
content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook and then we have Instagram well
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form video It Doesn't
Really drive a lot of traffic to your
website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four setting up a
social media calendar
a social media calendar demands the
message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
let's have a look at some of the most
popular types of posts on social media
first off we have competitions now I'm
sure all of you have seen posts like tag
a friend who does this or comment or
like to win something and stuff like
that competitions like these provide
great opportunities for engagement with
the audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media
then we have polls and surveys
polls can help you if you need a
collection that also encourages
followers to take action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and has so
much more to offer live stream with its
live nature and having a human face
alongside your business humanizes your
brand and by extension helps increase
customer loyalty and trust and then
there is infographics articles and
images
so social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization with it
you can create high quality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule posts on your social
calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer HootSuite
buzzsumo if Triple T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of posts
now for number six visual storytelling
visual storytelling involves passing out
a lot of information in the simplest of
forms visually using pictures and videos
your followers are able to grasp the
message quickly and remember it for a
long time afterwards visual storytelling
is also not limited by language barriers
and this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much more
but it also has some other advantages it
helps you build a bond with your
audience visual storytelling connects
with your audience methods like live
streaming help humanize your brand and
help grow customer loyalty and trust it
has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
so have a look at some of our videos so
here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and AI in five
minutes now these are some of our most
viewed videos on our Channel and now you
know why visual storytelling if you guys
are interested in watching these videos
you can check them out on our Channel
homepage and we also have similar videos
on blockchain devops and Six Sigma but
now back to the list
let's go to number seven paying for
advertising
this is a method that helps you find a
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goal
and this can help you improve your reach
and improve your Brand's visibility it's
pay per click model and shows cost
Effectiveness by providing great results
and return on investment it also helps
improve targeting by letting you control
who sees your ad you get to choose from
a number of different factors like
interests Hobbies personality types
alongside the basic user demographics
like age location gender and so on
now since most social media platforms
have native analytics you also get to
assess and Define the performance of
your ad campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
peer advertising first of all your
audience could get exposed to your posts
too many times and tune out your content
disregarding it in the process
second it could get really expensive for
small businesses or startups to manage a
campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant or unimportant you also
have to deal with a lot of competition
smaller companies with lesser budgets
have more of an uphill battle to deal
with than better funded organizations
next we have number eight news jacking
newsjacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services now it's a
popular method that's used to improve
brand awareness
newsjacking uses the popularity of
current events and drives it to your
brand it helps shine a spotlight on your
products and it also helps you show off
that you are up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant and by extension it
also improves engagement and website
traffic
now for number nine a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content a b testing helps determine
which of the variants your audience
engaged with the most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
and next up number 10 community and
influences
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry
actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up with
and on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience
it helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in YouTube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influencers we have Marcus Brownlee
unbox therapy Mr who's the boss and
Linus Tech tips each of them with more
than 4 million subscribers
and finally we're at number 11.
measuring and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process it ensures that you're
making the most out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand and these metrics can be tracked
weekly monthly or on a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
so on Facebook you could look out for
reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for impressions
clicks and Impressions and interactions
on LinkedIn and likes comments and
mentions on Instagram and engagements
and Impressions on Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
HootSuite Google analytics and so on we
are going to be talking about Facebook
advertising
we're going to talk about how businesses
use face we get fertility how the what
are the benefits they can get from it
we're going to show you with a demo on
how to set up your Facebook advertising
and we will close today's session with a
few do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising but before we go into that
make sure that if you like today's video
or if you like the simply learn Channel
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
below and if you liked the video feel
free to like it and share it with your
friends so let's get started
today's world has changed dramatically
when it comes to reaching your audiences
fact is that everybody is trying to get
the attention of the million of
prospects out there in the market
everybody is screaming try my product
try my product or try my product but
most businesses they now have to realize
that today's customer has changed yeah
today's customer is looking for instant
gratification they want a product now
wherever they are whatever their device
that they're using yeah and they can
prop they can Source their products from
everywhere in the world yeah but it is
your challenge to make sure that when
they are in the buying mode that you are
there to help them it's a new economy
out there it's a service driven economy
look at products like Uber or an Airbnb
where a whole new ecosystem has
developed of people offering their
products their services to a global
audience in marketing terms we're using
a term called solomo standing for social
local and mobile
yeah when you bring those three elements
together of social media local marketing
and mobile marketing you stand a really
good chance to connect with your
customers at the right time
Google has summarized this in what we
call Google moments on average people
have a couple of hundred moments during
a day where they grab their mobile phone
to do a search on their mobile phone
they maybe want to buy something they
want to book something they want to
share something they want to learn
something all those little moments or
opportunities for you to connect with
your customer or your prospect and
that's your opportunity but that's also
your challenge to make sure that you are
there
when your customers are having those
moments when they scream I want your
products
and there are plenty of channels that
you can use to reach those customers
yeah we know about social media we know
about your website there's things like
influencer marketing there's email
marketing and there's more and more
competition out there that are trying to
use those channels to reach your
audience but fact is there is one
channel that really stands out of all
these channels and that is pay-per-click
advertising
pay-per-click advertising is a well
established part of what we call the
digital marketing Trifecta and this
Trifecta consists the word triceps of
three components owned paid and earned
yes so the owned is your own website or
your own social media profiles in your
social media pages
but owned is no longer enough you need
to supplement your own media with paid
media and this is what we call
pay-per-click advertising
and then the third element of the
digital marketing Trifecta is what we
call earned media and earned media is
where you can still use that powerful
effects of public relations in an online
world or where you can work with
influencers to help you develop your
online presence and connect with your
audiences
but one of the best ways to start
getting to your audiences is to use
advertising
yep and there are various platforms for
advertising there is
um Google yeah there is Google search
advertising Google display advertising
and there is Facebook advertising now to
put these two in the context Google did
about 210 billion dollars of Revenue in
advertising in 2021 Facebook is about
half of that 115 billion dollars in 2021
and the most powerful models for
advertising are search ads and display
ads yeah so with search ads is in the
Google search which is what Google the
offers the display ads and video ads are
offered by Google and by Facebook
and we call this pay-per-click
advertising which means you're not
paying for showing your ad but you're
paying when people click on your ads
okay so let's have a look between uh to
this advertising in a bit more detail
you have Facebook advertising was
introduced on around 2007.
yeah so
um in 2007 it was launched by Facebook
yep so but it has grown drastically
since then in 2011 ads were being shown
in the news feed yeah Google a Facebook
called it sponsored stories in 2012 ads
came on the mobile yeah mobile ads are
now considered the most powerful
um forms of pay-per-click advertising in
2014 a Facebook introduced a three-level
advertising structure which was very
much introduced by Google as well where
you have campaigns you have ad sets and
you have your ads and when you go in
setup and you'll see that later your
your ads in Facebook you will have to go
through these three ad elements
campaigns ad sets and ads to set up your
advertising on Facebook
in 2016 in 26 sorry in 2016 Facebook
introduced chat Bots and ads in
messenger which became a whole new area
for advertising for Facebook yeah
connecting with
um customers on Facebook messenger and
offering that for advertising as well
and in 2018 there was a whole range of
AD formats available on Facebook from
videos stories messenger Carousel
slideshows collections so a whole range
of ads to choose from when you start
your face setting up your Facebook ads
now what is the future yeah what does
the future hold for Facebook advertising
as you may have read
um that both Facebook and Google are
having a lower Revenue in their
advertising given the whole world
economic uh situation we're slowly
moving towards a a recession even yeah
Facebook and Google and Microsoft all
the big Tech players are feeling the
impact in that yes so that is one
Element now one of the other reasons why
Facebook's Revenue has gone down in
advertising HD tracking capabilities and
a lot of businesses they track people
when they visit their website and then
you can Target them with ads we call
this retargeting in marketing terms now
Apple has announced
um earlier this year that on iOS people
can say which is on the iPhone people
can decide to not being tracked yep so
that has put a whole sort of kind of a
um a a
um a a different set of Dynamics in
Facebook advertising on the iPhone and
it is not as effective as it was before
that announcement from um from Apple
so the future of advertising is all
about security it's about privacy and of
course in the end it all comes down to
how good are your ads how what is the
quality of the content in your ads are
you able to stand out from the crowd
yeah so those are the big challenges in
Facebook advertising now you have to be
aware that Facebook advertising is
completely different than Google search
advertising
you have to put it into a context Google
search advertising is what we call
intent based yeah so when I have a
question or I'm looking for something or
I need a plumber I go to Google Search
yeah and I search for plumber near me
and Google will give me some ads with
plumbers near me
that is not the way Facebook advertising
Works Facebook advertising yeah is not
intent based it is basically it is your
challenge when you advertise on Facebook
is to stop the user from browsing and
click on your ads so it's more
interruptive you need to make sure that
they stop what they're doing which is
much more difficult
yeah so you'll see that Facebook is
therefore slightly more challenging to
actually generate leads yeah to get new
customers
Google advertising is much better for
that but Facebook advertising is much
better to reach a global audience very
targeted yeah and work on awareness
developing your proposition helping your
prospects to go through the buying cycle
yeah so Facebook ads they help spread
product and brand awareness in the news
feed or on Instagram or on messenger to
a very specific targeted audience
now another element which is important
to understand when it comes to Facebook
advertising is to do with Organic reach
when I have a Facebook post and I do oh
sorry when I have a Facebook page and I
do a post on my page the people that
will like my that have liked my page
will see my post on their news feed
that's how the theory
is yeah of course not everybody will see
those posts because that wouldn't work
because then you would get way too much
advertising in your feed yeah so
Facebook is very selective in the number
of posts from advertising from
businesses or sorry from businesses that
will show on your news feed
yeah and in fact that percentage of
people that will see your posts your
business posts on their personal news
feed is less than three percent so again
if you have a Facebook page let's say
with 10 000 followers and you do a post
on your Facebook page less than 300
people will see your post
now businesses are not happy with that
yeah they said hey Facebook why are you
doing that I want to reach my entire
audience and Facebook says well hey you
still can yeah but it's going to cost
you some money and Facebook says you
have to go and advertise on Facebook to
reach your audiences so businesses Now
understand that Facebook is what we call
pay to play
you to reach your audiences you have to
supplement your organic reach with
advertising
and the beauty about Facebook
advertising is that it is a fantastic
way to reach your target audience
and that is the biggest benefit that
Facebook advertising can give you it's
all about the targeting there are so
many
targeting options in Facebook and I'll
show you when we go into the short demo
on how to set up your ads so what are
the reasons why businesses go into
Facebook yeah what are the reasons what
are the benefits that they will get from
it and the first big benefit that they
get is that they get access to an
audience which is out there
yeah and it is not just a small audience
we're talking about Facebook at as of
today as close to 3 billion active
monthly users that is a massive numbers
and most of these people they check
their profiles at least once daily so it
is a huge audience to reach and there is
no better social media Network to reach
a global audience than on Facebook
yeah so that is one of the reasons why
you want to start advertising on
Facebook the second reason why you want
to start advertising on Facebook is that
Facebook gives you a fantastic platform
to advertise your products to People
based on their demographics based on
their interests based on their location
based on their
um their history of browsing based on so
many different segmentation factors
which means that you can make sure that
your ads reach the Right audience
which is a really good benefit that you
will get from Facebook advertising
the next benefit that you get from
Facebook advertising is that it is very
cost effective
yeah you can just start with a small
budget you can slowly increase your
budget you can relate your budget to the
returns that you're getting from it so
it helps you spend less and achieve more
it is one of the advertising platforms
with the highest return on investment of
your on your money so very cost
effective to advertise on Facebook
here are some other reasons why
businesses use advertising on Facebook
it really helps them with increasing
brand awareness as I said earlier the
difference with Google search
advertising Facebook is not intent based
people are not searching in Facebook
looking for Content which could include
your ads they are actually browsing on
Facebook and it is your challenge yeah
to
um to be creative enough to make them
stop browsing and pay attention to your
ads so it really helps in increasing
brand awareness it's let it's an
opportunity for you to Showcase your
brand and to help them add value to
their lives so by doing that you
establish trust you establish
credibility yeah and you provide recall
value for your brand
so it is all about taking the customer
by the hand and helping them
in going through the buying cycle
yes so when the buying cycle is about
awareness is about building interest
yeah then building that trust that they
then will turn into buying your product
the second big benefit that you're
getting from Facebook is to Target
people that have already expressed an
interest in your service we call this
retargeting you may also have heard
about pixel targeting or pixel marketing
it basically means that if somebody
visits your website
yeah you can then retarget those people
with an ads
from a technical element as a
perspective it means that you need to
put Facebook will give you a piece of
code that you need to put on your
website
and then as soon as somebody visits that
website that triggers that code it
automatically connects with Facebook and
then Facebook will capture that user
data that you can then use to Target
them with a specific ads
so a big opportunity there for the
retargeting but things will be changing
here in the near future yeah Google has
announced that by 2023 24 it will stop
enabling third parties to leave cookies
on the um on on websites yeah to Target
people so that whole retargeting area
will go and will undergo some big
changes in the near future and then of
course Facebook advertising can really
help you increase Revenue as I said
earlier it is a fantastic way to to
connect with people and take them by the
hand through the buying cycle you can
educate your audiences about what your
product has to offer yeah and the more
people know about your products the more
likely they are prepared to make a
purchase and to share their experiences
so lots of benefits that you get now
let's dive a bit deeper into this and
let's look at the different type of ads
that Facebook has available so first
there is the single image ad
these are single ads single image ads
that have an option uh optional text on
the top and a link description that
links to your website and a call to
action that is very important to have a
good call to action in your ads the ad
images they need to be 1200 by 628
pixels
so that's where you have an opportunity
in the visual to stand out in the news
feed and make people stop and then click
on the link as you see here for instance
sign up
the next ads are the multi-product ads
they are usually carousels so it enables
you allow consumers to see all the
products or the services that you have
available they're very efficient they're
very Visual and they have lots of
creative options
um in them so they're very popular and
they're blocks being being used Lots by
by businesses so that's your
multi-product ads usually via a carousel
then of course you have your video ads
Now video ads are 30 seconds to two
minute ads and they are amongst
Facebook's most engaging most popular
ads they get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other ads and not only views
also engagement why because people love
to engage with video when you engage
with video you have the opportunity to
touch emotions of people which is much
stronger in building trust building
relationships with your audience
a particularly video on mobile yeah
works really well so it's a high growth
area of video advertising and one area
that you definitely need to look at if
you want to be successful with Facebook
advertising
then you have the lead ads lead ads they
offer slightly different way to
advertise your products they let you get
usernames emails phone numbers actually
without leaving Facebook
yeah and that's what makes them really
powerful within Facebook advertising you
can actually create a sign up form or
you could even drive them through
Messenger and have a communication with
them to get their details through a
chatbot
so people don't leave Facebook you do
the whole process of lead generation and
lead capture within Facebook and it can
be easily synchronized with your
existing CRM system
and then you have collection ads
collection ads blend video and product
catalog photos so they are really good
if you want to advertise multiple
products at once yeah if you want to do
this so collection ads work really well
okay so that's a short introduction of
Facebook advertising the benefits that
you get why people would use them why
businesses would use them and the
different type of ads so in the next
section let's go and have a look at how
do you create an ad what are the steps
to create a Facebook ads
so here you see I am on a Facebook page
and this is the page for Riyadh for
Russia which is a hotel in Marrakech and
I am the admin for this page
and what I'm going to show you on this
page is how to access the advertising
platform and how to set up your ads
yes so let me first before I do this
show you what Facebook is trying to do
everywhere whether it's your desktop or
your mobile to make sure that you go
into advertise creation mode yeah so
you'll see it everywhere promote
ad Center create ads create automated
ads boost post wherever you are you will
come to sections like boost post or go
please create an ad on the mobile it's
even more obvious yeah here is the same
page but then on the mobile device and
if I scroll down you see on the first
post immediately boost the post so
you'll see that Facebook is trying
everything to get you to advertise
yeah and I think it is a bit annoying
yeah but it's also you need to be aware
that all the various places that
Facebook will try to to hook you into
advertising they lead to various
subsections of the advertising platform
yeah so if I click here on booster post
it will take me to a what I call a quick
and dirty boost advertising module yeah
so I say I'm gonna good morning from our
rooftop I'm going to turn that post into
an ad yeah it I can immediately suicide
what goal do I want for my ad do I want
to add a button what is the URL yeah do
I want to edit the image who is my
audience yeah and then what is the
budget what is the duration where am I
going to show these ads and how am I
going to pay Bang Bang
boost post now
yeah so it's looks very interesting and
very effective to do this but what you
see here is you will only get a
subsection of what Facebook advertising
can do for you
yeah and if you think hey if that's okay
with you that's fine but you're missing
90 of the other features to make your
ads as effective as possible
in other words my advice to you would be
don't click on the boost a post button
on your mobile or your desktop because
again it leads you to a limited
functionality of the advertising module
and the advertising capabilities that
Facebook can offer you
so back to the desktop the same applies
here if I click here on Boost post
yeah there's nothing wrong with
advertising for a post you can take one
of your most successful posts or for a
video and you can create additional
reach for that post through advertising
but don't do it through the limited
advertising functionality again this is
a quick and dirty module everything on
one page and it will you can click boost
post now and it's an easy way to start
spending your money yes so that is if
you click the Boost post the same
applies if you go to the
create ads or create automated ads yeah
so let me show you the create automated
ads it takes you through a very
automated process of creating ads which
is great when you're a beginner
but again it'll only give you limited
functionality of what Facebook
advertising has to offer you
so my advice would be don't go to the
automated ads click on create ads that
again gives you limited functionality
gives it all in one page again you don't
want to do that
yep and then you click on the add Center
that gives you again a summary of the
advertising slightly more tools
yeah but it's all to lure you into spend
money in a very quick way
so then where do I go for my advertising
the place where you go ish to the
Facebook or how do you know called meta
The Meta business Suite The Meta
business Suite gives you everything you
need for your advertising it allows you
to manage multiple advertising accounts
yep and it gives you access to the full
functionality of what Facebook has to
offer you so let's go there The Meta
business Suite
hmm
so here you see
everything you need for your advertising
yeah so here you see it's your read for
Russia and it's not only for your
advertising you can manage your posts
here you can schedule your posts manage
your inbox your notification manage your
content manage your shop plan your post
now we'll cover all these areas in
future videos but for now we want to
focus on the advertising again even here
they have ads as a quick and dirty
method to create your ads again where I
want you to go click here on all tools
and now finally this is where you want
to go it gives you access to the full
advertising functionality to create your
ads to manage your ads to manage your
audiences to set up events when you want
to connect get data from your website
and where you can create your forms
this is where you want to go yeah so if
I click here on the ads manager
that takes me to the full advertising
platform
now here you see by the way turn off ad
blocker yeah which is important because
in your creation of your ads Facebook
will obviously
[Music]
simulate your your ads yeah but if you
have your ad blocker on the ads will not
show in the preview so it is important
that you switch off the ad blocker so
you create your browser environment
exactly as users will have in when they
they see your ads so let me go into
switching that off
which is more tools extensions and you
see here my ad blocker is on so I'm
going to switch that off
yeah let me do a review
yes so here you have your account
overview you have your uh your desk is
your sort of your dashboard now you see
I haven't run any campaigns yeah so I'm
not gonna so there's not much to see
here in this and this this tool so let's
go here under my campaigns yeah and this
gives me the basic sort of structure of
your advertising on Facebook
yeah and remember we talked about
campaigns ad sets and ads
yeah those are the three elements of
your
advertising campaign on Facebook you
create a campaign and I'll show you what
you need to set up in the campaigns then
within a campaign you can have multiple
ad sets and those ad sets within a
campaign inherit the settings of the
campaign
and then within ad sets you have ads
yep and Those ads they inherit the
settings of the ad sets and the settings
of the campaign
all right so you see here we have three
or two campaigns or three campaigns
there is a new leads campaign there is a
page likes and there is a traffic
campaign so now I'm not going to show
you these campaigns I'm actually going
to show you how to create a campaign
so let's go into that here is create
if you have experience with advertising
in pay-per-click advertising you will
recognize this approach Google ads has
it as well it is what we call guided
campaign creation
yeah so when you start your Facebook ads
and when you start your Google ads you
can select do you want an awareness
campaign
do you want a traffic engagement leads
promote your apps or a sales campaign
yeah and basically once the campaign
objective that you select will
set a number of the settings yeah sort
of specifically for that campaign
objective so it makes it easier to align
it with your business goals and the
whole setup will be done easier
yeah so here you see an awareness
objective so that is too good for reach
for brand awareness for video views yeah
so it's showing the ad to the month to
as many people as possible who are
likely to remember them
traffic is to send people to a
destination like your website this is
really good to get link clicks to get
views from a landing page or get people
get into conversations with people on
Messenger or Whatsapp engagement ads is
get more messages videos views post
engagements it's good for Instagram
first messaging apps good for video
views engagement on posts
lead ads or collect leads for your
business or brand they're good for
instant forms on messenger good for
conversions and to get calls here is to
promote your apps like in app installs
app events and here is sales that is for
your catalog sales for instance
yeah we're going to do a simple one I'm
going to set up a traffic I want to
drive people to a landing page
yeah so here I'm going to click on
traffic yeah and I'm going to click
continue
so now I'm going into the campaign
settings so here you see the three
structures again the new traffic
campaign new traffic ad set new traffic
ads that I'm going to use
okay so here is my traffic campaign I'm
going to create a name which is I'm
going to stick with new traffic campaign
am I going to use any ads are there any
AD categories yeah so is it about
elections is it about politics is it
about employment about social issues
yeah I remember a few years ago there
was this Scandal when there was brexit
and the Trump elections or the in 2018 I
believe it was there was a lot of data
being sold by this Cambridge analytica
that they data they took from Facebook
and they sold it to the campaign teams
of the U.S election and of the brexit
yeah that had a big impact on privacy on
Facebook and on
um advertising for for elections and
politics so and now Facebook has set
some extra sort of security guidelines
for specific uh categories
now what are the campaign details
here you see by default it is set as an
auction
pay-per-click works on an auction base
and this is not a pay-per-click course
but basically it means you will do a bit
on your ad how much you're prepared to
pay for a Click app and that will then
go into an auction and that will
determine the position of your ads we
want to get more traffic
do you want to do a b testing yes and we
want Facebook to do that yeah or you
switch that off and what is your budget
do you want to create distribute your
butt set across ad sets yeah if you want
to do that you can switch that on and
then you have your campaign budget so
we're going to set a daily budget of 20
pounds yes so go back to the
phone setting yeah and then what is your
campaign bit strategy I just want the
highest volume and there's more options
you can schedule your ads so you can set
it at specific times my advice is to run
the ads all the time yeah particularly
in the learning phase when Facebook
launches your campaign it goes into
learning mode and then Facebook will see
by itself when your audience will
[Music]
will will respond and they will adjust
the ad scheduling accordingly so there
is your traffic campaign
details then we're going to your traffic
ad set where do you want to drive your
traffic to your website to an app to
messenger we want to drive it to the
website
now Dynamic creative is an important one
yeah do you want to want Facebook to
create your ads or do you want to do it
yourself when you want Facebook to do it
you provide creative elements like
images and headlines and then Facebook
will automatically generate the best ads
for you yeah so I kind of like that yeah
so I always switch that on on here you
see the schedule when do you want to
start
yeah so do you want to send an end as
well so that would be then let's say
November the 22nd and then here is some
more options you can set at spend limits
and here is where the real meaty
sort of stuff happens in Facebook
advertising this is where you can select
your audience
you can save specific audiences
in the audience manager yeah so you can
have a number of audience if you have an
office in one country or another country
you can just hear select select the
audience for that particular country or
you can just create a new audience
okay so you can exclude audiences you
can set a location you can set the age
location let's look at that if I click
here on edit people living in or
recently in this location
people living people recently people
traveling in this location so this is
really powerful if you want to Target
people who are visiting a uh an event
like a football match or what have you
and you can include and this is where
you can search location you can in
search by City let's say London
yes oh London England or I can say let's
do prisons reading in England
yeah and I can even say uh give me
yeah so I can search location give me uh
rg7 I can do my postcode yeah so I can
actually people doing in the reading
area by postcode and I really like this
so if I say for instance
rg76 yeah so here you can see how you
can Target a specific area
and this is particularly for your local
marketing is very important
yep so that is the the local targeting
is really good so you can and then by
the way here you see your estimated
audience size and when your audience get
bigger you see estimated daily results
as well
and then you can do more you can search
by
um where was this you can search by
detailed targeting by demographics by
interests and behaviors yeah so if I
want to people who like reading
Football Club
yeah so here is the reading FC soccer
team yeah so here are I can now sent an
ad targeting specifically people in that
particular area who like and we have the
UK as well yeah so uh in reading and
that particular area who like football
who like Reading Football Club yeah or I
can
um other at other areas as well there's
also the suggestions if people like
reading they may also like these type of
things Neymar soccer or maybe they like
Manchester United yeah so this is just a
tip of the iceberg the whole
segmentation in Facebook advertising and
the targeting is extremely powerful
okay here are your placements for your
Facebook ads best is to let Facebook
decide where to place your ads but to
show you where your ads can be shown on
Facebook if you click on the manual
placements you see here they can show on
Facebook they can show on Instagram on
messenger and on the Audience Network
now what is the Audience Network Google
has said as well yeah in the display ads
which are ads that show on millions of
websites that Facebook has an agree or
that Google or in this case Facebook has
an agreement with so it shows your
Facebook ads outside Facebook
or millions of websites okay so that's
the Audience Network then if you look at
it here is the feeds where you're at can
she can show
your ads can show in stories and reels
your ad can show in-stream videos
overlay and post Loop ads on reels on
Facebook search on messaging in article
apps inside so there is tons of places
where your ads can show but the best
thing is to let Facebook decide where
your ads are going to show
okay so these are your ad set settings
so let's now look at the ads
so here you see the Facebook page and in
our case it is the Riyadh for Russia
page
there you go yeah we'll make it you can
opt in for Branded content tools you can
look at the ad setup we can do manual
upload you can get data from your
product catalog and here you specify
what type of AD you want to show is it a
single image or a video or is it a
carousel
yep and then here you have your ads
creative
and your media and the select images
select videos and then here you have
your primary text headline description
your website URL this is where you can
do your url parameters when you want to
track your campaigns
yeah here you see the ad previewed at
preview is off and now it's on yeah but
of course I need to select media
so let's see
find images so here we're going to say
go to my website
and create an image for me approve
yeah so now it will actually show me
some images
select images yeah so here you see
images from my reacts
yeah that it picks up from my react or
from my website here's the website yes
so let's take uh
let's take this image and we'll say
continue
yeah so
so selected destination link for your
ads let me see where we're going to put
that one
there you go yes from now because I put
in the destination link you will see how
the ad start building up but this is the
photo that I selected yeah now I'm not
going to show you the details of and I'm
not going to use as an example here I
just want you to show you the fields
where you can play and create your ads
yeah and then you see here in the ad
preview whether you see it in the feeds
there is a mobile preview as well
yep so you see here the feeds you see
here the stories and the reels how they
would look on Instagram the in stream
app and here in the search in article
and on apps
yes so there you have it that is your
traffic ads so we've now done our
campaign we've done our ad set we've
done our traffic ads and then basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to publish your ads
now when you're going to publish
yeah you can then go back to view the
details
and then you see that the ad is
um done and it is actually in review by
Facebook so if I now go back to my
campaigns
yeah let's close this one
you see here is the new traffic ads yeah
and you see here it's processing and
then here you see immediately the
details that you can get from your
campaign yes so you see the processing
you see the ad set name the bit strategy
the budget you see attribution setting
so basically attribution is how you
track the results of your ads
and then you see here the results in
number of Link clicks how many people
reached how many Impressions what is the
cost per result what is the quality
ranking the engagement ranking the
conversion ranking the higher these
rankings the better Facebook considers
your ads and the more and the better the
positions for your ads here you see your
amount spent and here you see the end
date of the campaign
yes so that is how you set up your
Facebook ads as a kind of introduction
to the Facebook advertising
yeah so if I now go back to all my
campaigns
campaigns yeah so you see here let me
see if I have some now you see there's
no none of these ads actually run or did
run in the past yes so I can't show you
the the results but we'll go into more
details at a later the later session on
on Facebook advertising for now this is
I think the best overview I can give you
yeah and if you want to get more than
details then we'll go in a more in-depth
session of the Facebook advertising
okay now that is all clear let's look at
the do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising
what should you do and what shouldn't
you do with your ads
so there are various dues to first of
all make sure you continuously test your
ads
and the good thing is that Facebook will
do this for you yeah you can tell
Facebook please test my ads you can give
Facebook a collection of creative
materials a collection of headlines yeah
and it will actually mix and match those
headlines and it will use the ones that
will give the best
um the best conversions so it's very
important that you continuously look
yeah at your performance and see if
minor changes to your ads will lead to a
better performance
second make sure that your images and
that your videos are engaging remember
there is no intent in Facebook
advertising you have to be very creative
to stand out from the crowd and you can
only do that by making your ads
engagement or them by making your ads
engaging
in images and videos
so the not only the images or the videos
but it's also the messaging that you use
use a message that will stay with your
audience
yeah so it's the combination of the
visuals and the key message of your ad
that will make people stop
if by looking in a split second at your
ad yeah they get it
then they will stop and they will
click on the call to action so make sure
you use a message that is
powerful and effective
also keep it simple or we say kiss keep
it simple and stupid make sure that
people easily understand
the message that you're trying to convey
with your ads don't make it too
complicated don't use complicated
visuals don't use complicated messages
keep it simple
and make sure that you reach the Right
audience
yeah Facebook's biggest benefit is the
targeting you can Target micro or micro
level targeting people in very specific
areas
yeah so that is the deuce and of course
there are don'ts as well so the first
thing is be sensible with your budget
don't spend your whole Budget on one
single campaign
yeah so start small and basically grow
your budget based on the results that
you're getting
yeah if you have to use visuals and
messages that are appealing then of
course don't make sure that you put too
much information in the ads again keep
your ads simple don't clutter them with
too much text and too many visuals
make sure that you proofread your ads
don't have typos in your ads there's not
a lot of text in your ad so please make
sure that you double check the quality
of the ads when it comes to the language
and the um the Cramer yeah so don't
forget to proofread your ads
be sensible in the activity level that
you have on your Facebook page yeah up
until a few years ago it was
it was actually promoted by Facebook to
do as many posts as you think are
relevant for your business people did
four or five posts a day nowadays it is
not about the quantity it is about the
quality so don't do too many posts on
your Facebook page be sensible think
from a customer perspective also when it
comes to your ads yeah so too many ads
or showing the same ads to the same
people all the time yeah may have an
adverse result
and then finally make sure that your
image relates to your product so don't
put up an image that doesn't relate to
the advertised product introducing
simple lens postgraduate program in
digital marketing that will transform
you into Master of the digital realm
this comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
enroll in a postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below we're going to talk about
affiliate marketing so let's jump right
into it and take a look inside an office
environment right now we have chalk here
Chuck's doing a little bit of pacing
John walks in the office hey man what's
with all the pacing everything all right
Chuck responded hey I'm just worried
that I might have exhausted every way we
can advertise our product I mean I've
done done SEO I've done paid search I've
done email I've done social man
nothing's working I got to come up with
something new ASAP well John responds
hey don't worry I think I've got your
solution for you man hang tight relax
take a load off here's my solution
affiliate marketing first off before you
ask the question what's affiliate
marketing let's talk about why we need
affiliate marketing so let's dig into
affiliate marketing so John's just
taking over now and he's gonna let Chuck
know everything there is to know about
affiliate marketing so the first
question John answers for Chuck what is
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if I'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me I'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these margins are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
The Exchange is you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
John's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away John so
John says first we have the merchant AKA
The Brand the seller the Creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea This
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone one okay so it
could be startups it's a large
multinational companies International
companies non-profits for-profits
individuals independent contractors
Freelancers a group of people who have a
passion for something okay it could be
anybody there's no limit the affiliate
aka the publisher so the affiliate is
basically that third party website or
entity which promotes the merchants
products and tries to convince potential
customers of the merchants products
value so this affiliate's going to
represent the merchant on their behalf
and try and get their clients to
basically purchase that particular
Merchant's product so the affiliate
could be incentivized based on you know
registrations email sign ups sales and
subscription so it doesn't always come
down to you know sales you know if I'm
just trying to get you know build my
email list then hey I can incentivize
that affiliate to push email signups if
I'm got this big you know offline you
know promotion that I'm doing at this
particular mall and I want to get people
there well I can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
sign ups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to fun
collaborate with not just any affiliate
but the affiliate best suited for their
particular brand and product because you
want to find somebody who is going to be
passionate who's relevant who has your
prospective customers in mind because
they're the ones that are going to help
those protective customers purchase your
product so that's what the affiliate
network does it helps bring the
merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
did
[Music]
we will understand how Google analytics
works
how we can use it to measure the
performance of our website we'll also
understand how to set up goals and
create events that will help us keep our
website on track
next we will look at Google tag manager
and towards the end we will unlock the
mystery of how to rank at number one
position on Google it's not that hard as
you think it is
we have Rob with us who has more than 15
years of experience in digital marketing
and analytics and he will take us
through these topics over to you rob
welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and today we're going
to talk about Google analytics I'm very
excited to be with you today because
Google analytics is one of my favorite
Google platforms and my favorite topics
so let's talk about what we're going to
cover today I'm going to start out with
how to set up a Google analytics account
and so we're going to talk about
everything that entails including
creating your Google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account and what a
property is we're going to talk about
setting up a reporting view in your
property and we're going to talk about
installing the tracking code so those
are the series of steps we're going to
go through today in terms of setting up
a Google analytics account so let's get
right to it and so really the Bruin
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be to name your company your your
name whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what Google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.com simplylearn.com it's going to
share that data anonymously with others
in the industry in this case jobs and
education and because you've opted in
it's going to do the same exact thing
for you it's going to share Anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the Benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important and I'm going to go over
that in a few minutes when we go over
the different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industry is performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialist I would also recom man you
opt into those because then it allows
you to basically Google allow Google
access to your account and they'll be
able to help you if you occur or run
into any issues so these are the options
in setting up a Google analytics account
it's very simple very easy to do you're
just entering in a few Fields note that
we talking about a website right now so
I'm talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app Google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what Google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
ID now I'm going to accept the terms of
service I'm going to accept another
terms and service and relay relation to
data protection I'm going to click
accept once I accept I'm going to be
able to get some tracking code the
tracking ID is the ID associated with
your account and so this number is going
to be associated with your account so
your account ID starts with UA and it's
going to be this number here now the
dash one is the property you set up so
in this case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number is just gonna have a
dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
okay so again take a look at the video
we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google's going to do
is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this so if I click on
demo account here it's going to add to
my Google analytics account so I'm going
to have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar or you're not sure
what you're getting yourself into so
think of the demo account as kind of a
test drive you're test driving Google
analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a Google account and if you have a
Google account and you add the demo
account to your Google analytics account
you're going to be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
I would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do is just
simply add the demo account and then
once you add the demo account you're
free to peruse around Google analytics
to see the different types of reports it
has to offer now when you do actually
set up a Google analytics account you're
going to have some settings that you're
going to want to pay attention to so
when you set up the account you have the
account name and then you have a
property so under each property you have
by default you're going to have one View
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property is demos simply learned so
that's associated with the website we're
going to track and then again by default
under each property you're going to have
a view and so by default the name of the
view is going to be called all website
data and so in that view is where all
your analytics data is going to be
stored so you can see my screen here
there's a lot of different settings you
have you have settings under the account
you have settings under the property and
you have settings under the view so
we're going to talk more about these
settings and future webinars for
advanced Google analytics users but for
now know that there's a bunch of
settings that you have that you can play
around with when it comes to Google
analytics anything from adding users to
your Google analytics account your
Google analytics property or view you
can actually set up goals you can set up
filters you can set up segments you can
link up Google ads you can you know set
up remarketing list there's a lot you
can do in terms of the settings as it
relates to Google analytics but so know
those settings are there they're located
right down here in this little sprocket
icon that's the admin icon so if you
need to get to these settings at any
time you could simply just click on the
sprocket or the admin icon and then
you'll be prompted to choose any one of
these settings here that you want to
edit or alter so now let's take a look
at some Google analytics reports so once
you've actually set up your account you
have a number of different reports that
you have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm an admin and I'm
looking at at the Google demo account
let's start out by looking at real time
so if I click on the real time report
and I just click on overview so
basically what this is going to do is
show me at this point in time how many
users I actually have active on the
website okay so that's why they call it
real time reporting because it allows
you to see the behavior of users who are
currently on your website and so this is
the overview report under real time and
you can see here I can see that 79
percent of my users are coming from
desktop 18 20 are coming from mobile and
then approximately three percent are
coming from tablet here I can see how
they actually came to the website so
this is the referring Source if they
came from say search or social I can see
the source there and I can see what
pages they're active on and then here I
can see what locations where they're
located and so if I want to see a
breakdown of everything in the overview
I can certainly do that if I go to
locations under real time I could see a
majority of my users are coming from the
United States okay where are they coming
from I'll just click on traffic sources
and here I could see the different
sources and mediums medium is the means
in which the traffic was driven so if
it's Google it's either paid search or
organic search so I can see here it's
organic then I can actually see what
contents they're looking at on my
website so I could see currently I have
three active users on the home page two
active users on the Google's women's
white t page so forth and so on now most
importantly if you have a vent tracking
set up so if you taking a look at our
Google tag manager webinar you know that
you could set up event tracking in
Google analytics to measure engagement
on your website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look look at
what conversions are happening in real
time just by clicking on conversions and
so now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you could see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we can still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they use so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented
English-speaking users from Great
Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the Google and Alex tracking
script to your website what's going to
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what Google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking at analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here I can see April 6
through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I could see about 23 24 are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving new traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous pair period or the previous
year I'm going to choose the last 30
days I'm going to click apply now I'm
looking at data over the last 30 days
and again you can change the date range
to any range you want you can only go
back as far as when you actually created
the Google analytics account you can't
go prior to that so here I'm looking at
the last 30 days and I can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender I
can say 66 percent represent males so I
can get a breakout of gender and age as
well as interest and click on interest
and look at the overview there and see
what the interest is of the users who
are coming to my site based on in-market
segments or Affinity I can also choose
language and location so if I want to
know exactly where my users are located
located when they're coming to my
website I can click on location and here
I can get a breakout 43 percent of the
users of the last 30 days were from the
United States more importantly I can
align my audience with goals and we'll
talk about goals here in a minute but
here I can see if I have an e-commerce
website I can see of those 43 percent
0.29 percent of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 percent of
the traffic so desktop still represents
a majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce Ray is approximately 48 percent
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case for mobile landed on a page
they left the site without going any
further so they consider it a bounce if
they don't go to another page if they
leave the site from the page they landed
on and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users should come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 4 38
mobile and desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 now if I look a little bit
further at engagement I can see how many
pages on average do mobile users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see 3.86 on desktop it's
4.5 now if I look a little bit further
in engagement I want to be able to
measure how long somebody from mobile
stays on the website if they're bouncing
at 48 percent but they're also looking
at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four pages per
session then that means in this report
analytics is telling me they're spending
about two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough I can see that
mobile of the last 30 days had more
transactions so 51 transactions versus
34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is low located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if I close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if I click on
customization if I click on Save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we're setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did I actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs and education and I choose
education all education as my industry
vertical I should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how I compare with those
websites so I'm choosing all countries I
can narrow that down if I wanted to I
can just search for the United States I
can choose a specific State and then I
can choose a particular site size so
here I'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
United States sites that have five
thousand to nine thousand nine hundred
ninety nine sessions per day that means
that they're approximately 310 web
property is contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria I chose now
if my site is similar meaning if I'm in
the United States if I'm in education
and I'm receiving 5 000 to 9 999
sessions per day then I'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now Google sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's a
shared data anonymously in particular
Industries and verticals and so now I'm
looking at a channel report so if I want
to see how I compare to others in my
industry then I can go ahead and see by
channel for example in my driving as
much traffic as others in my industry
and you can see I'm not in fact I'm 76
77 worse in terms of the amount traffic
being driven from organic search so
anything in red is going to show as a
negative result a negative comparison
whereas something in green is a positive
comparison so if I look at engagement I
can see that I might not be driving as
much traffic but I can see that the
pages per session are better than the
site average or the industry average I
can see if I go over again looking just
at organic search I can see the bounce
rate is better than the industry average
so the channel report under benchmarking
allows you to measure how you compare to
others in your industry and you could do
so by looking at location and devices so
if you opted into benchmarking when you
set up your account then you'll be able
to compare your website against others
in your industry in your country region
and based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our
websites they come via organic search
meaning do they type something into
Google and find you in the organic
listing analytics also groups users
based on whether they came to your site
directly meaning did they type in the
URL directly into the browser or did
they bookmark your website site and come
back via the bookmark so they're
grouping users under direct they also
group users under referral meaning do
they come from another website they
group users by social do they come from
a social media platform like Twitter or
Facebook if you're running paid search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say Google then do they come from Paid
search ads now if you're running display
ads on say Google's Network Google's
Display Network that's a default channel
so analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report it's
so so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number's about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our Channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of those four fifty four
thousand users I had 70 000 sessions I
could see my average bounce rate was 43
percent the pages per session were just
over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about 2 minutes
and 50 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and I had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500 okay and
that's all over the last 30 days so any
report you look at in analytics is going
to have a summary and note that any
to allow you to save it so if it's a
report you think you're going to go back
and look at at a future date then you
simply just have to click on the save
button conversely if you don't want to
save it you can simply just export it so
you can export it as a PDF if I click on
PDF it's going to allow me to export
that as a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a common
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my channel using
and then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can connect Google ads to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from Google ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
Google ads I'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here I'm running a
report based on campaign data so I could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much I'm paying per click and you
can see on average I'm paying 34 cents
per click and then more importantly I
want to be able to see if they're
converting so you can see I've spent 810
dollars over the last 30 days and
received 850 58 dollars in Revenue so
you want to make sure that you link up
your Google ads account to your Google
analytics account for this very reason
you want to be able to see how your
Google ads campaigns perform once the
users get to your website and so I want
to see if they're engaging and I want to
see if they're converting so they're all
sorts of reports under Google ads so you
can look at it by keywords by search
queries by hour of the day if you're
running display campaigns you can look
at display targeting it says all sorts
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
Facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website do they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages I've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where page uses accumulation of how many
times the page was viewed in the same
session so in other words you're always
going to have more page views than
unique pages okay so this gives me a
sense of how my pages performed so again
I can look at total page views and then
engagement so ideally what you want to
do with a report like this is if a user
is not engaging on the page then that
should tell you something about the page
itself if they're not engaging if the
bounce rate's high if the time on page
is low if the exit percentage of exit
rate is high then you probably want to
do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people people
actually landed on that page and so here
I can see under my landing page report I
can see the home page had 36 000 17
sessions in the last 30 days that's how
many people landed on the home page so
here I can see 71 percent were news
sessions meaning that I had a lot of new
users who landed on the home page in
fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page for new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is they can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 20 22 transactions
totaling 1200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of 0.06
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to point zero six
percent of the revenue so this gives you
an idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because with Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser what the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about about the site speed
report is if I go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load Time by Page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create foreign
correct the page load of that particular
page so look at the site speed report
it's important because there is a
correlation between site speed or page
load time and user behavior of that page
and there's also correlation between
page load time and a page ranking
organically on search so page load time
is very important it's so important that
I'm even going to save it so I'm going
to click save and click on speed site
speed suggestions as my name and click
OK and now that report is going to be
saved under customization under save
reports let's jump from Behavior to
conversions now conversion reporting is
arguably the most important section in
in Google analytics because what the
conversions reporting allows us to do is
see how people are converting or if
they're not converting on our website
and so in Google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your Google analytics View and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and Under The View you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types in analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if I
look here I can see I have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it it's going to
count as a goal and in this case I can
see here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal ties we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example is
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least one minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is an event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event into a goal so if
somebody clicks on say the submit button
of a form you can turn that event into
to a goal so here you can see the
category equals contact form so you can
always verify if a goal works just by
clicking on verify this goal and in this
case this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
going to count as a goal so you have
four different goal types in Google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if I look at goals overview I can be
able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal 2 engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7000 in goal
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit I so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
can see 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
converter version so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination over the last 30 days my
second best conversion gen grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert art but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance for this particular webinar
we're gonna jump into Google analytics
Direct play and spend all of our time
there because it's about learning
practical applications so goals are
important goals uh let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are align with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against the goal
so without further Ado let's jump right
into Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
on admin here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have an account column you
have your property column and then you
have review column now The View column
is where you're going to go to set up
goals okay so every view in every
property has up to 20 goals okay so by
default in analytics you're going to
have at least one view for your property
so if I have a property I'm gonna have
at least one view but if I happen to set
up multiple views like you see here then
I know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I could see I
have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here by clicking on the recording column
I can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation is at least
have one one goal again when you set up
a goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal okay so in this case we have five
particular goals we're measuring so we
have five active out of 20 total so if I
don't know no longer want to use a goal
I could simply just turn it off if I
want to continue using it just turn it
on okay it's that simple you could turn
on and off goals so here I already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in Google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log login
to Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission
then goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal id5 I'm gonna be able to
see those goals and goal set one and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active and goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three Etc notice I don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that earn
goal set four therefore I don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose custom as
our goal setup we're going to type in a
goal name I'm just going to say thank
you okay this is goal 15. now this is
the important part Google analytics has
four different goal types destination in
duration pages per session or screens
per session to screens per session is
related to mobile because Google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example I'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal URL
so for example destination is my choice
I'm going to click continue now this is
where I'm going to put the URL so if my
URL is just simply thank you.html I can
just go ahead and put thank you.html or
if it's just thank you then I can just
do thank you depends on the website
depends on the URI structure so whatever
that URL is that's what you're going to
put in and when you're done you can
verify it so what Google analytics does
is actually will verify over the last
seven days if anybody's actually gone to
that particular page so if we click
verify we can see zero percent
conversion rate so that tells us that if
this is the correct URL then we've had
zero percent people go to that page this
is just an example however if you didn't
see a conversion then you might want to
make sure you check the URL here that
you put in and if you do see a
conversion rate then you know it's
working so Google analytics actually has
options so we're saying thank you is
equal to so the destination URL is equal
to thank you or thank you.html or thank
you dot ESP or whatever that thank you
page is okay you do have options so if
you have a long URL you could say it
begins with and you could say it begins
with say thank you so this is the logic
we're going to say hey if anybody goes
to a real well that begins with thank
you then count it as a goal or you could
say equals two so if anybody goes to a
URL that equals two thank you then count
it as a goal you have one more option
Here regular expression so Google
analytics understands the language of
regular Expressions so regular
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with Google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to track so we can
always say you know starts with or ends
with so we can you know use characters
like the dollar sign ends with or begins
with so we can always do that so you can
use regular Expressions as well if
you're familiar with regular Expressions
if you're not then you don't have to use
them but there are special characters
where that you can insert in that are
used as regular expression so if you're
not familiar with regular expression
don't choose that option you can choose
the other option of equals to or begins
with now note that that on all three of
these options I didn't put the domain so
if my domain is Amma Dash foundation.org
and then thank you I don't need to put
the domain because analytics are already
knows what domain we're tracking so you
don't have to put in the domain here
when you're entering in in this case the
Google URL so you can omit the domain so
when you put in that URL you know that
you have three options to work with and
then you always always want to verify
that goal URL you always want to verify
it because if you see zero percent
conversion and in this case of the last
seven days then that should tell you
something either your goal is not set up
correctly or you just don't have any
conversions either way you want to
double check that now when it comes to
the destination URL goal you do have an
option here for funnel so if I turn on
funnel then that means means I have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if I have a cart and I want
to be able to check how many people go
in and out of the cart then I have the
option of adding specific Pages as part
of the cart so we could say you know
step one which is basically cart we
could say step two is billing
information that could be slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping and then step
four could be you know confirm and that
could be slash confirmation so whatever
your url structure is for your cart and
it doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnel is available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step require so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all gold types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then final
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I could see the
first step is the store front page so
over this particular period of time I
have 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 I can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page I can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and five
exited the site all together okay so
that gave me a 87 total and from 87 I
saw that 82 went on to the next page for
the next step what analytics does is
they give you a percentage so in the
first step we had 63 move on to the cart
page out of 84 that's 75 percent so from
the cart page to the create your account
page we had 94 move on so we didn't have
anybody enter in the create your account
page we didn't have anybody leave to
create your account page so if 82 82
create your account and then we have 82
move on to the payment page so that's a
hundred percent okay we have one exit so
we have 81 that proceeded to beyond the
payment page which was purchase so 81 of
82 is 98
and we started with 84. so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so they gave us
75 percent funnel conversion rate so 75
percent of the people who entered in the
funnel went on to purchase okay so don't
be confused with the overall e-commerce
conversion rate so 75 is the final
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
18.45 over this particular period of
time why because that takes into account
all sessions that have won to the
website so 18 of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
funnel 75 converted so that's a look at
the funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to measure everything
from step one and Beyond or measure as
traffic goes in and out of the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see where traffic drops off how
effective our funnel is what pay Pages
we need to address in that funnel okay
so that's the whole point of the funnel
and the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back to goals Under The
View I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular Expressions here and then
if we verify this goal we could see over
the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
not sure what type of goal to set up for
your website the very least you should
try and set up either duration or Let It
Go or pages per session related goal so
let's talk about the pages per session
so basically what this goal is going to
allow us to measure is for example if we
set the goal to three pages per session
then we're going to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if I
open up the goal here I can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
Beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verify it over
the last seven days we could see a 4.12
conversion rate and that tells me that
four percent of my traffic over the last
seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so you're probably asking
yourself well what number should I put
in for the actual variable so in this
case we see two well what you want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say year to date you want to make
sure you have statistical significance
so you want to look at a period of time
so if you go to analytics go to audience
okay and then if you go to overview and
if I change my date range to year to
date I could see on average right now I
have 1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and 30. and so the whole point is
you can hone in because this is a goal I
can go in this is goal okay this is a
goal here and so I could see that this
is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10 so I could see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because it's engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you can test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name so has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days of a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category and action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you could say I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
can see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I can see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well contributing to goals
now I do want to point your attention to
another report in Google analytics that
does take into account goals and that's
multi-channel funneling so again under
conversion goals multi-channel funnels
if I go to assisted conversions I can
actually see what channel in this
example is assisting with the
conversions I've set up and so what do
we mean by assistive conversions well
that means that if a channel let's just
say organic search drove traffic to the
website and that traffic didn't convert
when it arrived at the website and left
but it came back a week later via
another Channel let's just say email and
when they came back via email they did
convert during that session well what
analytics does is they give an assist to
organic search because they help Drive
the traffic to the website so it's
similar to the game of basketball if I
have the ball and I pass it to my
colleague and my colleagues the one who
scores because they had the ball last
well they get the credit for the point
I.E the conversion but I get an assist
and so analytics works the same way
they're always going to give credit to
the last click or direct conversion but
they will give credits to the channel in
this case that assisted with the
conversion so that's under assistive
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to day so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together to
contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could say I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement relay related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
today we're going to talk about how to
set up event tracking in Google
analytics so let's get started so many
of you out there have a website similar
to the one I'm looking at now this is a
non-profit that I work with I'm a
foundation and like this website and
probably like your web website you
probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons uh if you have buttons
like this one that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of inter activity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wanting around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under Behavior top
event events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we gotta donate now Bob we
got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less they're timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focus on the donating Now
button then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step one identify what you want
to track now when it comes to tracking
events on a website you want to identify
those events so we did that by choosing
this donate Now button now once we
identify what we want to track we need
to assign two parameters for that event
so with event tracking you have three
parameters but one is actually optional
so you have two mandatory parameters
that you have to assign to everything
you want to track on your website and
that's the category and then the action
so event label or label is the third
parameter but again that's optional okay
so basically when we identify an event
on our website we want to assign it a
category and an action okay so why do we
want to assign it a category in an
action because when we're in analytics
under Behavior under events top events
we could see we have different
categories here and we have different
actions we have different labels so if I
click on any one of these Dimensions I'm
going to be able to see some of the
parameters I've entered in for previous
events I'm tracking okay so the whole
idea is you want to be able to group
different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category head
or donate now I need to give an action
to each category and so in this case I'm
just going to say click because that's
what the action is doing it's it's
somebody's taking the action of clicking
now if it's a video and it's a play
button I can assign an action of play
it's up to you whatever you name these
parameters you just need to be organized
and methodical about what you name it
that's all and so in this case header
donate and then click okay and so that's
our category in action and so that's
clearly step two so step one identify
what you want to track step two assign a
category action and or label but
remember label is optional so if we go
back in analytics here I could see some
categories and if I click on action I
can see some actions that I've named now
step three so we've identified in Step
One what we we want to track we've
assigned a category in action so step
three is going into Google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with Google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
Google search for Google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to use to set up event
tracking now tag managers use for a lot
of different things but the main thing
we're doing here is setting up an event
for our website and so I'm logged in to
the same email address I'm using for
analytics okay so now I'm in tag manager
and I want to set up my event for this
donate Now button so what do I need to
do well for every event I want to set up
I need to set up a tag okay so if I go
to tags I can see I already have some
tags set up and some of these are events
and so when you actually set up a tag I
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it GA Dash event
Dash whatever it is we're trying to set
up and so in this case we want to set up
a new tag for the Donate Now button on
our website so we're in Google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event so if I click
on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page we're tracking an event
and so now remember in step two you
identified what you want to call that
category you identify what you want to
call that action and you have some
optional parameters like label so first
things first header donates the name of
our category and our action is click and
if you want to add in a label and a
value so if you want to sign a value you
can if you want to add in a label you
can okay those are optional so you just
need to focus on category in action and
then the last setting here that's
probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not not going to count a
bounce if I change it to true so from
false to true then that means it is
going to be a non-interaction if
somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks on the button so I don't
want it to be a balance I want it to be
an interaction so my advice is leave it
set to false we're going to choose
Google analytics as our setting here
this is our variable for Google
analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're signing a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set default so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag in Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step two you want to be
able to give that person the appropriate
category action end or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into Google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular at category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case I'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable for my label parameter and why
do I want to do that because in tag
manager I have something at my disposal
called variables and variables allow you
to see specifically things that are
being tracked so in this case I chose
pagepath okay so pagepath is a URL and
why did I choose page path as my
variable for the parameter label because
if somebody does click on the header
donate button and the header donate
button on our website is on every page
so if I go to the children's page I'm
still going to see that header donate
button and so for me I want to be able
to see what page somebody clicked on
that hitter donate button and so this
allows me to actually see in Google
analytics what page somebody clicked on
the header donate Now button and so now
if I go back to GTM Google tag manager I
have a category I have an action and I
have a label which is a variable okay so
note that in Google tag manager you have
a lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action and or
label and or value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for the this particular event and so if
I click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is it's a click on some links
not all links but some links I'm
actually saying Hey Google tag manager
fire this event when the click ID equals
header donate button now it just so
happens that if somebody did click on
this donate Now button they're gonna go
to another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal Network for good.com so
that could have been my Logic for my
trigger in this case I decided to go
with the click ID and so in this case
that button has an ID associated with it
called header donate button so if you
wanted to use click ID for your event
for your button you could simply just go
to the website you can right click on
that button and click inspect element
and so when I actually inspect the
element I can see now the button here
you can see it's highlighted in the
upper Pane and in the lower pane I can
see where it's linking to it's linking
to networkforgood.com but here you can
see if I hone in a little it I could see
ID equals header Dash donate dash button
so that's the click ID notice there's
also a class I could have set the
trigger to equal this class or again I
could have set the trigger to equal the
URL or the page that this button is
pointing to I could have chosen any one
of those but I decided to go with the ID
so this is the ID I chose and that's the
ID I have in my trigger okay so that is
what's going to fire that event so if
somebody clicks on a button that equals
header Dash donate dash button it's
going to fire that event which is going
to equal category header donate action
click and then the label is going to be
page path so now that we've set up our
events we want to test to see if it
actually works so there's two ways to go
about testing an event and the first way
is through Google analytics so if we go
to Google analytics and then we go to
real time okay we can go to events and
here you can see one is already fired so
let's go ahead and go to and test this
and go to the website so if I go here
for example and I click on omagar alumni
okay so if I click on that you can see
I'm under our family and if I click on
that button then go back to analytics
and look at real time I should be able
to see this event fire so if I click on
it I'm going to go to network for good
now if I go back to analytics here in
real time under real time under events
per second I can see that event firing
category equals header donate the action
equals click now if I click on the
category here I can see the label the
label remember was page path and here
you can see this event fired on the our
family page which was the page I was
just on so that's one way to test to see
if your event works and in this case
analytics recognize the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up under Behavior under
events you can go under overview or top
events okay and what am I going to look
for in this case I'm going to look for
header donate okay if I click on head or
donate as my category I'm going to be
able to see my action and if I click on
action I'll be able to see my label in
this case home page and then later on
when the data propagates in analytics
I'll be able to see under label the page
that I clicked on that header donate
button which is slash our family okay
the second way in which you can test to
see if an event fires is if you preview
so if I click on preview in tag manager
okay I'm going to go into preview mode
okay and preview mode allows you to see
in analytics and tag manager and on the
website what tags are firing so here I
could see I'm in preview mode now so I'm
going to go to the website and I'm going
to refresh and in my browser same
browser I'm using for tag manager I can
see the tags that are being fired on
this page already okay because I'm in
preview mode so here I could see
remarketing I could see page views I
could see Google optimize I could see
some tags that are already firing on
this page now if I click on this button
here by holding down my shift command
and then click on that button I'll be
able to see that the tag fired in
preview mode there's my event header
donate and I can see it fired so now I
can see it fired in the preview mode so
in addition to Google analytics in
preview mode I could see that that tag
is fired and I know that it's working so
there you have it you have two ways to
test to see if the event fires again you
have real time in analytics okay so in
real time if you just go up to real time
all you need to do is go down to events
go to your website click on the button
if you see it firing in real time then
you know it works the second version or
second way to test your event is through
the preview mode okay if you see it
firing in preview mode then you know
it's also working okay so let's rehash
our steps first step is we want to be
able to identify what we want to track
okay so it could be this newsletter sign
up it could be click on a Facebook it
could be anything we want to be able to
track an image a click on a CTA button
whatever we want to track identify it
second step identify the category action
and label because that's what's going to
show up in Google analytics remember
label is optional variable or excuse me
value is optional third step go into tag
manager actually set up your tag and
your trigger so if you set up a tag and
it's an event name it GA Dash events
that way you can see in your list of
tags and tag manager what event tracking
you have already set up so when you set
up your tag you set up your trigger your
trigger is based on logic that can be a
URL it can be a click ID it can be a
class ID whatever you want to use to
fire that event and then once you do
that you want to test it you could test
it in GTM or you could test it in Google
analytics if it doesn't fire you want to
tweak your trigger if it does fire then
great and then one thing I would
recommend is if you're setting up
various events for your website that's
the best practice what I would recommend
is set up a spreadsheet and in that
spreadsheet you know you want to put a
note what's firing what are you doing to
fire it could be in this case someone
somebody clicks on the Donate Now button
in the header you want to put the tag
name in here the type okay then you want
to record your category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if I go in analytics
and I go to admin and I go to go goals
if you set up a new goal okay all you
need to do is choose custom click
continue you're going to choose event as
your goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if I click now continue what is my
category it's equal to head or donate my
action is click and so I can verify to
see if this is working and here I can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and I
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal in
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what I would
recommend if the event is equal to a kpi
or business goal or it's of importance
it's something you really want to
measure okay it's just a click say on a
Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you recorded it
in your spreadsheet it's firing you want
to be able to then go back into Behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go to here to date so
here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value
divided by the total number of unique
page views or sessions and so because I
don't have value I'm not going to have
average value but here you can see
because value is optional here I can at
least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique in the total events
and if I click on label if I have a
label assigned then I'll be able to see
what page triggered that event so if we
go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form Etc so
what you you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here I could see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
analytics under Behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze introducing simple lens
postgraduate program in digital
marketing that will transform you into
Master of the digital realm this
comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
enroll in a postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description option
box below let's start out with why GTM
so let's just say you're Sam and you
have your own e-commerce website and you
want to understand how people are
interacting with your website well Sam
today's world of websites contain a lot
of interactivity everything from videos
to PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
all GTM is is really allows you to
really place a piece of java code which
is just script and the script that's
added to a web page to collect
information so that's really what a tag
is it's just some script that gets put
on a web page in order for you to
collect information like page views
clicks Etc and they send it to
third-party tools okay so that's what
GTM does it basically allows you to take
all these tags that collect information
and you can use them in GTM so if you
want to for example collect how many
people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into GTM let's just say you know
you're communicating with your developer
and there's a new user request on your
web page and you want to update the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small update to your website
is probably gonna not
um hesitate and is going to go ahead and
turn around and do it normally and so
normally what happens is the developer
is going to go to the website and update
the tag well what if you have a few
things that you want to track all those
things I mentioned before from downloads
to clicks to you know somebody checking
out to watching a video well your Web
Master your web developer is going to go
well hold on a second now all these
requests are going to take time I need
to put them into the work queue so to
speak well what happens is is when they
go into work queue usually it's going to
take some time and in some cases you as
a marketer need to launch a campaign and
you want to get that tracking uh added
to the website in time for the campaign
launch so you want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign and you're
sending people to a landing page that
has a form submission and you want to be
able to track how many people click on
the submit button of that form
submission well if you need to turn that
around your developer's like well I need
to put that in a work queue the time it
isn't going to always work out between
you and your developer is my point and
so that's where GTM comes in because
there is a solution to update your tags
faster and that's Google tag manager so
when we say GTM that's what GTM stands
for Google tag manager it's a place for
you to add tags quickly and easily so
tags remember are just Snippets of code
that allow you to track things on your
website interactively interactive
actively and basically when you have GTM
you can bypass the webmaster and do it
quickly and easily so that's what GTM is
all about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all this jargon
is just new to you today okay well well
don't fret sit back we're gonna take it
slow this is an introduction into Google
tag manager again let's start out with
what is tag manager so we've already
introduced it to some degree because we
already introduced it as a tool where
you can put all your tags into a toolbox
toy box or container so to speak right
and we already already mentioned that
hey you can bypass your webmaster so
you're probably thinking well if I'm if
you're not familiar with tag manager how
can I bypass my webmaster well first of
all it's a free tool and it's a Google
tool hence the name Google tag manager
and it helps you really that's the main
point it's deploy and track tags on your
website bypassing your webmaster so
that's tag manager and so examples of
tags that can be deployed via Google tag
manager are numerous these are just some
examples like Google analytics
Facebook's pixel tracking or Google ads
There's No Limit into the number of
texts you can track in tag manager there
is no limit you can add any number of
tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits well again I we
just listed two you can put any tag into
tag manager and track that onto your
website and we know you can bypass your
web developer or webmaster and what it
also does is it also allows you to test
and deploy your JavaScript codes quicker
so remember these JavaScript codes or
Snippets of codes are just there to
track certain things on your website
whether that be a page view or somebody
clicking on a play button or tracking
somebody who converts or even just goes
to your website so the biggest benefit
is you can take that snippet of code
let's just say Facebook let's just say
you're growing Facebook marketing and
you want to put that Facebook pixel on
your website so that you could track
people who come from Facebook and
convert well you don't need to put that
Facebook pixel on your website you can
go right to tag manager and you can put
that snippet of code right in tag
manager really quickly and the other
benefit here is all tags are managed in
one place and that's that to me is
really a good benefit because when you
start adding tags on your website and
you have some tags and tag manager it
just gets very confusing so ideally all
the tracking codes you have on your
website needs to be in tag manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing Bing or you're doing Facebook or
you're doing Twitter or you're doing
LinkedIn and you're doing Google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're going
to have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting all that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website you want to
put them all in tag manager so they can
be organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
GTM for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version It's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've had
coached your site there's no guarantee
it's going to work and so you can always
control what version you're dealing with
in tag manager and we'll talk a little
bit more about that so the biggest
benefit here to me with tag manager is
you have event tracking and so we talked
about some of the things you could track
on your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or pausing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different different
things these different interactivities
and buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and I'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already I'll mention
it again it is free tag manager is free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
Advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking codes
you have in GTM or you can have somebody
who is very familiar with tag manager it
can go in and add the tracking code to
tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets added so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag Manager work because you're
like Rob okay again a lot of jargon you
know you you got tags and JavaScript and
and versioning and Publishing and all
this other stuff well I know I'm
throwing a lot at you at once but just
bear with me here okay so let's start
talking about how it actually works so
you have a website okay whatever that
domain is you have a website and there's
chances are on your website you have
some form of interactivity whether that
be a video whether that be a Blog
whether it be a form submission you have
a website with some interactivity and
let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe Google or Facebook
and you want to drive traffic to your
website fair enough you're joining the
millions of other websites that are out
there that have interactivity that also
Drive traffic to the website so incomes
Google tag manager and so tag manager is
important because again we know we want
to track people coming from that
Facebook campaign or that Google
campaign and interacting with our site
so if you are running Facebook and you
are running Google analytics well guess
what you want to put that tracking code
in tag manager so Google analytics being
a Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
Facebook campaign to your website so
you're gonna get that tracking code from
Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say I Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I could see
a list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
analytics so if you're going to use Tag
manager you might as well put the Google
analytics code in here so here I can see
I have Google analytics as a tag in tag
manager now for Facebook if I'm running
a Facebook campaign well I can take that
pixel tracking and put it in GTM as well
and here I could see Facebook pixel that
is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it in a Google tag manager so you
can see I can add Facebook and Google
analytics and again I can't stressing
enough any tracking code from any
platform I can add to Google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so I just showed you an example of how
you could take Facebook and Google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do I do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember I mentioned Toy Box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're they're
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
Facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box or container and
so the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if I take
my Facebook tracking code and put it
into to a container I need to set up a
tag and a trigger okay so let's take a
look at what that is so first if I go
back to tag manager I'm going to have an
account and if I have an account I'm
going to have a container so here I'm
just going to click on an account with a
container and a container is nothing
more than what website you're adding the
tracking code to okay that's all the
container is we're just letting tag
manager know this is the website we're
adding all this code to so you have tags
triggers and variables that's the
structure of tag manager so tags are
just what it says tags what are we
trying to quote unquote tag well if it's
Google analytics that's easy here I
could see I have Google analytics added
so if I click on Google analytics here's
my tag and if I take a little bit of a
deeper dive there since Google analytics
is a Google product it integrates
already with tag manager is pretty easy
I can just choose Google analytics then
I'm going to check page view and that's
my tag now every tag needs a trigger
okay so I need to tell tag manager how
or when to fire the Google analytics
tracking code so in this case I'm going
to tell tag manager to fire on all pages
so if I get somebody a visitor to my
website analytics is firing on all pages
so whatever page that visitor lands on
Google analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is I have a
tag and I need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at an another example here if I go back
here you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell GTM when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from say Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and Trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
URL or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples I just
gave you are there to get your tag and
Trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if I
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger to work
with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
Trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that JavaScript code okay in the
case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on AdWords remarketing again
it's a Google product so I don't really
need to even deal with code I'm just
going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of JavaScript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
button friends you name it it even
clicks on external links for example
let's just say you have a click uh or a
Facebook uh icon on your site and when
somebody clicks on it they go to
Facebook you want to maybe track that
you're going to create a tag okay the
trigger is there because you need to
tell GTM when to fire that tag so it's a
certain condition whether it's you know
fire the tag if the URL equals
facebook.com or some other condition so
the tag cannot be created until the
creation of the corresponding trigger so
tags and triggers go together you can't
just create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that your
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I can
see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's gonna fire on specific Pages how
do I know that well if I look at the
trigger he here I could say the trigger
is a page view but I'm telling it to
fire on this particular hostname so the
tag and Trigger go hand in hand
foreign
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tagmanager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp Etc an accelerated mobile
page so most people by default are
probably going to set up tag manager for
their website and so when you do that
when you actually select website what's
going to happen is you're going to get
some Google tag manager code in return
and so the whole idea here is you're
going to do a swap what you're doing is
basically you're saying Okay Google I'm
going to take this Google tag manager
code and I'm going to put it on my
website I'm gonna put it on every page
in my website so notice tag manager has
two scripts one goes in the head as high
as possible the other goes into the body
tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be Facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in GTM
okay it's gonna go into the Container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing I wanted to mention on the account
is it's a Google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say Google
analytics or some other Google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
Google analytics right to Google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing Google tag manager then
what I would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of GTM so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in Google tag manager
well when you create an account account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific ID
so if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code okay so again
when I'm logged in to tag manager I'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation I'm going to see my
unique GTM ID if I click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you you need to do is basically
you're looking at all your tags if you
click on tag in the left side navigation
you'll see all your tags and there's a
new button there so you just click new
and so basically what you're going to do
is you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to set up a select
active variable and so what you're going
to do is you're going to select new
variable and what you're going to do is
you're actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID and analytics well if I'm in
analytics I'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings I'm going
to see my tracking ID and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got a copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to go
to tag manager I'm going to paste it and
then that's going to create a variable
for you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so I've already created
it and basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
I have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and it's going to
be all pages so ideally what you want to
do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or are you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics
running I have also Google optimized
running and I have Google ads remark
marketing tag running and tag manager so
that's what tag assistant does it allows
you to see if one tag manager is on the
site and if it is great what other tags
are firing on this particular site so
tag assistance telling me I have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and Trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
I click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now I'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take take a look at
what that looks like so if I go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's going to happen is tag manager is
going to load in preview mode just as
you see here okay so that's going to
take a second couple seconds to load up
and now what can I see in preview mode I
could see that I have GTM firing but I
also have some other text fine on this
page remarketing I have Google analytics
I have Google optimize I have some other
tags firing as well and so the preview
mode shows me what tags are firing on
any given page and I can also see what
tags did not fire okay so here I have a
number of tags already in GTM but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say I clicked on the Donate
Now button I'm still in preview mode so
I'm going to be able to see what tags
fired now I could see I have a couple of
tags that I've fired on this particular
page and then I can see what tags did
not fire on this page Edge okay so
that's the preview mode you can use the
preview mode before you even submit a
tag and Trigger to see if it fires and
that's the great benefit of tag manager
so if you're not sure if something's
going to fire or not then you can always
go into preview mode
um and if you are sure it's gonna fire
then you can go ahead and submit it so
you can leave preview mode and just go
ahead and submit that particular tag and
Trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is going to fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just Snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be Facebook
or vet tracking or any other Google
product like optimize or page view then
I have my triggers my triggers are there
to tell GTM when to fire that tag and
the variables are there to help those
tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables Google tag manager has
built in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again I can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from Google to non-google to
event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're gonna need tag manager and
when you have tag manager you're going
to be a able to track all of these
button clicks and interactivity on your
website with that tag manager it's going
to be hard to do that so that's an
introduction to tag manager in the age
of digital marketing it is very easy to
get lost in the sea of information if
you are a beginner you will probably
spend a lot of time reading and
researching even if you are an expert
you will still need to keep up to date
and know what's going on in the
marketing world but how do you find the
time to do that how do you find the time
to stay on top of Trends and Innovations
we have compiled a list of 20 plus
digital marketing tools to help you make
your life easier
some of these tools might sound familiar
to you and some might sound new and
interesting we believe all of them have
some value in your life and can assist
you in staying on top of trends hey
everyone I am tusha badiwal welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel in this
video we will understand 20 plus digital
marketing tools to grow your business in
2022 but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the plan for today's
session first we will look at the
research part next we will explore tools
to build or host the website content is
king So next we will have a look at some
of the best content creation tools to
grow your business
moving forward we will discuss designing
and Graphics tools once designing is
done it's time to promote and hence we
will look at the best promotional tools
after that we will discuss some great
email marketing tools user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
will end the session by understanding
the communication tools that will help
your business operate smoothly
research research is one of the most
essential parts of getting your business
to the next level its what turns an idea
into a real business however it is hard
to do research without the right tools
luckily there are many tools out there
that do the job perfectly here are just
few that you need to know about
Uber suggest Uber suggest is a free tool
that produces fresh keyword ideas it is
among the best free tools available on
the market however it has a Premium plan
for advanced features but it is best if
you are starting out and it has some
good features like you will get the
search volume for free keyword ideas and
content ideas
Keyword Planner it is one of the best
free tools and the best part is that
it's a Google product so that the data
can be trusted you can use Google
Keyword Planner to do keyword research
Google Keyword Planner will show you the
monthly search volume of keywords and
phrases the average cost per click in
your selected country and how difficult
it is to rank for the keywords some of
the best features are you will get the
custom time based keyword data and get
to know the competition on that keyword
hrefs hrefs is one of the most advanced
tool available for keyword research it
is also used for competitor analysis
rank tracking and site auditing hrf's
main features are geared towards
marketer but you can also use it to find
keywords for Google YouTube and Amazon
the tool is paid but suitable for
businesses looking for in-depth
information it has some features like
rank tracker that will help you know
your existing website ranking and the
second one is alert you will get
important information or stats by mail
after doing the research part you need a
website for your business let's have a
look at how to do that the first step in
creating a website is to find a place to
host it there are many options out there
and depending on what your site will be
used for you may need different tools
web hosting tools have evolved to meet
the online communities need better it
can be challenging to select the right
one through many options here are the
few of the best tools available on the
market
WordPress it will help you create your
website by just drag and dropping no
coding is required also it has a lot of
plugins that can be used according to
your website needs blogger you can
create a beautiful blog using blogger
for free and it is also has free themes
which you can use
still it is always recommended that you
use tools like WordPress to build your
website because businesses need a
website with lot of functionalities and
WordPress makes this process easier
the website requires hosting as the next
tool we have is hostinjure you need to
purchase a domain and hosting to host a
website there are other companies also
available that you can use to host your
site such as GoDaddy HostGator Etc
hosting job provides automatic backups
that will ensure that your website data
is secured it allows you to create
unlimited subdomain which is also
necessary for a business website
for free hosting and free domains you
can use Infinity free but for a business
website it is always recommended to go
with the paid hosting because this will
give your customer a good experience
when they visit your website but for
beginner just wanting to learn how
website hosting works you can use
Infinity free
every Business website and its social
media platform need content and content
is the oxygen of the internet there is
no surviving without it but meeting the
demand of a Content hungry World often
means that you are forced to pull your
hair out only to throw more into the
fire
from research to Creation to
distribution content is now 24x7 job
requiring many internal resources or
costly outsourced help
if you are looking to cut down the cost
and streamline your efforts here are
some content creation tools to take your
business to the next level
headline it is an AI tool that will
create a landing page automatically no
writing designing and coding is required
you need to give information about the
product and it is also has built-in
templates to use it became famous
because of this feature but now it is
upgraded and you will see a lot of other
features that will help you create
excellent content it is a paid tool but
you can try its free version
pepper type it is a One-Stop AI solution
tool for all content needs and the best
part is you will get 10 000 word limit
to try out this fantastic tool the
specialty of this tool is that it allows
you to create content for specific
social media platforms and long form
content
grammarly grammarly is a free online
tool that find mistakes in your writing
and suggest improvements as you write
grammarly will underline any mistakes
you have made and offer suggestions on
how to fix them greetings everyone this
is Rob Sanders from Simply learn happy
New Year and today we're gonna talk
about digital marketing skills
so digital marketing allows business
owners regardless of the business
non-profit for-profit large or small
National local International to really
expand their business allows them to
personalize their content they could
save money and most importantly they can
measure the results and so that's what
we're going to focus on today when we
talk about digital marketing skills
focusing on measuring those results so
suppose anybody wants to work in
marketing or grow a company or help grow
an individuals company or ensure to keep
up with the appropriate skills this is
what we're going to cover today so we're
going to cover a few channels and so
let's get right to it today we're going
to start off with search engine
optimization or SEO
also known as organic search so SEO is
an interesting channel it's probably the
premier channel for most companies in
fact HubSpot confirms that 57 of B2B
marketers stated that SEO generates more
leads than any other marketing
initiative
so it's really important for not only
just generating traffic but it's also
important for generating leads and and
generating more business
including e-commerce and so what does
SEO entail and what skills should you
acquire in order to manage SEO as a
marketing channel
well if you think about it SEO is really
divvied up into two pies one pie is
called on page the other pie is called
off Pitch and so on page consists of
things you can do to the website to help
you
be found in organic search
so what are those things well it could
be anything from you know page load
speed to four or four errors to sitemaps
and so the point here is if you're going
to manage SEO and you know that you got
to make sure your website's in Tip-Top
shape or your clients websites and good
enough shape for Google to recognize it
as a legitimate site you have to have
some technical skills now I'm not saying
you have to be developer but at the same
time you have to know what a 4-4 error
is you know have to know where and how
to generate a site map and upload that
sitemap you need to know how to edit a
robot's text file so those are you know
what I call soft technical skills but
they're all valid for SEO so you have to
have some technical background
staying in the on page pie
okay you need to make sure you have not
only skills to write content but skills
to optimize content so you need to be
aware of all the different elements on a
page in order to optimize that page
so again that entails you know some
copywriting skills but more importantly
and probably more challenging is to take
those copywriting skills and enhance
them for SEO okay so making sure that
you're able to understand what it is
that you need to do to get a page
optimized so it can rank higher in the
search engine results so those are on
page skills
and then you got the other piece of the
pie which is off page so understanding
you know what it takes to make sure your
site is relevant so it's understanding
different metrics off page metrics like
page Authority domain Authority external
links internal links and so generally
most SEO managers have a third-party SEO
platform that they work with like
semrush or Moz so it's understanding how
to work with those platforms to measure
off-page results so
we always say that SEO as a digital
marketing channel is an 800 pound
gorilla well it is because you have on
page and off page to worry about so the
two of those together you know is is
quite a task in order to rank
and so it brings SEO and all digital
marketing channels is understanding the
metrics and understanding what you're
seeing in order to measure results and
improve upon those results okay so
that's really the theme for all these
digital marketing channels we're going
to talk about today it's really about
okay what metrics and how do I measure
the results and so when we look at SEO
in terms of measuring results
on the on page side okay you're going to
have to do some keyword analysis you're
going to have to understand okay what
volume is you're going to understand how
to get the competition numbers okay and
you're going to have to understand what
keywords to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics then
you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are performing
okay and then again the off page you got
different metrics like domain Authority
or page Authority
you have external links internal links
you have no follow and follows and and
you know a lot of these little metrics
related to off Pages yes you're going to
have to understand what those metrics
made and if you can understand what
those metrics mean and then more
importantly act on those metrics then
that's what's going to help you improve
your results in terms of SEO
so again that's going to be the common
theme here so I'm just going to
highlight again those metrics that
you're going to need to understand in
order to better manage SEO as a channel
get on the on page side you need to
understand the technicalities involved
but for example page load what's a good
page load time it's about page load tone
from a keyword perspective what's good
volume what's bad volume what's good
competition what's bad competition so if
you can understand the intricacies of
the measurements related to SEO then
that'll help you improve upon this big
Channel called organic search so SEO is
the practice of getting relevant traffic
to the website okay from organic search
results so it really is essential to
stay up to date
and have a complete knowledge of the
latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search engine ranking
so that's SEO let's transition to search
engine marketing also known as paid
search sponsored search Google ads Bing
ads pay-per-click cost per click a lot
of acronyms a lot of ways to describe it
at the end of the day search engine
marketing means that hey you as an
Advertiser have the ability and have the
opportunity to rank at the very top of
the Google search results
now it's different than SEO because
you're actually paying for the placement
and so to be found at the top of the
search engine results
as a paid placement or sponsored ad
means that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're going to pay Google X amount okay
so unlike SEO sem is very fast moving
and so when we talk about fast moving we
mean that you're collecting a lot of
data very quickly so sticking with the
theme of what skills should I have for
search engine marketing well if you're
going to collect data then that means
you need to measure the results of that
data and so sticking with our theme of
measuring results you need to understand
first and foremost what all the
different metrics mean related to
Central engine marketing okay so I'm
just gonna rattle off if you will a few
of the metrics but the commonality here
is yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but you have to act on those
metrics so one of the the main metrics
involved with search engine marketing is
Impressions so impression is just
basically how many people have seen your
ad okay so if your ad shows up on the
search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
have seen your ad what's a lot of
impressions well it's objective okay so
it could be a thousand Impressions or
ten thousand Impressions at the end of
the day that's how many people have seen
your ad
now more importantly
you have another metric called clicks
clicks means how many people actually
saw your ad and then clicked on your ad
okay so if you have 100 people that have
seen your ad and one person who clicked
on your ad then you have a click through
rate of one percent
now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have a high click-through rate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score it's quality score
is another metric you need to be aware
of okay so quality score is simply a
number between 1 and 10 that's assigned
to each keyword okay so what impacts
quality score click-through rate is one
of the factors that impact quality score
so if you have
200 or 300 or 500 or a thousand
Impressions and very little clicks that
means you click the rate is going to be
low and if your click your rate it's
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low
and in order to pay less to Google you
need to make sure that your quality
score is good so you need to understand
the factors involve a quality score you
need to understand Impressions clicks
click-through rate because if you don't
have a good click-through rate
then how do you improve that so it's
about measuring the results and acting
upon the results those are the skills
involved with search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you
got the conversion side of the house so
you need to be able to understand how to
get conversions
and how to maintain a high conversion
rate so for example if you have a
hundred clicks
and only one conversion
that is a one percent conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if that number is
high like say twenty dollars and you're
only selling a product that's say ten
dollars
well then you got a problem and so
there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involves search engine
marketing if you're getting the data if
it's a low click the rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion
or very low Impressions you need to be
able to understand how to react to what
you're seeing and what your data you're
collecting that to me is the primary
skill bottom line with search engine
marketing and there are other skill sets
involved don't get me wrong I mean it's
nice to be able to write copy because
with search engine marketing
typically the ads have very few
characters involved so you need to be
able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing Copy being able to
understand your target audience
um those are all things involved with
managing search engine marketing but
really the key component here is again
measuring the results okay let's switch
over to a traditional marketing channel
email marketing you know one of my
favorites you know listen we're all
bombarded with emails
uh and you know what it it becomes
cumbersome at times I mean it's easy to
just just regard an email and so to me
the key here if you're going to do email
marketing
you need to have a certain set of skill
sets and so what that skill set is is
really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients
you need to hope that that email is
relevant to that audience okay so you
need to be able to really identify who
it is we're sending this email to
and a recent study done by statista
stated that 49 of consumers really like
to receive promotional emails from their
favorite Brands so if you have a very
strong brand then email marketing is
probably a good channel for you if you
don't have a strong brand or nobody
really knows about your brand or your
product or your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper Hill to climb if you will
but really email marketing is it
involves emails that promote the brands
products and services and if you could
Target the Right audience or making sure
you have the Right audience then you got
a good chance of having successful email
marketing campaigns
but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the big skill set here again is
copywriting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copyrighted saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email
they're going to be able to react to it
so you know writing copy with strong
call to action a really relevant copy
that really talks to the audience I mean
those are all keys for email marketing
in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing and that's a
b testing and so a b testing has simply
taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs
well you could certainly do a b testing
with email marketing that means taking a
subject line
that has traditionally worked for you or
is relevant for that audience and then
creating
a variant or different subject line so
if I'm going to send an email to 100
people I'm going to send 50.
people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variance
subject line and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people react to
okay so if I see the open rates higher
for the variant
versus the traditional or
the original subject line then I know
that this subject line works and
therefore I'm going to apply this
subject line moving forward and then
what am I going to do I'm going to take
it and test it against another variant
so you should always do a b testing on
subject lines so the concept of a b
testing should not be lost on any
digital marketer okay whether that be
SEO search engine marketing or email
marketing so you should have an
understanding of a b testing and of
course going back to measuring results
with email you have a different set of
metrics we already mentioned open rates
so if you send out
100 emails how many people open the
email okay you want that open rate to be
as high as possible and then when they
open the email the people click on that
CTA or any of those links in the email
okay so you want a high click-through
rate and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
going to go to a landing page
you want that person to engage with that
landing page so it's the engagement rate
of the landing page from the email okay
so it's really important that you have
an understanding of all the different
metrics involved with email marketing
and again
how to react to that data so if you're
getting a low open rate could it be the
subject line isn't that good possibly
that's why you have to do testing if
you're getting a low click they're right
on the emails
that could be because the copy may not
be that great or the design or the call
to action or it's not compelling enough
for the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement on the landing page
if you have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate
you got to look at that and figure out
how to improve that okay so you can
apply a B test in the landing pitch so
there are always ways to react to the
data regardless of what campaign or
regardless of what digital marketing
channel you're working in
so that's the commonality here one point
on email marketing is if you're going to
measure the results of the campaign
whether you're using you know vertical
response or MailChimp or you know some
other email marketing platform you want
to make sure you have what we call a UTM
tracking and if you're using Google
analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign in Google
analytics so that's another skill set
you should have being able to apply you
know tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email
okay because if you don't it's going to
be hard to measure the results in Google
Analytics so let's focus on one more
marketing channel here and that's social
media so we all know social media isn't
going anywhere it's becoming more and
more popular
in fact you know offshoot of social
media is really influencer marketing uh
you know if somebody an influencer has
millions of likes on say tick tock or
Instagram you might want to engage with
that influencer and help you promote
your brand or your product
isn't that really what social media is
it's a platform whether that be you know
Facebook or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you promote your brand
your product your services and it's a
chance for you to get to message your
user base your community prospective
clients people who don't even know about
your brand it's a chance to build
awareness so social media holds a lot of
different uh strategies if you will in
fact nearly almost 4 billion of the
world's population uses social media let
me say there's seven something billion
people in the world well that's a large
percentage the majority of the
percentage of the world uses a social
media platform okay in fact
just like SEO where you need an SEO
platform there are plenty of social
media platforms there's later there's
Sprouts social there's HootSuite there's
buffer in fact buffer confirms that 73
percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business and that's promising because
social media in my opinion
having been in this industry a while it
can be a very fickle Channel I mean if
you're trying to promote a product or
service on Facebook
and it's very very gonna be very hard to
pull that person away who's engaged with
their Facebook feed
not only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and convert
okay based on what you have on your
website so it's challenging enough just
to get them away from the social media
platform let alone convert it so that's
why when I say very fickle but you know
someone encouraging if Buffer's telling
us that marketers believe that social
media marketing can be effective and it
can be effective you just have to have
the right strategy so to me one of the
skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying to achieve
when we set up a social media platform
or enact a social media campaign
okay and so that's really the first
thing it's really understanding what
platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because the last thing
you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content
because just like any other marketing
channel you're going to have metrics and
social media is not shy on the metric
front Okay so you have reach
you have Impressions you have engagement
rate in fact every social media channel
has its own set of specific metrics
whether that be likes followers shares
uh uh reviews Stars if you will so it
really depends on the social media
platform that you're using
but at the end of the day you need to be
able to measure the results if you're
posting let's just say on Facebook
and your whole
job or strategy is to entice engagement
meaning get people to share that
particular post or act on that post then
you need to be able to measure the
engagement how many people saw the post
how many people engaged with the post
okay and so just like any other
marketing channel you're collecting data
and you need to react to that data but
more importantly it's about being able
to you know put a strategy together
first
and then I would you know a skill set I
would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just named buffer or HootSuite or
Sprout social they're all good in their
own right but they're all going to have
different features so to me
understanding what social media platform
works best for you you want to choose a
social media platform that you know
allows you to control what posts you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on
at the same time you want a social media
platform that's going to help you
understand the engagement that you're
getting from that platform
and you'll probably want a social media
platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will on what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform
okay so you want to listen until if you
will uh as part of that social media
platform so it's understanding what
platform you want to use when it comes
to social media marketing it's
understanding what strategy that that
platform is going to help you when they
enact okay and then it's also that
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the data so you can
react to the data
so those are all to me the skill sets
you need as a social media manager and
then
an offshoot of social media is paid
social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
your ad on LinkedIn and somebody clicks
on it you're gonna pay
for that click you're going to pay
LinkedIn or you're going to pay Twitter
you're going to play Facebook so it's
understanding you know the skill sets
involved with paid social is
understanding what assets you can have
when advertising on these platforms you
know can you use video on LinkedIn or
Facebook
um you know can you use what type of
images and you know how big do those
images need to be and can you have
wording on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your ads
so having a full understanding of the
types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise again a whole nother set of
metrics you know how many people saw
you're at how many people clicked on
your ad how many people engage with the
landing page how many people converted
what was the cost per conversion so all
of those are metrics that we covered in
search engine marketing they apply with
paid social
so you have the opportunity on paid
social you have the opportunity on
social media
to really get your message out there
it's really understanding what kind of
data you're collecting what are the
results of the ad or the post and how do
you react to that and that's really the
common theme with digital marketing
skills if you're not a big fan of
numbers you're not a big fan of excel if
you will or spreadsheets if looking at a
mountain of data scares you
well then you might want to think
otherwise when going into digital
marketing but if you want to embrace the
data
than digital marketing is really a great
career because if you can get the data
and you know how to react to the data
then you can be successful in any
campaign you run introducing simple lens
postgraduate program in digital
marketing that will transform you into
Master of the digital realm this
comprehensive program crafted by
industry specialist equips you with
extensive knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced digital realm
enroll in a postgraduate program in
digital marketing become a game changer
in online marketing and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below we're going to cover digital
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's going to work so we
broke out a few questions and answers uh
in different categories a lot of you are
going to be interviewing for some jobs
out there and some of the jobs maybe an
SEO manager or search engine Marketing
Manager or email marketing manager or
content marketing manager or social
media manager so we broke up those
questions into those areas and so that's
what we're going to do we're going to
start with SEO we're going to go through
some questions and I'm going to explain
the answers to those questions so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible so let's get
started we're going to start with SEO
search engine optimization we're going
to go through a series of questions and
I'm going to answer those questions for
you okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you take in or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site B we're
going to basically tell Google Bing and
some of these other search engines hey
go ahead and follow that link now I know
file is just the opposite so no follow
link doesn't allow the search engine
crawlers to follow it so if we have a
link on our site site a pointing to site
B we could put a nofollow tag in there
and what that's going to do it's going
to signal to the Crawlers hey don't
follow this link so in the end if the
Crawlers don't follow the link then
there's not going to be any link juice
passed and so Google is not going to
give you credit or give that site credit
for having a link pointing to it or
pointing to another site or from another
site and so it's all about linking so we
can control if there's links on our site
whether we want the Crawlers to
recognize those or not simply with no
follow tags so just a reminder our link
juice is the reputation or Equity passed
from one website to another so if you
have a link on another website and that
website is of high quality meaning their
page Authority their domain Authority is
high they have a lot of content you know
they're not spammy they're really rich
and they're relevant then you may want
to make sure that the link pointing from
that site to your site is a no follow so
that way that Google can recognize the
link from that side to your site and
basically that reputation is going to be
passed on to you okay so that's a do
follow versus a no follow and why would
we do a nofollow well it just pens it
really depends a lot of social media
platforms like Facebook have no follows
if you have a lot of content you may not
want to be pushing out a lot of do
follows it could actually look bad from
an external linking standpoint and so a
lot of sites are really particular about
who they want to pass link choose onto
and give credit for the link so it's a
business decision and at the end of the
day there's really no hard fast rule
here except from an SEO perspective if I
have a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engines to follow and
what links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the href
notice the nofollow has the the tag
appended to it the href tag with a
nofollow so if the search engine's
crawling your site and they see that no
file there they're not going to follow
that link and vice versa if there's a
link on another site pointing to yours
and there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 301 redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the keyword here permanently so
permanent only moved we're going to
explain that in a minute so it's just
moved from one page to another and so if
we don't have a page anymore we have a
new page let's just say you built a new
website with new URLs you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so for 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
Google to not keep that page in its
search engine rankings because it's
temporary so why would Google want to
keep a temporary page or even a page
that is pointing to another page on a
temporary basis so they may remove both
pages from its index okay but if we have
something permanent in place Google may
say okay this page is permanently
linking to another page redirecting to
another page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain Authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from high quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get a more of a Lion's Share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an on-page
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain Authority Google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
best practices of having engaging and
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing a video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume in low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty IE low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of a title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize the description and but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
gonna grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with Twitter and
Facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes without saying you
did all the work created a really great
video it's engaging it's informative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with you two per
se so the benefit here is if you post it
on Facebook or LinkedIn or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to YouTube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so promote your videos to help
you with the ranking of the video on
YouTube so that does play into it so go
ahead and promote it so other people can
watch it like it comment Etc and that's
going to engage other people to want to
do the same so what is mobile first
indexing this is a really important and
timely question mobile first indexing
means Google's just using mobile
friendly content for indexing and
ranking websites so in other words
Google for example has two Bots they
have the traditional desktop bot and
they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody it has as a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone Bob and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device Google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asks this question you can even take it
a step further and say look I'm going to
measure how friendly my wall my web
website is for mobile devices and Google
search console because Google search
console has a report that will show you
what pages on your website are not
mobile friendly and it's not a guarantee
but I could say if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
Bob and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mobile usability
report okay number six list down the
most important local SEO ranking factors
okay so organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say Google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or you're looking for a coffee
shop so what you want to do is you want
to create a web page for every product
and service okay you also want to opt
for your business listings on Google my
business and and there are plenty of
other local business directories out
there like Yelp for example or Bing even
has one so go ahead and also make sure
you have a business listing as well but
since Google in the United States has a
huge market share you want to start with
Google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so you want to
make sure that that's current and
consistent so if you have a number on
your website make sure it's the same
number on Google my business okay you
can embed a Google map on your website
it could certainly optimize The Meta
tags and content not only on your web
pages but within your Google my business
directory so you can add your business
to other local directories like I
mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews The Hat you
have the better off you are okay so I
always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
Google is obviously the keyword the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can't control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
Google my business Okay so so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading your the the business out on
other directors that's really all these
are really key factors for local SEO
okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this and
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember three
or ones are permanent we can also use
what they call canonical tag and a
canonical tag basically alerts the
search engines as to which page is the
original okay so if we have an original
page we want to point to that page with
our canonical tag and there third option
is opt for preferred domain and Google
search console okay so if you have
multiple no names make sure you set up a
primary one in search console so those
are ways to work around it of this three
I would always go with the canonical
tags because that's just a tag that's
going to sit on the page it's going to
alert Google as to what the original is
just in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what I mean
by simple as possible really I mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images made in other words don't have
such a large image size if you don't
need something very large don't have it
okay you want to improve server response
time and what do we mean by that well
your site's sitting on a server
somewhere you can own that server or you
can be renting it out from say Amazon
web services or let's just say GoDaddy
as your register they also have web
hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server is slow
that's going to slow down everything
else in terms of loading in the browser
and that's not going to be good for SEO
okay optimize your code what do you mean
by optimize minifying when we see
mimifying we mean get rid of some of the
Redundant code if you have CSS you know
get rid of chop some of the get rid of
the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
readies redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's never going to bode
well and it's going to slow things down
as well enable browser caching so if you
enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably going to see a cache version of
that page and then off for the content
delivery Network as well so these are
some of the ways to reduce page speed
now if you're curious about the page
speed of your website site you can
always go to Google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just Google page speed insights or even
just something generic like Google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a URL when you plug
in the URL Google is going to analyze
the URL for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see Google gives a
score so we could see the score from low
ball and we can see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here I could see some of the issues
that the site may be having in terms of
page load time for their desktop if I
flip over to mobile you know here I can
see some other issues for example they
have a server static assets with
efficient cash policy now if you're not
sure what the heck that means you can
always just click on it and you can see
some specifics here and where you can
just always Google it as well uh here
you got to reduce the impact of
third-party code okay so that's another
thing uh reduce JavaScript execution
time so again going back to a lot of
some of the comments we made about
coding okay some sometimes too much code
or code not functioning as well as it
should we'll tend to slow down the site
okay so you can use page bin insights
you can always get a glimpse of how
pages are loading simply by also going
to for example Google analytics under
Behavior okay you can go to site speed
and if you click on overview okay Google
what Google does is they do a sampling
of pages over time and in this case
based on 89 Page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific Pages
load or your site overall simply by
looking at the site speed overview
report in Google analytics to get a
sense of how quick your pages are
loading now there's certain factors that
do a effect load time so obviously the
way the page is built with the code the
images Etc but also the browser each
browser loads differently okay so you
want to take a look at it by browser
also by country every country has a
different network and you can be in the
United States and have worse network
service than you do say in you know
Ivory Coast in Africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and Google analytics
you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast and which ones do and maybe
hone in on the pages that aren't loading
fast and address those pages first okay
so you have two tools at your disposal
one Google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual Target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so remember short
tail are usually one to two key words
very Broad in nature long tail keywords
or maybe three four keywords in a query
or maybe an entire sentence those are
considered long tail keywords so usually
short tail keywords have higher volume
but also higher competition longer tail
keywords usually have lower uh volume
but also lower competition but the great
thing about long tail keywords the
conversion rate will tend to be a little
bit higher than say a short tail because
it's less vague and more specific so you
can use short tail keywords if you're
trying to drive a lot of visitors
because those keywords are going to be
vague or Broad in nature long tail
keywords are used for targeted Pages
such as product pages and articles so if
you have a specific product with a long
name you can certainly optimize that
page for that product name again the
product name may have low volume but if
somebody types in exactly that product
name you show up the chance of you them
converting are going to be very high so
you don't have to always be that
specific at the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just honed in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care of a lot about the traffic
you just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are they Port elements to
focus while developing a website so
we're talking in terms of SEO okay so if
somebody asks me this question in an
interview what am I going to focus on
while developing a website well the
answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be indexed with Google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple URL structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and need okay if you have five
products okay maybe you have uh in your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat and easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for Google but
if complicated for the end users
probably going to be complicated for
Google you always want to create a site
map now what is that sitemap a site map
is simply just a formatted file with two
that includes all your URLs and assets
your images and your videos they're
going to be sitting on your server as
well so you want Google or these these
Bots to be able to find your pages and
assets and by the way you want to take
it a step further and make sure you
upload that site map which is sitting in
the root directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
site map and make sure you input that
site map location in Google search
console that way Google search console
has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all A robot's text file is
it's like a lock I always say to a house
so if you lock a door in your house
nobody's going to be able to get in that
door so it's all a robots text file is
you're telling Google and these other
Bots that are coming to to crawl your
site what's locked and what's not locked
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to non-index
specific pages of your website because
if you tell Google don't crawl these
Pages or this directory they're not
going to get crawled if they don't get
crawled they're not going to get indexed
so robot's text file is an important
element to focus on while you're
developing your website and why you're
developing your website it could be on a
you know in a directory just called new
website so you probably want to have new
website as the directory in the robots
text file and just to let Google know
don't go into this directory because
it's my new website I'm not ready to go
live yet so you don't want it indexed so
there are a lot of reasons to have
robots text files that's the main reason
sitemap you want Google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you want
to make sure that your side texture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when I say content I don't necessarily
just mean words I also mean videos I
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if an end user finds your site
engaging Google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just a quick recap here
it's important to have a better site
structure so the Bots can easily access
into next content okay with a responsive
design helps to make your website mobile
friendly and user friendly would also
increase the amount of time a user
spends on your website which may improve
your site's ranking sitemap is simply
just a file that helps search engine
Bots to understand the structure of the
website okay how many pages are on your
website and where they located along
with the videos and images okay and then
the robots text just instructs the
search engine crawlers to understand
what pages should not be indexed okay
this is simply just a text file and it's
added to the root directory again think
like a door think of a lock okay you can
tell you can lock whatever doors you
want in your house
so now it's time to wrap up our Advanced
digital marketing course for 2023 we try
to cover everything necessary for you to
start your digital marketing career
confidently in case if you have any
questions about any of the topics scored
in this course please let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
thanks for watching until next time stay
safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign